COME TO ORDER IN RESPONSE TO
THE COVERED NINETEEN EMERGENCY
AND TO PROTECT THE REPUBLIC
THE- PUBLIC LEGISLATORS AND
EMPLOYEES WE MUST LIMIT
NONESSENTIAL GATHERINGS AND IT
HERE TO SOCIAL DISTANCING MPAS
COVERING GUIDELINES AND
COMPLIANCE WITH THOSE ORDERS
THE SENATE HAS MADE NECESSARY
ADJUSTMENTS TO NORMAL
PRACTICES. IN ORDER TO ENSURE
THAT THE PUBLIC CONTINUES TO
HAVE ACCESS TO THE LEGISLATIVE
PROCESS WE'RE HOLDING OUR
COMMITTEE HEARINGS HERE IN
CAPITAL ROOM FORTY TWO A THREE
WHAT NONE OF OUR COMMITTEE
MEMBERS PARTICIPATING REMOTELY.
AND REPORTING CHAU THREE WITH
ME OUR SENATORS CORTESE DOLLY
GLAZER MCGUIRE MITCHELL BROKE
AND PAN. TO ALLOW THE PUBLIC
ACCESS WE HAVE ADMITTED MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC TO TWO HEARING
ROOMS TO THE EXTENT THAT SOCIAL
DISTINCT INSERTING REQUIREMENTS
ALLOW AND WE WILL BE USING A
TELECONFERENCE SERVICE FOR
THOSE INDIVIDUALS WHO WISH TO
TESTIFY TODAY. FOR INDIVIDUALS
WISHING TO PROVIDE PUBLIC
COMMENT THE PARTICIPANT TOLL
FREE NUMBER AND ACCESS CODE IS
POSTED ON OUR COMMITTEE WEBSITE
IT WILL BE MADE ON THE SCREEN
AND I WILL ANNOUNCE IT NOW.
TODAY'S PARTICIPANT NUMBER IS
EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN SIX NINE TWO.
EIGHT NINE FIVE THREE AND THE
ACCESS CODE IS. SEVEN ZERO FIVE
SIX NINE ZERO NINE FOR DETAILED
INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW THE
TELECONFERENCES TO MARKS PLEASE
REFER. TO THE SENATE AND OR
COMMITTEE WEBSITE. WHEN WE
MOVED TO PUBLIC YOU'LL BE
PROMPTED BY A MODERATOR TO DIAL
ONE AND ZERO FOR SUPPORT AND
OPPOSITION. PLEASE PRESS IS
ONLY ONE TIME AND WAIT
PATIENTLY FOR AN OPERATOR TO
ASSIGN YOU A LINE NUMBER THIS
CAN BE A SHORT WAIT. WHAT YOU
RECEIVE YOUR LINE NUMBER YOU'LL
WAIT IN THE QUEUE FOR THE
MODERATOR TO CALL YOUR LINE
NUMBER. AT THAT TIME YOU'LL BE
ON MUTED AND YOU'RE NOW READY
TO ADDRESS THE COMMITTEE.
PLEASE NOTE THAT IN ORDER FOR
US TO HEAR YOU CLEARLY AND TO
AVOID ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK. YOU
MUST MEET THE DEVICE YOU'RE
WATCHING ON. AND PRIOR TO
GIVING TESTIMONY OVER THE
PHONE. IT IS IMPORTANT THAT WE
HEAR FROM YOU AND WE THANK YOU
FOR YOUR PATIENCE. I WILL
MAINTAIN DECORUM DURING THE
HEARING AS IS CUSTOMARY. IN ANY
INDIVIDUAL WHO IS DISRUPTIVE
MAY BE REMOVED FROM THE REMOTE
MEETING SERVICE OR HAVE THEIR
CONNECTIONS MUTED. WHILE EVERY
EFFORT HAS BEEN MADE TO
STREAMLINE THE HEARING PROCESS
AND CONDUCTOR HEARINGS IN AS
CLOSE TO THE SAME MANNER AS IS
CUSTOMARY. THERE MAY BE SOME
LIKE TIMES FOR PARTICIPANTS WHO
ARE ADJUSTING TO THE NEW USE.
OF ONLINE TOOLS OR
TECHNOLOGIES. PLEASE BE
RESPECTFUL AND PATIENT SO ALL
INTERESTED PARTIES MAY BE
HEARD. TODAY IS OUR LAST
REGULARLY SCHEDULED HEARING
ALWAYS GOES BY SO QUICKLY. WE
HAVE THIRTEEN BILLS ON TODAY'S
AGENDA. FOR BILLS ARE ON
CONSENT. THE BILLS ON CONSENT
OUR- ITEM NUMBER SEVEN AB FIVE
NINETY NINE. ITEM TEN A. B.
ELEVEN TWELVE. ITEM ELEVEN AB
THIRTEEN TWENTY SIX AND ITEM
TWELVE A. B. THIRTEEN SEVENTY
SEVEN. BEFORE WE HEAR
PRESENTATION OF BILLS LET'S
ESTABLISH THE QUORUM MADAM
CONSULTANT PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. SENATOR LEYVA HERE LEYVA
HERE PHOTO ABOVE HERE PHOTOBOOK
HERE COURTESY. COURTESY HERE
DALLY. SENATOR DELHI HERE DAILY
HERE GLAZER. MCGUIRE PAN AM
HERE CALIFORNIA THANK YOU VERY
MUCH A QUORUM HAS BEEN
ESTABLISHED MEMBERS I WOULD
LIKE TO TAKE UP THE CONSENT
CALENDAR AT THIS TIME. DO WE
HAVE A MOTION. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH SENATOR- BUT CHAO ABODE
HAS MOVED THE CONSENT CALENDAR
AMERICAN SOUL PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. CONSENT SENATOR LEYVA. HI
LEYVA HI OF TROUBLE BUG.
CONTROLLABLE GUY CORTESE.
COURTESY I DALLY DALLY I GLAZE
MCGUIRE PAN HI AN HIGH WE WILL
LEAVE THE CONSENT CALENDAR OPEN
FOR ABSENT MEMBERS TO VOTE
MEMBERS WE'RE GOING TO MOVE TO
OUR FIRST BILL WHICH IS FILE
ITEM ONE AB ONE OH ONE FROM
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MEDINA ASSEMBLY
MEMBER PLEASE STEP FORWARD AND
BEGIN WHEN YOU'RE READY. THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS. I
AM PLEASED TO PRESENT AB ONE OH
ONE. AB ONE OH ONE WOULD MAKE A
ONE SEMESTER COURSE IN ETHNIC
STUDIES A HIGH SCHOOL
GRADUATION REQUIREMENT
COMMENCING WITH PUPILS
GRADUATING IN THE TWENTY TWENTY
NINE. TWENTY THIRTY SCHOOL YEAR.
THIS SUMMER WE ARE WITNESSING A
RECKONING REGARDING THE FUTURE
OF EDUCATION. SCHOOL DISTRICTS
COMMUNITIES AND STATE
LEGISLATURES ACROSS THE UNITED
STATES ARE GRAPPLING WITH THE
VERY DIFFICULT AND OFTEN
EMOTIONAL TOPIC THE CONCERNS
HOW WE VIEW AND PORTRAY
OURSELVES AS A NATION. BECAUSE
OF THE PROTESTS AND OUTCRY THE
pFOLLOWED THE MURDER OF GEORGE
FLOYD ONE YEAR AGO. WE ARE IN A
MOMENT OF HISTORY NOT UNLIKE
THAT OF NINETEEN FIFTY FIVE
WHEN THE MURDER OF EMMETT TEEL.
HELPED USHER IN THE CIVIL
RIGHTS MOVEMENT OF THE NINETEEN
SIXTIES. TODAY SCHOOLS OF
EDUCATION ACROSS THE COUNTRY
COLUMBIA'S TEACHERS COLLEGE TO
UC SANTA BARBARA UC DAVIS UC
RIVERSIDE AND SACRAMENTO STATE
UNIVERSITY ARE REIMAGINING
TEACHER PREPARATION TO BETTER
PREPARE FUTURE TEACHERS TO MORE
EQUITABLY MEET THE INTELLECTUAL
AND EMOTIONAL NEEDS OF AN
INCREASINGLY DIVERSE GROUP OF
STUDENTS IN OUR SCHOOLS AND
CLASSROOMS. AS STUDIES LIKE THE
ONE DONE AT STANFORD UNIVERSITY
HAVE DEMONSTRATED ALL STUDENTS
DO BETTER ACADEMICALLY AND
ATTENDANCE IMPROVES WHEN
STUDENTS ARE GIVEN THE
OPPORTUNITY TO TAKE AN ETHNIC
STUDIES CLASS. LET US LISTEN TO
THE VOICES OF THE TWENTY
THOUSAND STUDENTS HIGH SCHOOL
STUDENT WHO SIGNED THE PETITION
CALLING FOR ETHNIC STUDIES
BECAUSE THEY WANT TO SEE
THEMSELVES REFLECTED IN THE
CURRICULUM. CALIFORNIA HAS
ALWAYS BEEN A LEADER IN
EDUCATION LET US NOW CONTINUE
THE TO BLAZE THE TRAIL FOR FULL
EDUCATIONAL EQUITY AND
INCLUSION. WHEN THE TIME COMES
I WILL RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR
AYE VOTE ON A. B. ONE A ONE. ON
THE LINE TODAY ON BEHALF OF AB
ONE OR ONE. DR ALBERT COMMITTEE
ON. THE LEON SLOSS MEMORIAL
PROFESSOR AND PROFESSOR OF
HISTORY EMERITUS AT STANFORD
UNIVERSITY. AND ALVIN LEE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF
GENERATION UP. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
WE WILL NOW GO TO YOUR LEAD
SUPPORT WITNESSES BUFFER
COMMITTEE- IF YOU WERE ON THE
LINE PLEASE PROCEED YOU HAVE
TWO MINUTES AND MR ALVIN LEE
WILL ALSO HAVE TWO MINUTES.
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
TO BRIEFLY SHARE A FEW COMMENTS
WITH YOU. IN SUPPORT OF AB ONE
OH ONE. I FOLLOW THE PATH OF
THIS PROPOSED LEGISLATION FOR
MANY YEARS. AND I MUST SAY UP
FRONT I AM A STRONG SUPPORTER
OF AB ONE OH ONE BUT NOT FOR
POLITICAL REASONS BUT FOR SOUND
PEDAGOGICAL AND INTELLECTUAL
REASONS. IN ADDITION AND
PERHAPS MOST IMPORTANTLY FOR ME
PERSONALLY BUT FRIDAY I KNOW
FOR SO MANY CALIFORNIANS I
SUPPORT THIS PROPOSED
LEGISLATION BECAUSE AS A
CITIZEN WHO IS DEEPLY
CONCERNED. ABOUT ETHNIC AND
RACE RELATIONS IN OUR STATE AND
NATION. I CONFIDENTLY BELIEVE
THAT ETHNIC STUDIES CURRICULUM
COMPLAIN IMPORTANT POSITIVE
ROLE IN HELPING OUR STUDENTS
UNDERSTAND AND APPRECIATE THE
DIVERSITY THAT DEFINES SO MUCH
OF CALIFORNIA AND AMERICAN
SOCIETY. I HAVE PREVIOUSLY
ENDORSES LEGISLATION BEFORE THE
EDUCATION COMMITTEE OF ASSEMBLY
AND THE STATE BOARD OF
EDUCATION AS A CONSIDERED
ADOPTING THE ETHNIC STUDIES
MODEL CURRICULUM. THREE THERE
ARE MANY COMPELLING REASONS TO
ENDORSE AB ONE OH ONE AND I
MENTIONED THREE HERE. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER DATA REFERENCE THIS BILL
BUT ALL ALL GO OVER JUST VERY
BRIEFLY THE RESEARCH CONDUCTED
OVER THE LAST TWO DECADES ON
THE EFFICACY OF WHAT IS MORE
BROADLY TERMED CULTURALLY
RELEVANT PEDAGOGY. CONCLUDE
THAT SUCH CURRICULUM
CONSISTENTLY HAS POSITIVE
OUTCOMES FOR STUDENTS OF COLOR
AND STUDENTS IN GENERAL. THOUGH
MOST OF THIS RESEARCH IS
QUALITATIVE AND MASTER MORE
RECENT QUANTITATIVE MASSES OF
FINDINGS BASED ON RESEARCH
CONDUCTED IN SAN FRANCISCO
SCHOOLS THAT PILOTED ETHNIC
STUDIES COURSES FOUND
SIGNIFICANT INCREASES IN DAILY
ATTENDANCE. GRADE POINT AVERAGE
AND COMPLETION OF COURSE CREDIT
ESPECIALLY FOR HOLDING COURT AT
RISK STUDENTS WHO ENROLLED IN
THESE COURSES. I COULD
PERSONALLY SUPPORT THESE
FINDINGS BASED ON MY PILOT
PROJECTS OVER THE PAST TEN
YEARS WORKING WITH HISTORY
TEACHERS TO INSTITUTE ETHNIC
STUDIES CURRICULUM AT TO
CHARTER HIGH SCHOOLS IN THE SAN
FRANCISCO BAY AREA EAST PALO
ALTO ACADEMY HIGH AND THE LUIS
VALDEZ LEADERSHIP ACADEMY IN
SAN JOSE. I CAN ATTEST THAT
STUDENTS WHO ENROLLED IN OUR
ETHNIC STUDIES CURRICULUM AT
BOTH SCHOOLS WERE MORE
INTELLECTUALLY ENGAGE MORE
MOTIVATED TO LEARN AND MUCH
MORE COLLEGE READY THAN THEIR
PEERS. WHO DID NOT ENROLL IN
THESE COURSES. I DON'T THINK
STUDIES CORE RECALL NOW ASSUME
BULLET TO SOLVE. INCREASINGLY
TENSE RACE RELATIONS IN
CALIFORNIA DR CARILLO YOU ARE
EATING AND- I WILL STUDENTS IN
THE HAS GREATER AND MORE
APPRECIATION FOR ETHNICALLY AND
RACIALLY DIVERSE SOCIETY THANK
YOU AGAIN FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
TO SHARE MY COMMENTS WITH YOU
THIS MORNING. THANK YOU SIR
OKAY WE'RE GONNA GO TO YOUR
NEXT WITNESS- MISTER ALVIN LEE
YOU HAVE A LITTLE UNDER TWO
MINUTES PLEASE PROCEED. HI ALL
MY NAME IS ALVIN WEEK IT IS
PRONOUN AND DETECTIVE DIRECTOR
IF YOU QUIT ORGANIZATION UP.
TENS OF THOUSANDS OF STUDENTS
ACROSS CALIFORNIA
THAT HE'S DOWN CALIFORNIANS SIX
POINT THREE MILLION HIGH SCHOOL
STUDENTS EACH WITH THEIR OWN
EXPERIENCE TO TELL THEIR OWN
STORIES TO SHARE. I LEARNED
FROM SELECTED WATER DOWN
HISTORY CURRICULUM DOES VERY
EUROCENTRIC WHITE FOCUSED
PAINTED MANY COLONIZERS AS
HEROES I DIDN'T LEARN ABOUT THE
MANY ASIAN LATIN ACCEDER
AMERICAN BLACK LEADERS THAT
HELPED SHAPE AMERICA INTO WHAT
IT WAS TODAY. OVER THE SUMMER
GEN UP INTEGRITY FIRE NATICK
WAS PROUD TO LEAD THE U. CHART
ON PASSING AB TWO THREE ONE
THROUGH THE SENATE IN THE SPAN
OF OVER A WEEK OUR PETITION
URGING THE LEGISLATURE TO
POSSIBLY BE KEEPING ONE
THOUSAND MORE THAN TWENTY SIX
THOUSAND SIGNATURES FROM
STUDENTS. EDUCATORS AND PARENTS
ACROSS CALIFORNIA. BETTER
UNDERSTANDING OUR PEERS POACHER
CARE KITCHEN MYSTERY IT'S A
GOOD START TO DISMANTLING
STEREOTYPES AND IMPLICIT BIAS.
REWRITING THE HISTORY
CURRICULUM SO MORE QUESTIONS TO
EXTEND REPRESENTS ALL THE
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR THAT WORK
TO BUILD AMERICA INTO WHAT IT
IS TODAY IS IMPERATIVE.
CALIFORNIA'S EDUCATION SYSTEM
CAN DO BETTER FOR THEIR
STUDENTS AND WE MUST CALIFORNIA
NOW HAVE HUGE AND UNIQUE
OPPORTUNITY TO LEAD BY EXAMPLE
AND SHOW THE COUNTRY WHAT
CREATING A MORE INCLUSIVE AND
DIVERSE FUTURE THROUGH
EDUCATION LOOK LIKE. NOW THE
TIME TO ACT ON BEHALF OF ALL
CALIFORNIA STUDENTS. WE NEED TO
ACT WITHOUT IGNORANCE AND LEAD
WITH COURAGE IN A DIERSE
INCLUSIVE AND POSITIVE VISION
FOR THE FUTURE. THAT IS WHY THE
CALIFORNIA STUDENT I'M STRONGLY
URGING MEMBERS OF THE SENATE
EDUCATION COMMITTEE TO VOTE I
AB ONE OR ONE THANK YOU. THANK
YOU BEFORE WE MOVE TO WITNESS
SINCE THE SUPPORT HERE ASSEMBLY
MEN. YOU ARE TAKING THEM AND
THAT'S CORRECT. THE TECHNICAL
MEN. PERFECT THANK YOU SIR ALL
RIGHT WE'LL GO TO. HEARING ROOM
FOR TWO- TO PLEASE YOUR NAME
ARE GOING. AND SO. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIRMAN JEFF WALKER
REPRESENTING RIVER SO COUNTY.
OF SCHOOLS AND THE THREE SCHOOL
TO DIFFERENT. AND RIVER COUNTY
AND STRONG SUPPORT GREAT THANK
YOU SIR ANYONE ELSE SEEING NO
ONE WILL GO TO OUR OVERFLOW
ROOM. SEEING A ONE THERE WILL
NOW GO TO THE PHONE LINES OF
MODERATOR FUEL QUEUE OF ANYONE
WHO WISHES TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
OF AB ONE OH ONE PLEASE. THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OF AB ONE OH ONE
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO. AN
OPERATOR WILL PROVIDE YOU WITH
MY NUMBER AND PLACE YOU BACK
INTO Q. ONCE AGAIN IF YOU WISH
TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT. OF AB ONE
OH ONE PLEASE PRESS ONE BUTTON
ZERO NOW. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
MY NUMBER TEN THE LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
MADAM CHAIR MY NAME IS SETH
BRAMBLE THEN I'M SPEAKING TODAY
ON BEHALF OF MORE THAN THREE
HUNDRED THOUSAND EDUCATORS THE
MEMBERS OF THE CALIFORNIA
TEACHERS ASSOCIATION WE ARE
VERY PROUD TO CO SPONSOR.
ASSEMBLY BILL ONE ZERO ONE WE
THANK ASSEMBLYMEMBER MEDINA FOR
HIS LEADERSHIP AND URGE YOUR
AYE VOTE. LINE NUMBER THIRTY
FOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MY NAME IS KIMBERLY WILL
I'M IN A UC BERKELEY AND I
REMEMBER CHEN UP AND I STRONG
AB ONE OH ONE THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. LINE NUMBER TWENTY FIVE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING ERICA
MERRILL ON BEHALF OF THE
HISPANIC ASSOCIATION OF
COLLEGES AND UNIVERSITIES
CALLING IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK
YOU THANK YOU. LINE NUMBER
FORTY SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
PERFECT GONZALEZ NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORKERS
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER IN SUPPORT.
MY NUMBER SIXTY SIX YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MORNING SHARON MEMBERS GREGORY
KRAMER ON BEHALF OF DISABILITY
RIGHTS CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT.
LINE NUMBER SEVENTY YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING MY NAME IS LEO COURSE
OF CLARK I'M A RECENT GRADUATE
OF ALBANY HIGH SCHOOL IN ALBANY
CALIFORNIA AND A MEMBER. OF
CHEN UP IN ON BEHALF WHICH
ENOUGH WE STRONGLY SUPPORT THE
L. MY NUMBER TWENTY THREE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO MY NAME IS ELECTION
MANAGEMENT COULD NOT DAMPEN
UNIVERSITY AND PART OF
DIVERSIFYING OUR TECHNICIANS
ARE HISTORY COALITION AND I'M
ASKING YOU TO PLEASE STAND WITH
THE COURT EIGHTY ONE OH ONE.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. BY NUMBER
FIFTY ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
MY NAME IS KATHERINE SHARE I'M
A STUDENT IN THE COMMUNITY
VALLEY UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT
NINE IN STRNG SUPPORT OF AB
ONE OH ONE. LINE NUMBER SIXTY
EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME IS
MICHELLE OUR I AM A MEMBER OF
NOT BEEN A CONSTITUENT AND
SENATOR GRANGER AND ONE. SEVEN
AND I AM STRONGLY IN SUPPORT OF
AB ONE AT ONE. PRIME NUMBER
FIFTY SEVEN THE LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY NUMBER
FIFTY SEVEN MAY BE ON YOU YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. MY NUMBER SEVENTY
TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING THIS IS MY
NORDBAHN HOSPITAL WITH
CALIFORNIA'S TOGETHER CALLING
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF AB ONE OH
ONE. NUMBER THIRTY ONE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HI MY NAME IS ASIA NINE STUDENT
NEAR COSTA HIGH SCHOOL AND I'M
A STUDENT WITH THE TEACHER
HISTORY COALITION NINE STRONGLY
IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL. MY
NUMBER SIXTY THREE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING TAT THE PENTAGON
WATCHING WHAT THE SAN DIEGO
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT AND
WEREN'T STRONG SUPPORT THANK
YOU. LIE NUMBER SEVENTY EIGHT
THE LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING MAIN DRAW
ON THE APPALACHIAN FOR THE CORE
OF THE BILL. AND AT THIS TIME
ADAM HERE WE HAVE NO ONE ELSE
CAN QUEUE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
PANAMA REITER WE WILL NOW MOVE
TO OPPOSITION WE HAVE TO FOCUS
AND LEAD OPPOSITION TAMMI
ROSSMAN BENJAMIN AND DOCTOR
WHO- MISS BENJAMIN PLEASE
PROCEED WHEN YOU'RE READY. YOU
HAVE TWO MINUTES. GOOD MORNING
I'M CAN BE LOST IN BENJAMIN
DIRECTOR OF. INITIATIVE A
NONPROFIT THAT DOCUMENTING
DESICCATED PANTAI SEMITISM IN
EDUCATION. TODAY I'M ALSO
REPRESENTING SIXTY
ORGANIZATIONS AND THOUSAND
MEMBERS AND SUPPORTERS OF THE
CALIFORNIA JEWISH COMMUNITY.
WE'RE DEEPLY CONCERNED ABOUT
EIGHTY ONE NO ONE. CAN BE
ENORMOUSLY HARMFUL IMPACT WE
BELIEVE IT WILL HAVE ON JEWISH
STUDENTS. ALTHOUGH THE BILL
RECOMMENDS THAT SCHOOL
DISTRICTS ADOPT THE S. B. E.
APPROVED MODEL CURRICULUM. AS
TO CASES FOR THE REQUIRED
COURSES IT ALSO ALLOWS FOR THE
USE OF ANY CURRICULUM APPROVED
BY A SCHOOL DISTRICT EVEN THE
REJECTED OVERTLY ANTI SEMITIC
FIRST DRAFT. OUTRAGE THE JEWISH
COMMUNITY OF LEGISLATIVE JEWISH
CAUCUS AND THE GOVERNOR. I
WOULD FOR ORGANIZATIONS HAVE
PROVIDED YOU WITH COMPELLING
EVIDENCE. TO REJECTED FIRST
DRAFT OR ANYTHING MORE EXTREME
VERSION WILL LIKELY BE TALKED
TO AND IMPLEMENTED BY MOST
SCHOOL DISTRICTS. IF THE BILL
BECOMES LAW. THE ORIGINAL
AUTHOR SAID THAT PERHAPS I CAN
CARRYING OUT A SUCCESSFUL
CAMPAIGN. TO PROMOTE THEIR
CURRICULUM INCLUDING ANTI
JEWISH AND ANTI COMMUNIST
QUESTIONS THROUGHOUT. THE STATE.
COURT ON THE COMPUTER TEACHERS
UNION AND FROM THE STATE REJECT.
STUDIES PEOPLE ALSO FEATURES
THREE INDIVIDUAL SCHOOL TO. AND
SUCH AS UNIFIED RECEIVED TO THE.
THE ONENOTE ONE NO ONE BECOME
LAW WE LAW SCHOOL TO. WILL
FOLLOW SUIT. HOW IT'S GOING A
MIDDLE IS GOING ON INTO ATTACK
FROM ALL OVER THE WORLD
INCLUDING INTEL. WE BELIEVE A
PEAK WHEN A LOT DIRECTLY. THE
AND WELL OF JEWISH TO IN OUR
STATE. WE URGE YOU TO GO NO ON
THE BILL. YOU DOCTOR WILL YOU
HAVE TO MINUTES. YES CAN
BECAUSE WHEN WARM EXECUTIVE
GIVE OF COUNTY FOR WILL RIGHT
ON THE THANK YOU FOR THE OPTION
TO SPEAK MY GROUP REPRESENT A
GLOW BAG ONLINE UP AT. THERE
CAN. ABOUT TWENTY HUNDRED
ORGANIZATIONS ARE AB ONE WAY
THEY ACTUALLY MAIN REASON WHY
I'LL- STRONGLY OPPOSES THE BILL.
IT IS YOU CAN MAKE INCLUDING
FOR THE EXACT NATURE TO PASS
THE TAX PAYER FUNDED MANDATE ON
ETHNIC STUDIES ONE TENSION
AGREEMENTS AMONG THE FINAL
STATE APPROVED MODEL CURRICULUM
IS. NOT CHANGED I DOUBT COSTS
LIKE A COULD PEDAGOGY MORE
IMPORTANTLY THAT BUT NEEDED
SCHOOL DISTRICTS HAVE ADOPTED
DIRECTLY TO DOOR THE FIRST
REJECT MARC SECOND WAS WIDELY
WHICH GAP IN THE I'LL COME
DISPARITIES CALIFORNIA'S. HE TO
TWELVE EDUCATION. HOME PRICES
EQUITY CRISIS THE BILL WOULD
SURELY DIE IN HAS HEAVY I TAG
BUT IF THE PACKAGE. ALL OF THE
PUBLIC EDUCATION HAVE. LET ME
OFF OF ON THE FACT THAT ONE
HUNDRED FORTY MONTHS. AND. A
POSSIBLE ECONOMIC BENEFITS OF
ETHNIC STUDIES. WHAT BUT NOT
LEAST SHOULD YOU HAVE DONE A
CRITICAL COME. EIGHT EIGHT
EIGHT- WE SHOULD VISION AND
ENACTED AT WITH FUNDAMENTALLY
BY THE FOURTEENTH AMENDMENT TO
THE COMPETITION POLICY COMPANY
OF. WHAT IN A PACK RAT IN
DISCRIMINATION NOT AT FEDERAL
LEVEL. THANK YOU DOCTOR WILL.
WE WILL NOW GO TO ANYONE HERE
IN ROOM FORTY TWO- THREE WISHES
TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE WE WILL GO TO THE
OVERFLOW ROOM SEEING NO ONE
WILL NOW GO TO THE PHONE LINES
WE GAVE FIVE MINUTES INTO THE
SUPPORT SO WE WILL GIVE FIVE
MINUTES TO OPPOSITION. MADAM
MODERATOR IF YOU WILL CHAIRED
BY. IF THE WHOLE QUEUE UP
ANYONE WHO'S IN OPPOSITION OF
AB ONE OH ONE PLEASE. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IFYOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION OF AB ONE OH ONE
BECAUSE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AN
OPERATOR WILL PROVIDE YOU WITH
ONLINE NUMBER AND PUT YOU BACK
INTO Q. ONCE AGAIN IF YOU WISH
TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION. OF AB
ONE OH ONE PLEASE PRESS ONE
BEEN THERE- NOW. WELL MY
MANAGER WE HAVE PEOPLE QUEUING
UP NOW THANK YOU. WE'LL START
WITH LINE NUMBER SEVENTY SIX
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU PENNY
HARRINGTON PARENT GRANDPARENT
AND LEGISLATIVE ANALYST FROM
SAN DIEGO COUNTY IN OPPOSITION.
MY NUMBER EIGHTY FIVE THE LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI I'M
TRYING TO DO WITH THE PHYSICIAN
CALPERS SCHOOL ADMINISTRATORS
WITH THE SUPPORT AND THEN IT
MISSION RESPECTFULLY REQUESTING
THE CARTER AND LANGUAGE THE
REMOVED INSURE IMPLEMENTATION
OFTEN WITH THIS NAME IN
OPPOSITION PLEASE. LINE NUMBER
TWENTY SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES GOOD
MORNING- MADAM CHAIRMAN AND
SENATE EDUCATION COMMITTEE
MEMBERS. MY NAME IS JOE
WILLIAMS FROM MARINA CALIFORNIA
AND I STRONGLY URGE YOU TO VOTE
NO ON EIGHTY ONE OF ONE. OF THE
FOLLOWING REAL WORLD THANK
GENERATIONS TO THIS NEXT CALLER
BILL. LINE NUMBER SIXTEEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MY NAME'S JERRY FERRARI I LIVE
IN SIGNAL AND SENATOR GLAZERS
DISTRICT I BELONG TO A GROUP
LARGE GROUP OF GRASSROOTS
VOLUNTEERS AND I OPPOSE AB ONE
OH ONE. BY NUMBER TWENTY TWO
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MY NAME IS LINDA WAGNER
AND I'M AN ORANGE COUNTY. AND I
WANT. ONE MY NUMBER THIRTY TWO
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. BACCARA CLOTURE. A LOT
CALIFORNIA GRADUATE AT THE TOP
OF A UNIVERSITY AND A FATHER OF
FOUR. IF YOU WANT TO WATCH.
LINE NUMBER THIRTY SIXTY LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING MY NAME IS AMY GRAY
WHERE I LIVE IN LOS ANGELES AND
I PUT AB. ONE OH ONE. MY NUMBER
FOURTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
MY NAME IS JULIE NORTON I'M A
PARENT OF FOUR FOUR CHILDREN-
WE DO NOT SUPPORT AB ONE OH ONE
OR AB ONE ZERO FOUR ZERO- THANK
YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE IN. SO I
NUMBER FORTY THE LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY NAME IS
COLLEEN JO HANSON FROM TURLOCK
CALIFORNIA I'M AN EDUCATOR AND
FORMER TEACHER AND GRANDMOTHER
OF SIX CHILDREN I WOULD
STRONGLY OPPOSE AB. ONE OH ONE.
LINE NUMBER FORTY FIVE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS GOING
TO ALLOW I AM A FORMER TEACHER
AND NINE PRESIDENT EAGLE FORUM
HAVE CALIFORNIA. ALL OF OUR
MEMBERS ACROSS THE STATE
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL ASK
THE SENATE TO PLEASE VOTE
AGAINST IT. MY NUMBER FIFTY
THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. MY NAME IS DAVID
CAMPBELL I AM A CALIFORNIA HIGH
SCHOOL TEACHER AND ON BEHALF OF
THE TEACHES IT AS SOCIALLY WITH
WE STRONGLY OPPOSE- AB ONE ON
ONE WITH THE MARXIST IDEOLOGY.
LINE NUMBER TWENTY NINE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
IF OF AGE I THINK IN OPPOSITION
AB. ONE ONE. LINE NUMBER
SEVENTY FIVE THE LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME
IS KURT CRAWFORD I'M A LIFETIME
CALIFORNIA RESIDENT AND- I AM
STRONGLY OPPOSED AB ONE ON ONE
AND ONE OH FOR- THANK YOU
THANK. LINE NUMBER EIGHTY NINE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. BECAUSE YOU GREG BURKE
WITH A CALIFORNIA FAMILY
COUNCIL AND STRONG OPPOSITION
THEY CAN. THANK YOU. BLIND
NUMBER SEVENTY THREE THE LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. THIS
IS TONY AROUND BALLOTS WITH
CAPITOL RESOURCE INSTITUTE IN
OPPOSITION TO AB ONE OH ONE. MY
NUMBER FOURTEEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES THIS
IS JULIE NORTON I REPRESENT
WHAT TELL ME TO UNION AND
SCHOOL DISTRICT WE'RE IN
OPPOSITION ALSO HUNTINGTON
BEACH NINE TWO SIX FOUR SIX. WE
ARE IN NOT FAVOR IN OPPOSITION
AT THAT ALSO THANK YOU NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. AND AT THIS TIME
AND I'M SURE THERE'S NO ONE
ELSE IN Q. THANK YOU MADAM
MODERATOR WILL BRING IT BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE DO YOU HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS COMMENTS CONCERNS
SENATOR CORTESE. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR IN IN THEM FINDING
MYSELF IN SUPPORT OF- OF THE
MEASURE RIGHT. I HAVE A
QUESTION I DON'T REALLY KNOW
WHO CAN BEST ADDRESS IT BUT AT
A DO THINK WE HEARD- FROM
POLICE ONE PERSON ON THE
OPPOSITION LINE- TALKING ABOUT-
THE HOLOCAUST REMEMBRANCE-
ISSUES END OTHERS CONCERNED
GOING FORWARD IN TERMS OF HOW
THE HEATER EDUCATION- COMMUNITY
ACTUALLY IMPLEMENTS- WHAT IS
THE RESPONSE TO THAT I JUST
WANNA MAKE SURE I MEAN I KNOW
OUR COMMITTEE. I GUESS THIS IS
THE PART WHERE I DON'T EXPECT
THE CHAIR TO ANSWER THIS BUT WE
ALL KNOW WE DON'T REALLY HAVE.
A CONTINUING JURISDICTION- SORT
OF DOWNSTREAM YOU KNOW IN TERMS
OF THAT KIND OF MONITORING
ALTHOUGH WE CAN CERTAINLY
ALWAYS. COME BACK WITH- YOU
KNOW SOME SORT OF ADJUSTMENTS
BUT BUT IN THE IN THE NEAR TERM
WHAT IS THE RESPONSE TO IN THE
REASSURANCE TO FOLKS THAT.
THAT- IT THAT THEIR CONCERNS
WILL BE WILL BE ADDRESSED- YOU
KNOW POTENTIALLY GIVEN AND THAT
THE AMOUNT OF AUTONOMY WITH
LOCAL JURISDICTIONS. THANK YOU
SENATOR DAISY FOR YOUR- FOR
YOUR QUESTION WHICH I THINK IS
AN IMPORTANT QUESTION AND ONE
THAT THAT IS CERTAINLY BEEN
DISCUSSED- THAT THAT I DO WANT
TO ADDRESS. AND AS YOU SAID AS
YOU RECOGNIZE- OUR SYSTEM OF
EDUCATION IN THE IN THIS
COUNTRY. RIGHT IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. IS- GIVES MUCH OF
THE CONTROL TO LOCAL FOLKS I
WAS A SCHOOL BOARD MEMBER I WAS
A COMMUNITY COLLEGE TRUSTEE AND
I'VE ALWAYS FELT THAT THAT IT
IS THE WAY IT SHOULD BE- OTHER
COUNTRIES HAVE A VERY DIFFERENT
FORM. OF EDUCATIONAL SYSTEM AB
COUNTRY LIKE MY JAPAN ARE VERY
MUCH MORE CENTRAL RIGHT WHERE
WE'RE MAYBE WHAT IS TAUGHT
THROUGHOUT THE COUNTRY MAYBE
VERY SIMILAR IF YOU WENT FROM
OR OR- IF YOU WENT A ONE SCHOOL
TO ANOTHER. BUT HERE WE-
BECAUSE WE ARE DEMOCRACY WE
INTENTIONALLY MAKE- EDUCATION-
OF THE FORM THAT THAT EVERYONE
CAN PARTICIPATE IN AND WE GIVE
UP PEOPLE AT THE LOCAL LEVEL
INPUT AND SO THAT IS HOW.
ETHNIC STUDY IS BEING
IMPLEMENTED IN THE PAST THREE
YEARS. AS YOU MAY KNOW READ THE
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION I CAME
UP WITH A MODEL CURRICULUM- IT
WENT THROUGH DIFFERENT
REVISIONS. MUCH MANY HEARINGS A
LOT OF PUBLIC INPUT- IT WAS A-
RE DONE. AND NOW THIS LAST
MARCH IT CAME OUT OF THE MODEL
CURRICULUM AS ESTABLISHED BY
THE STATE BOARD OF EDUCATION.
THAT MODEL CURRICULUM IS JUST
THAT IT IS A MODEL FOR LOCAL
SCHOOL BOARDS LOCAL SCHOOL
DISTRICTS TO USE AS THEY
IMPLEMENT ETHNIC STUDIES THERE
ARE TWENTY DISTRICTS ALREADY-
WHO ARE FOR. OR REQUIRED I
THINK STUDIES AS A AS A
GRADUATION REQUIREMENT. AND SO
WE SEE DISTRICTS THROUGHOUT THE
STATE. SOMETIMES HOTLY DEBATING
RIGHT WHAT FORM OF ETHNIC
STUDIES SHOULD TAKE. AND I
THINK THAT WE HEAR IN THE
LEGISLATURE NEED TO HAVE FAITH
IN THE SYSTEM THE THAT WE
CREATED IN A SYSTEM OF
EDUCATION. THAT WE HAVE- RELIED
ON AND THAT WORKS AND THAT AND
THAT IS PART TO HAVE FAITH ALSO
IN THE DEMOCRATIC- PROCESS THAT
IT IS THROUGH DISCUSSION. AND
THROUGH GIVE AND TAKE THAT- THE
BEST CATION I THINK IS ACHIEVED
AND I THINK THAT IS WHAT IS
GOING TO HAPPEN WITH THE ETHNIC
STUDIES. THAT SCHOOL DISTRICTS
I WAS A TEACHER FOR THIRTY FOUR
YEARS. A SCHOOL DISTRICTS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. WILL USE THE MODEL
CURRICULUM. TO FORM THEIR OWN
CURRICULUM IN IN THE SCHOOLS-
BASED ON THE MODEL CURRICULUM
BUT ALSO GIVEN THE LOCAL
HISTORY AND POPULATION AND I
THINK THAT MAKES SENSE YOU KNOW
WE SAY HERE MANY TIMES THAT ONE
SIZE DOESN'T FIT ALL AND I
BELIEVE THAT SO THE MODEL
CURRICULUM IS JUST THAT SCHOOL
DISTRICTS WILL USE IT. USE IT-
AS A MODEL TO MAKE A BEST FIT.
A LOCAL AREA. AND SOMETIMES A
DEMOCRAT DEMOCRATIC PROCESSES
IS MESSY. BUT WE SHOULD NOT SHY
AWAY FROM HAVING DIFFICULT
DISCUSSIONS BUT I THINK THAT IS
SORT OF VIA THE PROCESSES THAT
WILL WILL BE IMPLEMENTED
THROUGHOUT THE STATE OF
TEACHERS ARE GONNA BE TRAINING.
A TEACHING ETHNIC STUDIES-
WE'VE ALREADY SEEN MANY.
ALLOCATED IN THE IN THE BUDGET
FOR THAT. THANK YOU TO THE
AUTHOR AND JUST THROUGH THE
CHAIR I JUST WANNA SAY I HAVE
SOME OR SOME SIMILAR BACKGROUND
EXPERIENCE TO YOU IT IS A
SERVICE SUPPORT LOCAL CONTROL-
IS LOCALIZES POSSIBLE IN MOST
CASES I DO THINK THE CONCERNS
ARE- ARE ALWAYS VALID BILL IF.
YOUR FIRM DESPITE. YOU KNOW THE
BEST PHILOSOPHIES WILL CONTROL
SOMEBODY CROSSES A LINE YOU
KNOW WHAT GUARD RAILS ARE IN
PLACE TO BRING THEM BACK AND I
AM NOT ASKING YOU FOR AN
EXTENDD RESPONSE I JUST WANNA
MAKE SURE THAT- IF YOU LEASES
ONE COMMITTEE MEMBER HERE JUST
ONE SENATOR THAT. THE THOSE WHO
HAVE THOSE CONCERNS UNDERSTAND-
YOU KNOW THAT THAT THEY'RE
BEING HEARD IN THE THERE IS
THERE SOME SHARING OF THOSE
CONCERNS RELATIVE TO- YOU KNOW
MAKING SURE THAT. AGAIN OF
GUARD RAILS ARE IN PLACE
UNDERSTAND THE MODEL CURRICULUM
IS ONE OF THOSE- BUT AGAIN I
APPRECIATE YOUR RESPONSE AND
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR. THE
MANAGER OF YES PLEASE REFER TO
TWO COMMENTS ABSOLUTELY. THE
FIRST I DID HEAR THE OPPOSITION
RIGHT OTHER FOLKS WHO PRESENTED
IN AN OPPOSITION- I WANT TO
SHARE. THAT I HAVE TWO ADULT
CHILDREN- TWO ADULT CHILDREN
WHO WENT TO A CALIFORNIA PUBLIC
SCHOOLS BOTH OF THEM. BOTH MY
CHILDREN ARE JEWISH. AND THEN
MY SON UP WHEN HE WAS IN IN
SCHOOL HAD ANOTHER STUDENT DRAW
A SWASTIKA ON HIS BACKPACK
BECAUSE THAT STUDENT KNEW THAT
HE WAS JEWISH MY SON- SO GIVEN
THAT MY OWN EXPERIENCE. BUT TO
JEWISH CHILDREN I WOULD.
WOULDN'T BE STANDING HERE IN
FRONT OF THIS BODY ADVOCATING
FOR SOMETHING THAT I THOUGHT
WAS ANTI SEMITIC. THAT THAT WAS
ONE POINT I WANT TO MAKE IN THE
OTHER POINT IS THAT- THIS
LEGISLATION DOES HAVE
GUARDRAILS- PUT IN IN
COLLABORATION WITH THE JEWISH
CAUCUS THAT VERY MUCH US STATE
AND POINTS OUT THAT THERE WILL
BE NO INSTRUCTION THAT- IS.
PREJUDICIAL OR ANTI SEMITIC.
THANK YOU AGAIN MANAGER THANK
YOU VERY MUCH AND I WOULD JUST
SAY TO CENTER CORTESE'S POINT I
THINK THAT'S ALWAYS OUR CONCERN
WE CHANGE SOMETHING RIGHT THIS
WILL BE IMPLEMENTED IN THE
RIGHT WAY- I DO WANT TO THANK
THE AUTHOR HE'S WORKED IN
NATION SLEEP FOR MANY YEARS ON
THIS AND TRY TO ADDRESS EVERY
ISSUE FROM OPPOSITION AND- AND
DEMOCRACY CAN BE MESSY BUT
DOING THE RIGHT THING NEEDS TO
BE DONE US SENATOR PAN. I THANK
YOU I APOLOGIZE I'M TRYING
BOUNCE BETWEEN TWO COMMITTEES
HERE NO WORRIES- UT- SO FIRST
OF ALL- SUMMER MEDINA FOR
SOMEONE THANK YOU FOR YOUR
CONTINUED WORK ON THIS BILL I
THINK I'VE BEEN ON THIS
COMMITTEE THROUGH BOLLIER
RATIONS OF THIS BILL AND I KNOW
HE SAID ANY DISCUSSIONS ABOUT
ABOUT THIS BILL- I WOULD MAKE
NOTE THAT- YOU'VE WORKED VERY
HARD WITH THE READY
STAKEHOLDERS- AND- YOU KNOW FOR
THE OPPOSITION- I KNOW YOU'RE
ANXIOUS ABOUT THIS AND THERE
ARE CERTAINLY FEARS ASSOCIATED-
BUT I THINK AS YOU SAID YOU
KNOW YOU HAVE TO HAVE FAITH IN
OUR SYSTEM- YES WE DECIDE WE
HEAR IN CALIFORNIA DECIDED TO-
BASICALLY- ESTABLISH GRADUATION
REQUIREMENTS FOR HIGH SCHOOL
IN- IN THE CODE. LEGISLATION
THAT'S AN ISSUE THAT WE'VE
TALKED ABOUT WHY DIDN'T
LEGISLATION IS NECESSARY
BECAUSE THAT IS HOW WE STATUS
GRADUATION REQUIREMENTS IS IN
THE CODE BUT ALSO WE GIVE
LATITUDE TO LOCAL SCHOOL
DISTRICTS TO FIGURE OUT HOW TO
IMPLEMENT FIRST A QUIEN SE- AND
CONJUNCTION WITH OF COURSE THE
PART OF EDUCATION WHICH SETS
OUT GUIDELINES AND THAT'S A
PROCESS THAT'S BEEN THROUGH AND
TRACTORS AND INVARIOUS CHECK
UPS AND DISCUSSIONS ALONG THE
WAY- BUT I THINK YOU HAVE
ALWAYS ACTED IN THE BEST SPACE.
AND TRYING TO BE SURE WE BRING
PEOPLE TOGETHER CERTAINLY YOU
KNOW NOT EVERYONE ALWAYS AGREES
AND WE HAVE OPPOSITION TO THIS
BILL I REALLY DO APPRECIATE THE
WORK YOU PUT INTO IT AND- WELL
I HAVE TO RUN UP TO NEXT MASON
MY MIGHT NOT MIGHT NOT BE HERE
FOR THE VOTE RIGHT NOW I DO
WANT TO EXPRESS MY SUPPORT FOR
THE BILL AND MY GRATITUDE FOR
YOUR ON. THANK YOU THINKING.
GENDER PEN CENTER DOLLY. THANK
YOU. MADAM CHAIR. I WANT TO
START BY. THE I REALLY HAVE A
GREAT RELATIONSHIP WITH THIS
AUTHOR AND- ALSO I WANT TO SAY
THAT THE COMMITTEE AND THE
COMMITTEE AS ONE OF MANY
COMMITTEES I SIT ON I WANT TO
THANK. THE OPPORTUNITY TO GET
REALLY GOOD INFORMATION AND I
DON'T ALWAYS GET THAT ON OUR
SIDE OF THE AISLE AS A
REPUBLICAN BUT WE'VE GOT. A
FULL PACKET OF THE SAME THING
THAT THE CHAIR HAS AND I AM
THAT'S REFRESHING I JUST WANT
TO INSURE THAT. WE ARE THE BILL
ITSELF- I DID A BILL. WE'VE HAD
SEX EDUCATION THAT'S THAT'S
CURRICULUM THAT'S TAUGHT IN
CALIFORNIA AND I DID A BILL
EARLIER IN THIS COMMITTEE TO
TRY TO BE TRANSPARENT ABOUT
WHAT THE CURRICULUM IS AND
ACTUALLY GET IT POSTED ONLINE
BECAUSE THERE'S A LOT OF
CONFLICTS IN THAT AREA. AND IT
IS MESSY JUST AS THE AUTHOR
STATED ABOUT THIS BILL AND SO
WHEN WE PASSED LEGISLATION AND
WE MANDATE SCHOOL DISTRICTS TO
TEACH SOMETHING. AND THEN WE
TALK ABOUT WHAT THE CURRIULUM
IS GONNA LOOK LIKE AND THEY DO
HAVE. LOCAL CONTROL TO BE ABLE
TO. THE COME UP WITH WHAT THEY-
THEIR BOARD OF DIRECTORS OR
THEIR THEIR SCHOOL BOARD AND
THEIR- TEACHERS. ARE GOING TO
DO BUT THIS THIS GUIDES THERE'S
A THERE'S GUIDANCE ALONG THE
WAY WITH THAT. TO WARRANT
HEADING WITH THIS WAS THE-
LIBERATED ETHNIC STUDIES MODEL
CURRICULUM. THAT WAS PUT OUT-
IS ONLY THING OUT THERE RIGHT
NOW AND AS THE OPPOSITION
TALKED ABOUT- THERE'S A LOT OF
PEOPLE THAT REALLY DON'T LIKE
THAT CORRECT ONE. BUT THAT'S
THE ONLY THING AVAILABLE TODAY.
THAT MANY RULE SCHOOL DISTRICTS
WHO DON'T HAVE THE- RESOURCES
THE TIME THE EXPERTISE THE KNOW
HOW TO PUT TOGETHER A
CURRICULUM ARE GONNA BE FORCED
TO MAKE A DECISION IF THIS BILL
IS SIGNED INTO LAW SO CAN YOU
ADDRESS- WHAT THAT LOOKS LIKE
IN THIS TIME FRAME THIS THIS
BILL IS GOING TO COME INTO LAW.
THEN THERE'S NOT GOING TO BE
ANYTHING OTHER THAN WHAT HAS
BEEN. PROPOSED WHICH WAS VERY
CONTROVERSIAL EVEN THE GOVERNOR
THE LIEUTENANT GOVERNOR THE
TREASURER OF THE STATE THE
JEWISH LEGISLATIVE CAUCUS THE
HOOVER INSTITUTE THE CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE THE HINDU AMERICAN
FOUNDATION THE CREE AMERICAN
COALITION ALL OPPOSED IT. ALONG
WITH THE FOLKS IN THE JEWISH
COMMUNITY SO. LET'S TALK ABOUT
THE TIMING OF THIS BILL AND-
WHAT CRITICAL WILL BE AVAILABLE
FOR THOSE VERY SMALL THERE'S
THOUSANDS OF SCHOOL DISTRICTS
IN OUR STATE THAT DON'T HAVE
THE RESOURCES TO COME UP WITH
THIS. TYPE OF- WELL BALANCED-
CURRICULUM. I WORKED WITH A
PROFESSOR AT UC RIVERSIDE HIS
NAME IS A DOCTOR CARLOS CORTES
IT WAS MY PROFESSOR OF HISTORY
AT UC RIVERSIDE. I ADMIRE HIS
WORK VERY MUCH. I WHEN I WAS
WORKING ON THE BILL CENTER
DOLLY I WORKED WITH DOCTOR
CORTES. ONE OF THE FIRST THINGS
THE DOCTOR CORTEZ SAID TO ME IS
THAT THIS CURRICULUM HAD TO BE
A CURRICULUM THAT WOULD BE.
AFFECTED IN IN LOS ANGELES AS
MUCH AS IT HAD TO BE EFFECTIVE.
IN RED BLUFF VENTURA RED BLUFF
IS. BUT I AGREED WITH HIM ON
THAT- THAT THAT WE NEED A
CURRICULUM THAT THAT YOU KNOW
FITS. IN IN THE LOCAL AREAS.
BUT I THINK THE WORK OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION HAS
GOTTEN IS THERE- I WOULD
DISAGREE RESPECTFULLY THAT
THIS. SO CALLED LIBERATED
ETHNIC STUDIES IS THE ONLY
THING THAT'S OUT THERE I DON'T
THINK THAT'S TRUE THE MODEL
CURRICULUM THAT THE STATE. HAS
IS NINE HUNDRED PAGES. NINE
HUNDRED PAGES THAT INCLUDES
LESSON PLANS- APPENDICES-
RESOURCES. FOR SCHOOL DISTRICTS
TO USE. AND THEN WE TALK ABOUT
THE TIMING OF THE BILL. AS I
SAID AT THE OUTSET BUT THIS.
WOULD NOT TAKE EFFECT. UNTIL
STUDENTS ARE GRADUATING IN THE
YEAR. TWENTY TWENTY NINE TWENTY
THIRTY WHICH MEANS IT WOULDN'T
HAVE TO BE IN PLACE. AND TELL
TWENTY TWENTY SIX. I BELIEVE
FOR GRADUATES TO GRADUATE IN
TWENTY TWENTY NINE. IN OTHER
WORDS WE ARE GIVING. I THINK
OUT AMPLE TIME TO SCHOOL
DISTRICTS TO SCHOOLS OF
EDUCATION IN CALIFORNIA TO WORK
ON JUST THAT CENTER DOLLY ON
THE CURRICULUM ON HOW AND
TRAINING TEACHERS- EIGHT ZERO
IT IT'S A BIG STEP. UP NO DOUBT.
BUT I THINK THAT IF IT IS.
SOMETHING THAT IS OVERDUE. IN
THIS STATE AND IN THIS COUNTRY.
AS A TEACHER OF US HISTORY. THE
THERE IS SO MUCH OF OUR OWN
HISTORY THAT IS LEFT OUT. OF A
OF THE CURRICULUM NOW. IN THAT
STUDENTS LIKE WE HEARD ARE
CLAMORING FOR- TO SEE
THEMSELVES IN THE CURRICULUM
YOU KNOW THAT I COULDN'T. BEGIN
WITH THE STORY OF ANGEL ISLAND.
AND THEN- CHINESE IMMIGRATION-
WITH WITH THE TREATY WELL LOU
BAY THAT'LL ENDED THE MEXICAN
WAR WITH THE UNITED STATES- THE
TO DO RIGHTS WITH THE GREAT
MIGRATION. OF AFRICAN AMERICANS
FROM THE SOUTH TO THE NORTH ALL
THESE STORIES STORY OF CHINESE
AMERICANS IN THE RAILROADS ALL
THESE STORIES- NEED TO BE TOLD
AND RIGHT NOW THEY'RE NOT SO
THAT IS WHY WE ARE HEARING FROM
STUDENTS WHO ARE SAYING THAT
THEY WANT TO SEE IT THANK
STUDIES IMPLEMENT I THINK WE
HAVE THE ABILITY TO DO IT. IN
THE STATE. I'D LIKE TO DISCUSS
AGAIN- I DON'T DISAGREE WITH
THE FACT THAT. WE NEED TO TEACH
GOOD ACTORS HISTORY AND- BUT IN
DOING THAT. THE GOAL IS TO
UNITE US NOT DIVIDE US THAT'S
THAT'S I THINK WHY THIS IS THIS
IS OBVIOUSLY A CAN- IT'S DRIVEN
BY MOTION IS DRIVEN BY THERE'S
LOTS OF THINGS THAT THAT WE
NEED TO LEARN SO I JUST WANT TO
ON MY OWN TIME MANAGER I I'M
BILL TODAY- AND I KNOW THAT
YOU'VE WORKED REALLY HARD AT IT
TO THE WHICH YOU ALWAYS DO ON
YOUR BILLS BUT I JUST WANTED
TO. SHARE SOME THOUGHTS THAT.
WHY I THINK THERE'S A LOT OF
PARENTS AND I'M ONE OF THOSE
PARENTS WHO HOUSE OTHER THAN AN
ELEVEN YEAR OLD DAUGHTER- WHO
IS. IS ATTENDING A PRIVATE
SCHOOL- RIGHT NOW BUT WAS. THAT
WHEN WE WERE WHEN WE HAD HER IN
SCHOOL IN BEEPER BEFORE BOTH OF
US BECAME ELECTED HERE- WE
BROUGHT HER TO SACRAMENTO SO
SHE'S GETTING EDUCATION HERE IT
IS IN A PRIVATE SCHOOL. BUT
BOTH MY SONS AND MY DAUGHTER
FOR THE FIRST TEN YEARS OF HER
LIFE ATTENDED PUBLIC SCHOOL SO.
VERY MUCH ENGAGED IN THAT
PROCESS AND WHAT ENDS UP
HAPPENING- IN MY OPINION IS. A
LOT OF GOOD. CURRICULUM IS
THOUGHT OUT IN BUT IT GETS
STORED ALONG THE WAY AND ACCESS
FOR THE PARENTS AND I AND I'M
BACKING UP TO MY- TO MY BILL ON
SEX EDUCATION THAT I HAD
EARLIER THIS YEAR AND- THE
ABILITY FOR PARENTS TO WAY AND
MAKES IT VERY DIFFICULT AND-
THAT WORK. AND THE SCHOOLS
AREN'T VERY TRANSPARENT AND
PEOPLE ARE EXITING. PUBLIC
SCHOOLS. INCLUDING MYSELF. I
HOPE I NEVER HAVE TO SEND. MY
CHILD TO PUBLIC SCHOOL AND I
AND I HATE TO SAY THAT BECAUSE-
I PAY FOR. NEARLY PAY FOR AND I
THINK THERE'S A LOT OF
CALIFORNIANS WHO ARE
QUESTIONING WHAT WE REALLY
GETTING. AND THE PARENTS OF
THESE CHILDREN DON'T BELIEVE
THEY'RE GETTING. WHAT THEY WANT
THEIR CHILDREN TO BE TAUGHT.
AND SOMEHOW WE HAVE TO FIGURE
OUT A WAY. TO BRING THOSE BRING
EVERYBODY AND NOT JUST THE KIDS
THAT HAVE DON'T HAVE THE
ABILITY OR THE PARENTS OF THE
BELIEVE IT TAKE ANOTHER CHOICE.
WE'VE WE'VE PUSHED OUT CHARTER
SCHOOLS WE DON'T FUND IN THE
SAME WAY AS WE- FUND PUBLIC
SCHOOLS AND THERE'S A AN ATTACK
ON. ANYBODY THAT TRIES TO GET
AWAY FROM A SYSTEM THAT IS NOT
REALLY IN MY OPINION DOING A
GREAT JOB SO THOSE ARE JUST
SOME THOUGHTS OF MINE. BUT I
THINK THE PUBLIC IS OUT THERE
GRASPING WITH AND THE ABILITY
FOR THEIR MONEY TO FALL THEIR
CHILD. AND THEN GET ACCESS TO
WHAT IS ACTUALLY BEING TAUGHT.
IS VERY FRUSTRATING. AND I
THINK THIS BILL. EVENTUALLY
WILL BE THE SAME AS PLATE SPACE
THAT MY SEX WHICH WHICH IS
WHERE SEX EDUCATION IS THAT IS
IT'S VERY DIFFICULT ACCESS. IT
AND ACTUALLY KNOW WHAT IS BEING
TAUGHT BECAUSE HOW IT'S BEING
TAUGHT. AND WHAT IS BEING
TAUGHT IS CRITICAL IT'S YOUNG
MINDS TO. HOPEFULLY BRING US
TOGETHER NOT DIVIDE US APART ON
WHERE WE THINK OUR CHILDREN TO
GO AND PARENTS SEEM TO BE PART
OF THAT SOLUTION AND WHEN THEY
DON'T FEEL THEY CAN'T THEY TRY
TO EXIT BUT WHEN THEY TRY TO
EXIT. THE MONEY DOESN'T FALL SO
THOSE ARE JUST SOME THOUGHTS
APPRECIATE YOU AS AN AUTHOR AND
A FRIEND- BUT I WON'T BE ABLE
TO SUPPORT YOUR BILL TODAY.
THANK YOU MISTER DOLLY- SENATOR
I HAVE TO SAY I WHOLEHEARTEDLY
DISAGREE WITH YOU ABOUT OUR
PUBLIC EDUCATION SYSTEM. I
THINK WE HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY.
IN THE LEGISLATURE TO CONTINUE
TO DO BETTER. AND WHEN WE FIND
A PROBLEM. TO TRY AND FIX IT
AND MAKE PUBLIC EDUCATION
BETTER FOR OUR CHILDREN. AND I
WOULD ALSO JUST SAY THAT. I
THINK JUST THE OPPOSITE OF WHAT
YOU SAID ABOUT ETHNIC STUDIES.
I THINK IT BRINGS US CLOSER
TOGETHER. BECAUSE I THINK THAT
WE FIND OUT WE ARE HAVE MORE IN
COMMON. THAN THAT NOT. WHEN WE
LEARN ABOUT EACH OTHER WE LEARN
THAT WE ALL HAVE FAMILIES WE
ALL LEARNED THAT WE HELPED. HER
YOU KNOW WE'RE ALL PEOPLE
TRYING TO. TO SURVIVE IN THIS
WORLD SO I THINK THAT MAKE
CITIES. BRINGS US CLOSER
TOGETHER- BUT I APPRECIATE YOUR
COMMENTS LET ME JUST SAY I'M
NOT OPPOSED TO ETHNIC STUDIES.
I WANTED TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
DO IT IN A WAY. THAT IT'S
INCLUSIVE AND THAT PEOPLE GET
TO BE. I'M NOT I'M NOT BECAUSE
I AGREE WITH WHAT YOU SAY I'M
NOT DISAGREEING THE ETHNIC
STUDIES ART. SOMETHING WE
SHOULD TEACH ABSOLUTELY IT'S
MAKING SURE THAT. IT IS THE
CURRICULUM THAT IS OUT THERE
IS. ACCURATE AND BRINGS US
TOGETHER AND NOT USED TO DEVISE
A PART OR- AGAINST ONE OF THE
OTHER THAT'S WHAT AND THAT'S
WHAT I'VE HEARD AND I'VE BEEN
HEARING. FROM MY DISTRICT I
DON'T DISAGREE THAT WE SHOULD
HAVE IT. I THINK WE SHOULD IT'S
NOT A PROBLEM BUT IT'S HOW WE
DO IT THAT MATTERS. AGAIN I
WOULD SAY TO THAT THE
CURRICULUM THAT YOU FIRST
MENTIONED. HAS BEEN CHANGED IN
THIS BILL THE MASTER CURRICULUM
SOME OF THE POINTS HE TALKED
ABOUT HAVE BEEN TAKEN OUT AND
CHANGE THE AUTHOR DID THAT. TO
MAKE IT MORE INCLUSIVE SO YOU
KNOW I THINK AS A SOCIETY WE
TRY TO JUST KEEP GETTING BETTER
RIGHT. ALL RIGHT TO HAVE ANY
OTHER FURTHER COMMENTS
QUESTIONS CENTER PAN. THANK YOU
THANK YOU- AND- IT REALLY
FREESHEET THE DISCUSSION- BUT I
DO IT JUST MAKE THE OBSERVATION
THAT. ACTUALLY THE TONES WERE
CONCERNED THAT DESPITE THE
CHANGES THAT WERE MADE AND THE-
STATE CURRICULUM THAT THEY'RE
CONCERNED WHAT HAPPENED AND
LOCAL AREAS INTERESTING ENOUGH-
WE ACTUALLY WANT MORE LOCAL
INPUT AND CONTROL RIGHT AND
THAT'S HOW WE SET UP OUR
SYSTEM. SO I THINK THIS IS A
STEP IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION.
AND THEN JUST FOR THE WORK TO
DO I AGREE YOU KNOW PARENTS AND
SCHOOL BOARDS AND TEACHERS NEED
TO WORK TOGETHER AND EACH
LOCALITY. SO THE PEOPLE OF OUR
RESPECTIVE DISTRICTS. WELL
ENGAGE BECAUSE WE DON'T WE
DON'T DICTATE IT FROM THE TOP
WE'RE ESTABLISHING A GRADUATION
REQUIREMENT BUT EXACTLY AND I
APPRECIATE THAT I APPRECIATE
THE ODDS BROAD SUPPORT FOR
ETHNIC STUDIES HERE- SO I THINK
THAT SOUNDS LIKE AN AREA OF
COMMON AGREEMENT TO APPRECIATE
THAT AND THEN HOW WE IMPLEMENT
THAT- WILL TAKE ON A VARIETY OF
DIFFERENT- WAYS DEPENDING ON
HOW EACH OF OUR LOCAL
COMMUNITIES COME TOGETHER TO DO
THAT. SO THAT'S BOTH AN
OPPORTUNITY I ALSO HEAR THIS
YEAR THE OPPONENTS ABOUT WHAT
THAT MEANS BUT I HOPE THAT WE
CAN SEE THIS AND OPPORTUNITIES
A ORGANIZATION HERE'S A
LEGISLATURE WE'VE OFTEN TALKED
ABOUT THE IMPORTANCE OF LOCAL
CONTROL LOCAL ENGAGEMENT THAT'S
HOW WE SET UP OUR EDUCATION
SYSTEM SO- SO LET'S GO AHEAD
AND SET THE GOAL HERE AS WELL
TO DO THIS BILL AND THEN I A-
THANK THAT WE ALL WORK- CLEAN
PARENTS WHETHER YOU SUPPORT OR
OPPOSE. ENGAGE WITH YOUR SCHOOL
DISTRICTS AND DEVELOP THE- THE
AT. THE DEVELOP THE PROGRAM AS-
YEAH WE WANT YOU CAN YOU FOR
OBVIOUSLY WE PROVIDE GUIDELINES
SINCE THE STATE AND WE WORK
PEOPLE WORK VERY HARD ON THAT
TO GIVE PEOPLE SOME GUIDANCE.
BUT LET'S GO AHEAD AND BEGIN
WORK TOGETHER- IS A SAID. WE
ALL WORK TOGETHER AND I GET A
CURRICULUM THAT. ENSURES THAT
ALL CALIFORNIANS A MATTER WHERE
THEY CAME FROM. OTHER
BACKGROUNDS ARE- CAN LEARN.
ABOUT OUR HISTORY TOGETHER. AND
TAKE THE LESSONS FROM THAT- AS
WE MOVE FORWARD AND I THINK
THAT'S THE OPPORTUNITY THAT'S
BEING POSED BY THIS BILL TODAY
SO. AGAIN THANK YOU I PREFER
COLLEGES WERE SPEAKING TWICE
BUT NOT. JUST WANTED TO MAKE
THAT FINAL COMMENT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU CENTER PAM CENTER
CHOKE- GOOD MORNING ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MEDINA- I HAVE A
QUESTION ABOUT- HOW WOULD YOU
ADDRESS THE CONCERN OR THE
REQUEST BY MANY TO MAKE AB ONE
A ONE A TO YOUR BILL IN ORDER
FOR IT TO HAVE AND I KNOW IT'S
YOU'VE IT'S BEEN A WORK IN
PROGRESS BUT- CONSIDERING THE
FACT THAT THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION JUST
CAME UP WITH THE CURRICULUM OR
THE MODEL. IN IN MARCH GIVING
SOME TIME TO HAVE- JUST TO BE
MORE TO HAVE MORE TIME IN ORDER
TO DEVELOP AT AT THE CURE HIM A
LITTLE FURTHER OUT FOR LOCAL
SCHOOL DISTRICTS. YEAH WELL-
THANK YOU FOR YOUR COMMENT IN
QUESTION AND I CHUCKLED
UNDERNEATH MY MASK BECAUSE AS-
DR PAN DR LEYVA SENATOR DOLLY-
NO THIS IS MY THIRD TIME COMING
UP HERE- PRESENTING. TO THE
EDUCATION COMMITTEE OF THE
SENATE- THIS BILL AS YOU
PROBABLY KNOW WA VETOED TWICE
IN THE LAST TIME IT WAS VETOED.
BY OUR GOVERNOR IT WAS JUST
BECAUSE OF THE CURRICULUM THAT
HE DID NOT FEEL COMFORTABLE
WITH WITH THE CURRICULUM AS IT
WAS AND IN HIS VETO MESSAGE HE
SAID THAT HE WANTED TO SEE A
MORE BALANCED CURRICULUM. AND
THAT IS WHAT WE HAVE NOW. A
MORE BALANCED CURRICULUM- THE
CURRICULUM THAT I THINK WE CAN
ALL BE PROUD OF. AND THAT
CURRICULUM WAS ABOUT THREE
YEARS IN THE MAKING- AND AGAIN
THIS IS MY THIRD TIME-
PRESENTING THE BILL- I THINK
THAT IF WE WOULD GO TO STUDENTS
STUDENTS WOULD SAY THAT THIS IS
LONG OVERDUE- ETHNIC STUDIES
HAS BEEN A DISCIPLINE FOR FIFTY
YEARS. IT'S GOING BACK TO
NINETEEN SIXTY EIGHT OVER FIFTY
YEARS THAT'S FIFTY YEARS OF
RESEARCH THAT HAS TAKEN PLACE
FIFTY YEARS OF NEW KNOWLEDGE-
THAT HAVE BEEN PRODUCED
PRODUCED BY ACADEMICS. PRODUCED
BY HISTORIANS. THAT IS NOT
INCLUDED IN OUR CURRICULUM SO I
WOULD SAY TO YOUR QUESTION THE
WE DON'T HAVE MORE TIME. WE
NEED TO DO IT NOW. WE'RE GIVING
PLENTY OF TIME FOR PUBLIC
SCHOOLS AND DISTRICTS TO
IMPLEMENT THE CURRICULUM BUT
THE TIME TO PASS IT IS NOW. AND
I WOULD SAY TO SENATOR- CHIU
ABOVE THE CURRICULUM IF IT PASS
AND GOES INTO LAW DOES NOT TO
BE IMPLEMENTED TILL TWENTY
TWENTY FOUR TWENTY FIVE SO THAT
WILL GIVE SCHOOL DISTRICTS. THE
TIME THAT YOU CAN YOU'RE
CONCERNED ABOUT SO HOPEFULLY
THAT HELPS. MEMBERS WE HAVE A
MOTION ON THE BILL. THANK YOU
CENTER PAN. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MEDINA YOU MAY CLOSE. I WOULD
JUST LIKE TO IN CLOSING SAY
THAT THERE ARE A LOT OF
MISINFORMATION OUT THERE IN
THIS REGARDS A LOT OF
MISINFORMATION- IN THE MEDIA. A
LOT OF MISINFORMATION THAT HAS
BEEN SHARED WITH THE PUBLIC AND
SO I JUST WANNA CLARIFY. ONE
THING- ETHNIC STUDIES AND THE
TECHNIQUE STUDIES CURRICULUM-
THAT THAT THAT IS PRODUCED BY
THE DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION IS
NOT CRITICAL RACE THEORY
CRITICAL RACE THEORY IS
SOMETHING THAT IS TAUGHT. IN
LAW SCHOOLS IT IS NOT THE
INTENTION OF THIS BILL. OR THE
CURRICULUM. BUT TO HAVE
CRITICAL RACE THEORY- THERE ARE
MANY THINGS THAT STUDENTS. IN
LEARN WHEN THEY ARE OLDER AND
GO OFF TO COLLEGE BUT- THIS IS
NOT CRITICAL RACE THERE AND
WITH THAT I ASK FOR YOUR VOTE
THANK YOU SOME A MEMBER AND I
WILL AGAIN THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PERSEVERANCE IN THIS AREA I
THINK IT'S INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT
MADAM CONSULTANT PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. FILE ITEM NUMBER ONE
AB ONE OH ONE THE MOTION IS TO
PASS AS AMENDED THE FIRST
AMENDED AND RE REFER TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
SENATOR LEYVA HI LEYVA AYE OCHO
ABOVE NOW A TROUBLED NO CORTESE
CURTIS HE AYE DALLY. DALLY NOW
GLAZER MCGUIRE PAN ALL RIGHT
AND I DO BELIEVE THAT BILL ON
CALL MR MEDINA YOU GET TO SPEND
A LITTLE MORE TIME WITH US
WE'RE GOING TO GO TO FILE ITEM
NUMBER TWO AB EIGHT NINE TWENTY
SEVEN BEGIN WHEN YOU'RE READY.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS I AM PLEASED TO PRESENT
AB NINE TWENTY SEVEN A
PRACTICAL SOLUTION TO
ELIMINATING THE SKILLS GAPS AND
ENABLING UNDERSERVED STUDENTS
TO COMPETE IN CALIFORNIA'S.
CURRENT FUTURE WORKFORCE.
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGES
PROVIDE TWO POINT ONE MILLION
STUDENTS WITH THE KNOWLEDGE AND
BACKGROUND. NECESSARY TO
COMPETE IN TODAY'S ECONOMY.
HOWEVER THE EDUCATIONAL
REQUIREMENTS FOR ENTRY LEVEL
LEVEL WORK. HAVE INCREASINGLY
INCLUDED BACCALAUREATE DEGREES
BY 203038% OF JOBS WILL
REQUIRE. AT LEAST A BACHELOR'S
DEGREE. A SHORTFALL OF ONE
MILLION COLLEGE GRADUATES.
TWENTY FIFTEEN. SB EIGHT FIFTY
AUTHORIZED THE BOARD OF
GOVERNORS OF CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGES TO ESTABLISH
A STATE WIDE. BACCALAUREATE
DEGREE PROGRAM AT FIFTEEN
COLLEGES. THERE IS A CLEAR NEED
FOR MORE DISTRICTS TO
PARTICIPATE. IN AN EXPANDED
PILOT PROGRAMS MORE EVER THE
PILOT SUNSETS ON JULY FIRST.
TWENTY TWENTY SIX REQUIRING
LEGISLATION TO EXTEND THE
PROGRAM. AB NINE TWENTY SEVEN
WILL EXTEND AND EXPAND.
STATEWIDE BACCALAUREATE DEGREE
PILOT AND DEFINITELY. THIS BILL
REQUIRE COMMUNITY COLLEGE
DISTRICT. SEEKING APPROVAL TO
PROVIDE EVIDENCE OF UNMET
WORKFORCE NEEDS ALLOWING UP TO
THIRTY PROGRAMS. IN THE STATE A
YEAR. THE IDEA FOR THIS BILL
CAME FROM THE SENATE.
CHAMPIONED BY SENATORS BLOCK
AND HILL **** THE SENATE AND
COMMITTEE SEIZE ON THIS UNIQUE
OPPORTUNITY AND SUPPORT THIS
ONCE AGAIN. TESTIFYING IN
SUPPORT IS CONSTANCE CARROLL.
AN ALLEY YAMA ICHI A STUDENT OF
FOOTHILL DANCER. THANK YOU
ASSEMBLY MEMBER SOMEONE MEMBER
ARE YOU ALSO ACCEPTING THE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS I AM THANK
YOU VERY MUCH WE WILL GO TO
YOUR FIRST WITNESS IN SUPPORT
CONSTANCE CARROLL- YOU HAVE TWO
MINUTES AND THEN WE'LL GO TO AL
AHLI YAMAN MOVED YAMAGUCHI AND
YOU ARE TWO MINUTES AS WELL.
PLEASE BEGIN WHEN YOU'RE READY.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS I RECENTLY RETIRED THE
CHANCELLOR OF THE SAN DIEGO
COMMUNITY COLLEGE DISTRICT AND
NOW AND SERVING AS PRESIDENT OF
THE CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY
COLLEGE BACCALAUREATE
ASSOCIATION WE THANK
ASSEMBLYMEMBER DINO FOR HIS
LEADERSHIP AND WE URGE YOUR
SUPPORT OF AB NINE TWENTY
SEVEN. THIS BILL WILL MAKE THE
HIGHLY SUCCESSFUL PILOT
PROGRAMS THAT ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MEDINA REFERRING TO PERMANENT
BY ELIMINATING THE SUNSET
PROVISION. IT WILL EXPAND THE
OPPORTUNITY TO OTHER COMMUNITY
COLLEGES AND IT PROVIDES ALL
LOCALLY STRONG CONSULTATION
WITH THE PUBLIC UNIVERSITIES.
BACCALAUREATE DEGREES ARE
WORKFORCE PREPARATION TO GREEN
DO NOT DUPLICATE ANY PROGRAMS
OFFERED BY THE PUBLIC
UNIVERSITIES. THE PILOT PROGRAM
ILLUSTRATES THE EFFICACY OF
THIS APPROACH IN THE IN RECENT
STUDIES WE FOUND THE FOLLOWING
70% OF THE STUDENTS ARE
STUDENTS OF COLOR. 63% ARE
WOMEN THE GRADUATION RATE OR
78% HIGHER THAN THE GRADUATION
RATE THAT YOU FIND IN MOST
UNIVERSITY. 83% OF THE STUDENTS
ARE EMPLOYEDAND 90% 5% OF
THOSE ARE EMPLOYED IN- THE WILL
BE STUDIED AND MOST IMPORTANT
FOR CALIFORNIA 94% ARE
EMPLOYED. IN IN IN CALIFORNIA
AND DO NOT LEAVE THE STATE.
THESE PROGRAMS ARE EXACTLY WHAT
OUR CALIFORNIA ECONOMY NEEDS
THEY ARE EXAMPLE SERVING LOCAL
COMMUNITY WORKFORCE NEEDS. THEY
ARE A FOR AFFORDABLE COSTING
ONLY TEN THOUSAND FIVE HUNDRED
SIXTY DOLLARS FOR ALL FOUR
YEARS. AND THEY ARE EXTREMELY
HIGH QUALITY SO WE ARE VERY
VERY PLEASED TO HAVE THE COURT-
MOST OF THE COMMUNITY COLLEGES
IN THE STATE THE STATEWIDE
ACADEMIC SENATE AND EVERYONE
WHO BELIEVES THAT CALIFORNIA'S
ECONOMY CAN BE STRENGTHENED. BY
CLOSING THIS WORKFORCE GAP
THROUGH THE COMMUNITY COLLEGE
VEHICLE- THANK YOU. FOR
LISTENING TO MY- PRESENTATION
AND I WILL BE HAPPY TO RESPOND
TO QUESTIONS GREAT THANK YOU
VERY MUCH WILL NOW GO TO L. A.
YAMAUCHI. YOU HAVE TWO MINUTES
AS WELL I. I THANK YOU HI MY
NAME IS ALLEY I'M REACHING AND
I'M A GRADUATE OF THE WHOLE
COLLEGES DENTAL HYGIENE
BACCALAUREATE PROGRAM. AND I
MEAN FOR A TV NINETY SEVEN. I
JUST GRADUATED A FEW WEEKS AGO
AND CURRENTLY WORK AS A DENTAL
ASSISTANT WAITING PATIENTLY
CENTER PROJECT AND THE HIGH
JENIS. ALLEN WAS MY TOP CHOICE
THE OF ITS- HAS. A PORTABLE- I
DID NOT LEAVE ME AND THAT AND
LOT MY CLASSMATE YOU NEED
QUICKLY MOVE ENTER EDUCATION.
QUICKLY MOVE FROM EDUCATION IT
TO THE LORD. I'M DETERMINED
PREPARE MY CLASS AND ME THE
PAST AND BOY AND STATE
LICENSING EXAM. AND OUR CLASS
HAS A 100% PASSING RATE ON THE
EXAMPLE OF LAW BECAUSE OF THE
PROGRAM MANY OF US HAVE JOBS
LINED UP HERE IN CALIFORNIA
WHERE MOST OF US WILL STAY WANT
TO RECEIVE OUR LICENSES IN A
FEW MONTHS. WITH THAT SAID I
SUPPORT EXPANSION THE PROGRAMS
LIKE THIS AND SUPPORT AB
NINETEEN TRENT NINETY SEVEN
NINE CURRICULA VOTE IN FAVOR OF
THIS BILL THANK YOU THANK YOU
WE WILL NOW GO TO SUPPORT HERE
IN ROOM FORTY TWO OH THREE
PLEASE. STATE YOUR NAME AND
SUPPORT. GOOD MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS MANY DEALS REPRESENTING
SOUNDS A EVERGREEN COMMUNITY
COLLEGE DISTRICT VERY MUCH IN
SUPPORT. GREAT THANK YOU VERY-MUCH SEEING NO ONE ELSE HERE
WILL GO TO THE OVERFLOW ROOM.
SEEING NO ONE THERE WE WILL GO
TO THE PHONE LINES MADAME
MODERATOR CAN YOU PLEASE KEEP
ANYONE WHO WISHES TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF AB NINE TWENTY SEVEN.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR LADIES
AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF AB NINE
TWENTY SEVEN. THIS PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO. AN OPERATOR WILL
PROVIDE YOU WITH THE LINE
NUMBER AND PLACE YOU BACK INTO
Q. ONCE AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF AB EIGHT
NINE TWENTY SEVEN. PLEASE PRESS
ONE THAN THEIR OWN NOW. LINE
NUMBER SIXTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS MARK
MCDONALD- MGI ADVOCACY ON
BEHALF OF A NUMBER OF LOCAL
COMMUNITY COLLEGE DISTRICTS
ANTELOPE VALLEY KERN- MOUNTAIN
A SINGLE PERALTA PALO VERDE SAN
DIEGO SAN FRANCISCO SAMPOERNA
DINO AND YUBA COMMUNITY COLLEGE
DISTRICTS ALL IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. BLIND NUMBER
SIXTY TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
THIS IS JUSTIN HIGHER WITH THE
CHILDREN I LEADERSHIP GROUP
WE'RE PROUD TO SUPPORT THE BILL
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. NUMBER
THIRTY FOUR YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY NAME IS
KIMBERLY WILL ON YOU KNOW YOU
SEE POLITICALLY AND ALSO NUMBER
JANET AND I STRONG SUPPORT
SYSTEM THANK YOU THANK YOU. BY
NUMBER SIXTY THREE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO
INDICATE RAJ ON BEHALF OF SAN
DIEGO UNIFIED THERE WEREN'T
SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU. MY
NUMBER ONE OH NINE ONE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THE MORNING
MICHELLE MCKAY UNDERWOOD ON
BEHALF THE ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGE
ADMINISTRATORS AND SUPPORT
THANK YOU. MY NUMBER NINETY TWO
THE LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS
ALICE IN CHAINS I'M A RECENT
GRADUATE FROM KIANA COMMUNITY
COLLEGE AND ALSO STUDENT IN
GENERATION AND I AM IN SUPPORT
OF THIS BILL THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. MY NUMBER ONE FOURTEEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MY NAME IS MAKAYLA
MCCARTY I'M A STUDENT AT UCLA
AND I'M JUST NOT GOING TOWARD
THIS BILL. THANK YOU. BUT MY
NUMBER ONE IN THE LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
DAVID NEVIN ON BEHALF OF THE
SOUTH ORANGE COUNTY COMMUNITY
COLLEGE DISTRICT WATER ENJOYS
CAT THE LOS ANGELES COMMUNITY
COLLEGE DISTRICT AND THE SANTA
MONICA COMMUNITY COLLEGE
DISTRICT IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU
THANK YOU FOR. BY NUMBER
SEVENTY ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THE MORNING
CARE MEMBERS THIS IS JENNIFER
CANNOT HELL WITH ERIN REED AND
ASSOCIATES- BOTH THE CALIFORNIA
SOCIETY FOR RESPIRATORY CARE
AND THE CALIFORNIA DENTAL
HYGIENISTS ASSOCIATION. WORD OF
EIGHTY NINE TWENTY SEVEN THANK
YOU. THE LINE NUMBER SEVENTY
FOUR YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS KCLU ON
BEHALF OF THE COAST COMMUNITY
COLLEGE DISTRICT IN RANCHO SAN
DIEGO COMMUNITY COLLEGE
DISTRICT IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
THE MEASURE. THANK YOU THANK
YOU. MY NUMBER ONE OH EIGHT
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING RYAN BACK
ON ANY WITH THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGE LEAGUE OF CALIFORNIA
TESTIFYING ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIANS OF THE THREE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE DISTRICT IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
HE MET THIS TIME MADAM CHAIR WE
HAVE NO ONE ELSE IN Q. THINK
ABOUT A MODERATOR WE HAVE NO
LEAD OPPOSITION LISTED IS THERE
ANY OPPOSITION HERE IN ROOM
FORTY TWO OR THREE. SEEING NONE
WE WILL GO TO THE OVERFLOW ROOM.
SEEING THEM THERE. WE WILL NOW
GO TO THE LONG PHONE LINES
MADAME MODERATOR CAN YOU PLEASE
KEEP ANYONE WHO'S IN OPPOSITION
TO AB NINE TWENTY SEVEN. THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION AB EIGHT NINE
TWENTY SEVEN PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO. AN OPERATOR WILL
PROVIDE YOU WITH YOUR LINE
NUMBER AND PUT YOU BACK INTO Q.
ONCE AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION OF AB NINE TWO
SEVEN. COULD PRESS ONE BUTTON
THERE- NOW. AT THE TIME AND I'M
SURE WE HAVE NO ONE TO THINK
ABOUT A MODERATOR WILL BRING IT
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE SENATOR
DOLLY AND INCENTIVE AND- A
MANAGER I JUST WOULD LIKE TO
THANK THE AUTHOR FOR THIS I'M
GLAD WE'RE GONNA SEE THIS
CONTINUE OBVIOUSLY. BY THE
TESTIMONY CAN SEE A LOT OF
PEOPLE ARE USING THE PILOT
PROJECT AND SO I MOVE THE BILL.
THANK YOU SIR CENTER PAM. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. I DO APPRECIATE
YOU BRINGING THIS BILL FORWARD
AND I DO HAVE CONCERNS ABOUT-
THE SHIFTING MISSIONS IN BENTON
FRANKLY- AND I KNOW WE'VE
TALKED ABOUT THIS BEFORE THIS
COMMITTEE. THIS IS KIND DRIVEN
BY WHAT CALL CREDENTIALS- SO
WHAT'S HAPPENED IS AND WE ALSO
SEE THE CSU IS THAT. FIELDS
THAT TRADITIONALLY WERE TAUGHT
BY WHETHER IT'S COMMITTEE
COLLEGES OR CSCS WHAT HAPPENS
IS THAT DAVE. CONSTANTLY
INCREASE THE DEGREE
REQUIREMENTSFOR ENTRY INTO THE
FIELD SO WHAT USED TO. CORNICES
YOU THREE NOW REQUIRES A
BACHELOR'S DEGREE WHAT REQUIRED
BACHELOR'S DEGREE REQUIRED
MASTER'S DEGREE. AND OF COURSE
THAT CREATES CHALLENGES BECAUSE
OF THAT FIELD IS TRADITIONALLY
TAUGHT BY COMMUNITY COLLEGES
STAND IF THEY'RE GONNA CONTINUE
TO DO THAT. AND THEY YOU KNOW
THEY HAVE ALL THE EDUCATORS AND
SO FORTH THEY HAVE TO NOW BE
ABLE TO OFFER BACHELOR'S
OTHERWISE. THE STUDENTS CAN'T
ACTUALLY ENTER THE FIELD AND WE
ALSO SAW STATUS AT CSU TO
WHERE. THEY'RE ASKING US FOR
MASTER'S DEGREES AND DOCTORATES
WORKS ONLY IT'S- SO I
APPRECIATE YOU TOOK THE
AMENDMENT FROM THE COMMITTEE I
DO HAVE CONCERNS ABOUT. WHAT
HAPPENS TO THE CULTURE AT THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGES WE HAVE MORE
MORE BACHELOR'S DEGREE BUT ALSO
RECOGNIZE THAT THEY'RE- KIND OF
VICTIMS OF. OF WHAT'S HAPPENING
IN TERMS OF. LIKE ALL THIS
CREDENTIALS AND I ALSO DID IN
THE CERTAINLY ISN'T AN ISSUE
WITH YOUR BILL SPECIFICALLY BUT
IT'S ARE PART OF LARGER ISSUE
IS THAT. AS YOU CAN CONSTANTLY
ALSO RAISES CREDENTIALS WERE
ALSO RISK INCREASING THE
FINANCIAL BARRIERS TO PEOPLE
ENTERING THESE FIELDS SO WE CAN
TALK ABOUT DIFFERENT THINGS.
AND SO CERTAINLY I APPRECIATE
WHAT YOU'RE DOING THE BILL
OFFICIALLY SPONSOR ON THIS OF
THE BILL- BUT MY AGAIN JUST
RAISES. ISSUE ABOUT. EACH FIELD
CONSTANTLY POPPING THE
CREDENTIALS ARE REQUIRED FOR
THE FIELD WHICH THEN MAKES IT
MORE EXPENSIVE PEOPLE ENTRY.
ENTER INCREASES THE L. C. LOANS
ALL THAT OTHER STUFF AND- WE
REALLY SHOULD THINK. NOW IT'S A
LITTLE HARD FOR US THE
LEGISLATURE TO SET RULES AROUND
IT BUT HOPEFULLY AS A SOCIETY
WE'RE THINKING ABOUT. IS THIS
REALLY NECESSARY AND WHY ARE WE
DOING THIS BECAUSE EXACTLY SO.
EVEN THOUGH THEY COULD YOU KNOW
THEY'RE STILL DEALING COMMITTEE
COLLEGE BUT THE BEST IS GONNA
BE LONGER AND ASSOCIATES SO
WE'RE STILL TALKING ABOUT MORE
MONEY MORE TIME IT'S CETERA.
YET AND I DO HAVE CONCERNS
ABOUT THAT SO THANK YOU FOR
GIVE ME THE OPPORTUNITY EXPRESS
THAT- AND CERTAINLY WILL
SUPPORT YOUR BILL- BUT- ALSO
ONE BE SURE WE MAINTAIN THE--CHARACTER OF OUR COMMUNITY
COLLEGES IN A WAY. THAT WE IT'S
NOT DOMINATED BY- THE BATCHES
DEGREE SEEKING AND THAT LEADS
TO THE OTHER ASPECTS OF THE
COMMUNICATIONS ARE STILL
PRESERVED. WITHIN THE CULTURE.
AND SO. YOUR DOCTOR PAN THAT'S
A GOOD POINT YOU MAKE WE SHOULD
KEEP THAT IN MIND ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS CONCERNS. A FARMER
MEDINA WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE
I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE
VOTE THANK YOU SIR THE BILL HAS
BEEN MOVED BY SENATOR DOLLY MAN
CONSULTANT PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. FILE ITEM NUMBER TWO A.
B. NINE TWENTY SEVEN THE MOTION
IS TO PASS AS AMENDED BUT FIRST
AMEND AND RE REFER TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
SENATOR LEYVA HI LEYVA AYE
OTOBO AYE BUT CHAO ABOAGYE
COURTESY. COURTESY I DELI DELI
I GLAZER MCGUIRE PAN HI CAN I
VERY GOOD WE WILL LEAVE THAT
BILL ON CALL FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS. ALL RIGHT ASSEMBLY
MEMBER DUTIES ALSO HAVE FILE
ITEM NUMBER. THREE AB FOURTEEN
FIFTY SIX. PLEASE PROCEED WHEN
YOU'RE READY I AM A PROUD CO
AUTHOR OF THIS BILL GO RIGHT
AHEAD. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
AND MEMBERS THIS IS MY FINAL A
BILL TO PRESENT TO YOU THIS
MORNING. I'M PLEASED TO
PRESENT- AB FOURTEEN FIFTY SIX
THE CAL GRANT REFORM ACT WITH.
WHICH MODERNIZES STREAMLINES
AND EXPANDS. ACCESS TO THE
LARGEST STATE FINANCIAL SYSTEM.
FINANCIAL AID SYSTEM CAL GRANT.
CALIFORNIA'S FINANCIAL AID
SYSTEM SUPPORTS OVER FOUR
HUNDRED THOUSAND STUDENTS
SEEKING POST SECONDARY
EDUCATION AND A BETTER LIFE
EACH YEAR. THE LEGISLATURE
APPROPRIATES MORE THAN TWO
BILLION. ANNUALLY TOWARD
FINANCIAL AID. IS A KEY
COMPONENT OF THE STATE'S
LONGSTANDING COMMITMENT TO
ACCESSIBLE AFFORDABLE HIGHER
EDUCATION. NEVER THE LESS THIS
PROGRAM IS DESIGNED SIX DECADES
AGO. AND NO LONGER MEETS THE
NEEDS OF THE STATE'S STRUGGLING
COLLEGE STUDENTS. OF THESE
PROBLEMS CAL GRANT ELIGIBILITY
RULES ARE GEARED TOWARD
STUDENTS ATTENDING COLLEGE
DIRECTLY AFTER FINISHING HIGH
SCHOOL. STUDENTS INELIGIBLE FOR
THE CAL GRANT ENTITLEMENT
PROGRAM. DUE TO AGE WHEN THEY
GRADUATED FROM HIGH SCHOOL OR
GPA MUST COMPETE FOR A LIMITED
NUMBER OF AWARDS. THROUGH THE
COMPETITIVE CAL GRANT PROGRAMS.
THEREFORE ONLY ONE OF EVERY
EIGHT ELIGIBLE ELIGIBLE
STUDENTS ARE TYPICALLY AWARDED
TO CAL GRANT THROUGH THE
COMPETITIVE CAL GRANT SAYS TO
ENSURE MORE CALIFORNIANS HAVE
ACCESS TO AFFORDABLE DEGREE.
COMPREHENSIVE REFORM IS NEEDED.
AB FOURTEEN FIFTY SIX DOES THE
FOLLOWING CONSOLIDATES THE
THREE CAL GRANT AWARDS INTO A
NEW CAL GRANT TO AND CAL GRANT
FOR PROGRAM. CAL GRANT TO WILL
GUARANTEE AN AXIS AWARD FOR ALL
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGE
STUDENTS WELL CAL GRANT FOR
WILL MAINTAIN THE TUITION FEES
AWARD TO STUDENTS. ATTENDED AN
ELIGIBLE FOUR YEAR INSTITUTIONS
AB FOURTEEN FIFTY SIX
ELIMINATES THE NEED FOR THE
COMPETITIVE CAL GRANT PROGRAMS
AND OPENS UP OF DISABILITY TO
CAL GRANT EIGHT TO NEARLY TWO
HUNDRED THOUSAND MORE
CALIFORNIA STUDENTS. FINALLY A.
B. FOURTEEN FIFTY SIX WILL
ALIGN STATE AND FEDERAL
FINANCIAL AID POLICIES TO
CREATE A MORE COORDINATED
APPROACH TO INVESTMENTS IN
COLLEGE AFFORDABILITY. I AM
PLEASED TO HAVE WORKED WITH OUR
STAKEHOLDERS ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MCCARTY ENSURE LABOR ON THIS
BILL- ON THIS BILL AND ALSO IN
THE BUDGET. THE BUDGET DEAL FOR
TWENTY TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWENTY
TWO COMPLIMENTS A. B. FOURTEEN
FIFTY SIX. WITH THE BUDGET DEAL
WE WILL BE ABLE TO ENACT PHASE
ONE OF AB FOURTEEN FIFTY SIX
AND EXPAND ACCESS TO MANY MORE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE STUDENTS.
THIS BILL HAS LARGE BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT. IN THE ASSEMBLY AND I
AM PLEASED TO ADD TODAY'S
COMMITTEE TO ACCEPT TODAY'S
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS WHICH
INCLUDE OUR VICE CHAIR AS CO
AUTHOR. HERE TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT IS JAKE BRIMMER FROM
THE STUDENT AID COMMISSION AND
CRYSTAL RANGE FROM THE CSU
BOARD OF TRUSTEES. VERY GOOD
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ASSEMBLY
MEMBER AND JAKE YOU'RE HERE IN
PERSON PLEASE PROCEED YOU HAVE
TWO MINUTES. THANK YOU AND GOOD
MORNING CHAIR LEYVA AND
SENATORS I'M JAKE BRUNNER I'M
SERVED AS THE DIRECTOR OF
GOVERNMENT AND EXTERNAL
RELATIONS AT THE CALIFORNIA
STUDENT AID COMMISSION. AB
FOURTEEN FIFTY SIX REFLECTS
WORK THAT HAS BEEN YEARS IN THE
MAKING TO SIMPLIFY AND EXPAND
THE CAL GRANT PROGRAMS
INCLUDING A DELIBERATIVE
PROCESS IN WHICH STUDENTS
HIGHER EDUCATION SEGMENTS AND
OTHER EDUCATION ADVOCATES CAME
TOGETHER IN THE CAL GRANT
REFORM. WORK GROUP- TO THE
ONSET OF KOBE NINETEEN
CALIFORNIA STUDENTS WERE
ALREADY STRUGGLING TO MEET
THEIR BASIC NEEDS FOOD AND
HOUSING AS THEY PURSUE HIGHER
EDUCATION. WE KNOW THAT KOBE
NINETEEN AND THE RELATED
ECONOMIC IMPACTS I'VE ONLY
COMPOUNDED THAT CHALLENGE WHEN
WE SURVEYED SEVENTY SIX
THOUSAND INCOMING RETURNING
COLLEGE STUDENTS LAST YEAR.
MORE THAN SEVEN OUT OF TEN
INDICATED THAT THEY OR THEIR
FAMILY LOST SOME OR ALL OF
THEIR INCOME DO TO COPE IN
NINETEEN. AND THE FOLLOWING
SURVEY STUDENTS REPORTED THAT
THEIR COSTS FOR PUTIN HOUSING
INCREASE DURING THE PANDEMIC.
ALL THIS YEAR'S BUDGET MAKES A
HISTORIC EXPANSION TO CAL GRANT
ELIGIBILITY FOR WHICH WE ARE
VERY GRATEFUL TO THE
LEGISLATURE AND GOVERNOR. THERE
WILL STILL BE BARRIERS TO
STUDENTS IN ACCESSING CAL GRANT
A IN THAT ARE NOT BASED ON
THEIR FINANCIAL NEED OR ABILITY
TO BENEFIT FROM HIGHER
EDUCATION. AB FOURTEEN FIFTY
SIX REMOVES THE SPINAL BARRIERS
TO ALLOW US TO BEST LEVERAGE
THESE NEW INVESTMENTS FOR
STUDENTS. AB FOURTEEN FIFTY SIX
ALSO STREAMLINED THE CAL GRANTS
SYSTEM BY ESTABLISHING THE CAL
GRANT TO AND THE CAL GRANT FOR
WHICH REFLECT THE UNIQUE NEEDS
OF STUDENTS AT COMMUNITY
COLLEGES. AND FOUR YEAR
INSTITUTIONS RESPECTIVELY THE
SYSTEM WILL BE EASIER FOR
STUDENTS AND FAMILIES
PARTICULARLY WHO ARE FIRST
GENERATION COLLEGE GOERS. TO
UNDERSTAND AND PLAN AROUND. ON
BEHALF OF THE STUDENT AID
COMMISSION WE THANK ASSEMBLY
MEMBERS MEDINA AND MCCARTY FOR
THEIR LEADERSHIP ON THIS
BECAUSE AS WELL AS CARE LEYVA.
AND ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT OF
THIS CRITICAL LEGISLATION.
THANK YOU FOR AND I'M HERE TO
HELP WITH ANY QUESTIONS THANK
YOU MUCH APPRECIATED. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER YOUR NEXT WITNESS I HAD
SOMEONE ELSE DIFFERENT LISTED
BUT IS YOUR DID YOUR WITNESS
CALL IN. YEAH SHE'S ON THE LINE
NOW SHE'S NOT COMING ON LATER
ON. BEAUTIFUL THANK YOU VERY
MUCH SO WE ARE LOOKING FOR
ALEXIS ZARAGOZA. IF YOU'RE
HONOR PLEASE PROCEDURE OF TWO
MINUTES. YES THANK YOU SO MUCH
CHAIR- AND HELLO TO THE SENATE
EDUCATION COMMITTEE MEMBERS HI
MY NAME IS ELECTED I THINK THIS
IS ERICA THAT. LEAH REGION ON
THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
BUT IT REGION AND ALL THE
GREATEST NUMBER ON THE
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGES
BOARD OF GOVERNORS. DURING MY
TIME BUSINESS DO AND I'M OF THE
BOARD I FOUND MYSELF.
INTERTWINED WITH THE-
HEALTHCARE. I'M NOT HERE ON
BEHALF OF MY CURRENT FOR I
THINK IT DIDN'T. AND FACULTY
ACROSS ALL OF THE CALIFORNIA.
THE TRAFFIC. WE MADE A VERSION
HOW TO HANDLE CAMP POLICY WE
KNOW ONE THING. OUR NEED TO
SERVE MORE THAN EVER. WE ARE
GRATEFUL FOR THE SUPPORT WE'VE
GOTTEN THAT FAR THIS PROCESS
BUT THERE IMPAIR TO FEASIBLE
THE SO I SHOULD BE NOTED AS
ESSENTIAL FROM A STUDENT
PERSPECTIVE. IT WOULD BE
REMOVAL OF BARRIERS AND A LONG
TERM. PLAN IN PLACE FOR
SIMPLIFICATION CONTINUE FUNDING.
BARRIERS ARE TRACTORS FOR
EDUCATE YEAH. TO BE CONTINUED
ARE TO BE ROOM UPON THE BRING
ONE CLEAR TO. ANYONE GO TO
COLLEGE AGE ONE AT THE TIME AT
HIGH SCHOOL AND IT DID THE
IMPACT PARENTS AND ADULTS
RETURNING TO WORK OUR STUDENTS.
TO LIVE IN AREAS OF MORE
INDUSTRIAL WORK IN PRISONS AND
THERE ARE COLLEGES ARE MORE
LIKELY TO HAVE THIS KIND OF. MY
HIGH SCHOOL AS PRIMARILY
HISPANIC AND HAD KIDS GOING TO
AMAZON FASHION. WITH THE- WE
CANNOT WONDER WHY RACIAL EQUITY
IS STAGNANT WE DON'T ADDRESS
THE ROOT CAUSES. YOU SHOULD NOT
BE PUNISHED FOR HAVING LIFE TO
BE LIKE. A DECISION TO GO LATER
IN LIFE ARE OFTEN MORE
DEDICATED BUT WE-NEED TO GO TO
COLLEGE WITHOUT WORKING AND
POSSIBILITY OF TRACTOR. OR TO
BE REMOVED HIS GPA I DON'T FEEL
LIKE A NORM TO MAINTAIN A GPA
REQUIREMENT BUT IN CALIFORNIA
WERE KNOWN TO BREAK THE STATUS
QUO. I THINK THAT ACADEMIC
STATUS ESPECIALLY FOR THEIR
FIRST WITH THE MASTERS AFTER
BEING AWAY FROM SCHOOL WHILE OR
COMING FROM UNDERFUNDED SCHOOL
CAN BE DIFFICULT. WITH NEGATIVE
DST THAT TAKING AWAY OUR LACK
OF FUNDING BASED ON HAVING A
MORE DIFFICULT TIME IT'S A
DECISION DOCTOR BUT WHETHER OR
NOT THEY CAN CONTINUE AN
INCREASE. INTO OUR FUNDED
PROPERLY ARE LESS LIKELY TO GET
A JOB AND THEIR WORK AND HAVE
TIME TO EXPLORE FEELS GOOD TO
DRINK AND FIND WHAT THEY LIVE.
IN A NAVAL AFFORDABILITY.
ADDITIONALLY THE PUBLICATION IS
ESSENTIAL IN THE PROFIT THE
COUNTER BEFORE WITHOUT IT
PEOPLE TRIP. OVER AND- WHAT I
HAVE BUSINESS COMMITTEE AND A
MEMBER CAN NOW ONLY A THE
FORWARD BUT YEAH. THE EFFORT
FOR YEARS COME. WE NEED
CONTINUED THE- TO ENSURE THAT
IS WITH THE PROGRESS. IN
CARMICHAEL AFTER. AND NOT OF
THE SHORT TERM. TO WE KNOW.
ONLY COMPETE TO WORK AND IF WE
CAN ACCEPT. I THINK HE OFFER
LIKE ME TO BE. AND OPEN TO
QUESTION. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
RIGHT WE'LL GO WITH. IN SUPPORT
HERE IN ROOM FOR TWO- THREE
STATE YOUR NAY AND PARKING AND
YOUR- PLEASE. I'M SURE. GOOD
MEMBERS MANY IDEAS FOR HOW THEY
AGREED CAN MAKE HISTORY. VERY
MUCH IN SUPPORT ALSO ON THE
FACT OF THE L. OFFERS. MEDINA
MCCARTY AND IF OF COURSE YOU
CENTER LEYVA WE'RE LEADERSHIP
ON THIS CAL GRANT REFORM
PACKAGE THAT YOU'VE BEEN
WORKING ON FOR YEARS. THANK YOU
SIR MUCH APPRECIATED. NEXT GOOD
MORNING CHIRLA MEMBERS KITCHEN
ISLAND IN ON BEHALF OF THE
CAMPAIGN FOR COLLEGE
OPPORTUNITY IN SUPPORT OF AB
FOURTEEN FIFTY SIX TODAY THANK
YOU THANK YOU. MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS JEFF PARKER
REPRESENTING THE RIVERSIDE
COUNTY SUPERINTENDENT OF
SCHOOLS IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING COMMITTEE MY NAME
IS ANASTASIA SIMONOVA I'M THE
FORMER STUDENT OF SOMEONE A
COMMUNITY COLLEGE AND THE
TRANSFER STUDENTS AT UC
BERKELEY AND I FULLY SUPPORT A.
B. FOURTEEN FIFTY SIX THANK YOU
THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT SEE NO ONE
ELSE IN SUPPORT HIM FORTY TWO
OH THREE WILL GO TO OUR
OVERFLOW ROOM SEEING NO ONE
THERE MADAME MODERATOR CAN YOU
PLEASE QUEUE UP ANYONE WHO
WISHES TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF.
AB FOURTEEN FIFTY SIX. THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OF AB FOURTEEN FIFTY
SIX. FIVE ONE ZERO. AND THE
OPERATOR WILL PROVIDE YOU WITH
YOUR LINE NUMBER AND PUT YOU
BACK INTO Q. ONCE AGAIN IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT. OF AB
FOURTEEN FIFTY SIX. PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN THEIR OWN NOW.
SO WOULD LINE NUMBER ONE TWENTY
TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD CARE AND MEMBERS-
HANNAH BAG THAT LOOK THE CALL
STATE UNIFICATION IN STRONG
SUPPORT. MY NUMBER SIXTY TWO
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING THIS IS
JUSTIN HIGHER WITH THE SILICON
VALLEY LEADERSHIP GROUP IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL THANK YOU.
WHY NUMBER EIGHTY TWO YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK
YOU GOOD MORNING CHARLIE AND I
AM A THE COMPANY MANY IN THE
CHIKAN STEVEN ON THE SENIOR
STAFF ATTORNEY WITH PUBLIC
ADVOCATE MARK IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF AB. FOURTEEN FIFTY SIX. MY
NUMBER THIRTY FOUR YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. CAN WE
WILL I'M STATE AND A
CONVERGENCE SENATORS NINE ON
BEHALF OF THE BOARD OUTNUMBERED
CHINA I THOUGHT IT WOULD THINK
THAT THANK SHOULD. MY NUMBER
SIX ONE ONE IS OPEN PLEASE GO.
AND MORE STEPHANIE GOLDMAN- ON
BEHALF OF THE ASSOCIATION OF
THE COMMUNITY COLLEGES IN
SUPPORT. MY NUMBER ONE TWENTY
NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. THE MORNING THIS IS
INCREASING EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
OF CALIFORNIA EDGE COALITION
CALLING IN SUPPORT OF AB
FOURTEEN FIFTY SIX. MY NUMBER
SIXTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
KAREN MEMBERS MARK MCDONALD-
GEOGRAPHY THREE ON BEHALF OF.
SAN DIEGO SAN BERNADINO NO
COMMENT YUBA COMMUNITY COLLEGE
DISTRICTS IN SUPPORT OF THE
MEASURE THANK. MY NUMBER
SEVENTY EIGHT ONE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
SURE LEYVA AND MEMBERS. EAST
COMMITTEE MENYERAHKAN THE
PUBLIC HEALTH EDUCATION TRUST
WEST SUPPORT. MY NUMBER ONE
THIRTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
CAROL GONZALEZ ON THE HAVE THE
LOS ANGELES COMMUNITY COLLEGE
DISTRICT AND THE POOR. MY
NUMBER ONE FORTY ONE I WANTED
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI THIS
IS DANIELLE ONE DRUG WITH
CHILDREN NOW CALLING IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU THANK YOU. BLIND
NUMBER ONE TWENTY SIX YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING NINE HUNDRED AND WITH
WIDENING GROUP ON BEHALF OF
NEXT GEN CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT.
MY NUMBER ONE TWENTY FIVE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD MORNING RIGHT NOT GOING
INTO A COMMUNITY COLLEGE LEAGUE
OF CALIFORNIA REPRESENTING
CALIFORNIA SEVENTY THREE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE DISTRICTS AND
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
MY NUMBER FORTY THREE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING ONLY THE CAR ON BEHALF
OF THE UC STUDENTS ASSOCIATION
THEIR PRESENT IN THE BODY OF
OVER TWO HUNDRED EIGHTY FIVE
THOUSAND STUDENTS OF THE UC
SYSTEM WE ARE IN SHOCK SUPPORT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. MY NUMBER
EIGHTY THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
MY NAME IS SHANTI PRASAD THE
LEGISLATIVE AFFAIRS DEVICE FOR
THE LEGISLATIVE AFFAIRS FROM
HIS BANK ACCOUNT FRANKLY
COLLEGES REPRESENTING TWO POINT
ONE MILLION STUDENTS AND WE ARE
IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. MY NUMBER ONE TWENTY
EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING MADAM
CHAIR MEMBERS RON RAPP SPEAKING
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
FACULTY ASSOCIATION AND SUPPORT.
MY NUMBER FIFTEEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING GENESIS GONZALEZ
CALLING ON BEHALF OF THE OFFICE
OF THE PANIC OF AMERICA MANY
COULD UNLOCK IT IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF AB FOURTEEN THIRTY
SIX THANK YOU. THANK YOU. WHY
NUMBER NINETY TWO YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING MY NAME IS ALLISON CHAN
AMERICAN GRADUATE FROM KENYATTA
COLLEGE AND STUDENT AT UCLA AND
ALSO MEMBER JANET IN SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
MY NUMBER ONE TWENTY SEVEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
JUSTIN FILMIC ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGES
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU. MY
NUMBER ONE FORTY SEVEN THE LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
ANNA FONG FROM THE INSTITUTE
FOR COLLEGE ACCESS AND SUCCESS
IN SUPPORT OF AB FOURTEEN FIFTY
SIX AS AMENDED APRIL TWELFTH
THIS BILL BUILDS UPON REACHING
THE NEXT CALLER PLEASE. COMMENT
I'M SURE THERE'S NO ONE ELSE IN
Q. THANK YOU MADAM MODERATOR
ALREADY DO NOT HAVE ANYONE
LISTED AS LEAD OPPOSITION IS
THERE ANYONE HERE IN THE ROOM
WHO IS SUPPOSED TO AB FOURTEEN
FIFTY SIX. SAYING NO ONE WILL
COULD OR OVERFLOW ROOM SEEING
NO ONE THERE MADAM MODERATOR
CAN YOU PLEASE QUEUE UP ANYONE
WHO WISHES TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION TO AB FOUR. FOURTEEN
FIFTY SIX. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR WELL DON'T MIND IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF
AB FOURTEEN FIFTY SIX. PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO. AN OPERATOR WILL
PROVIDE YOU WITH YOUR LINE
NUMBER AND PUT YOU BACK IN THE
QUEUE. TO GET IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF AB
FOURTEEN FIFTY SIX. CONTRAST
WANTED THEIR OWN NOW. IN ONE
MOMENT MANAGER WE DO HAVE SOME
TUNE UP AT THE MOMENT. THANK
YOU. IT LOOKS LIKE THEY REMOVED
THEMSELVES SO WE HAVE NO ONE TO
MEDICARE GREAT THANK YOU MADAM
MODERATOR I WILL COME BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE DO WE HAVE YES
SENATOR DOLLY. THE MANAGER I
GOT A QUESTION THE- WE HEARD A
LOT OF THE- TWO BRICK AND
MORTAR. INSTITUTIONS BUT- WHAT
WHAT PROVISIONS IN THIS BILL
WILL HELP CROWDER AND STUDENTS.
WHO ATTEND. THE ONLINE- OR THE
CREDIT ONLINE SCHOOLS YOU KNOW
FOR THOSE WHO HAVE WORKING
FAMILIES ARE GEOGRAPHIC ISSUES-
IN ARE THEY FULLY CREDIT ONLINE
INSTITUTIONS THAT MAY NOT
PHYSICALLY BE LOCATED IN
CALIFORNIA. I'M A- PASSCODE
JAKE FROM THE STUDENT AID
COMMISSION IF HE COULD ANSWER
THAT QUESTION. YES TANK YOU
FOR THE QUESTION SENATOR DOLLY
THEIR EXISTING PROVISIONS IN
STATE LAW THAT GOVERNED BY-
WHICH- INSTITUTIONS OF HIGHER
EDUCATION ARE ELIGIBLE TO
PARTICIPATE IN THE CAL GRANT
PROGRAMS THAT DOES REQUIRE THAT
THERE BE A PHYSICAL PRESENCE
FOR AN INSTITUTION IN THE STATE
THIS LEGISLATION DOES NOT.
AMEND THAT PROVISION. AND I
WOULD JUST SAY CAL GRANT
CIRCLED CAL GRANT FOR REASON
THEIR FIRST TWO GAMES HERE IN
CALIFORNIA BUT RIGHT I KNOW YOU
CAN BE IN CALIFORNIA. ONLINE
IT'S NOT A PHYSICAL PRESENCE
YEAH SO LIKE I HAVE. LASSEN
COUNTY FOR EXAMPLE FOR OUR I
RESIDE WE HAVE AN AGREEMENT
WITH UNIVERSITY OF NEVADA TO BE
ABLE TO. IN AND IT'S ACTUALLY-
TO THOSE DOES. LASSEN COUNTY
RESIDENTS WON'T BE ABLE TO
ACCESS ONLINE AND USE A CAL
GRANT. CORRECT.
LEAVE THAT ON
CALL ASSEMBLY MEMBER IT HAS
BEEN NICE TO SPEND ABOUT AN
HOUR TO HELP WITH YOU TODAY
HAVE A GREAT REST OF THE DAY
YOU'RE QUITE WELCOME ALRIGHT WE
ARE MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM FOR
AB FOUR SIXTY NINE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER REYES IS. PLEASE PROCEED
WHEN YOU'RE READY. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS. I
PRESENTED TO YOU AB FOUR SIXTY
NINE WHICH REQUIRES LOCAL
EDUCATIONAL AGENCIES TO ENSURE
ALL HIGH SCHOOL SENIORS
COMPLETE THE FAST FOUR OR THE
CALIFORNIA DREAM ACT
APPLICATION FOR FINANCIAL AID
BEFORE GRADUATING FROM HIGH
SCHOOL. COVERT NINETEEN HAS
EXACERBATED THE INEQUITIES
STUDENTS FACE WHEN APPLYING TO
COLLEGE IN THE PAST YEAR STATES
ARE SIGNIFICANT DECREASE IN
FAPSON CALIFORNIA DREAM ACT
APPLICATIONS. AND UNFORTUNATELY
THE LARGEST IMPACTS WERE FELT
BY LOW INCOME AND MINORITY
STUDENTS. IN THE LAST TWO YEARS
ALONE MANY OF OUR HIGH SCHOOL
SENIORS IN CALIFORNIA DID NOT
COMPLETE THE APPLICATIONS
LEAVING AN ESTIMATED FIVE
HUNDRED AND FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS IN STATE AND FEDERAL
FINANCIAL AID ON THE TABLE. AB
FOUR SIXTY NINE INSURERS ALL
STUDENTS GET THE SUPPORT THEY
NEED TO SUPPORT SUBMIT CRITICAL
FORMS FOR FINANCIAL AID. BY
REQUIRING THE COMPLETION OF
FINANCIAL AID APPLICATIONS
CALIFORNIA WILL JOIN STATES
LIKE LOUISIANA TENNESSEE AND
TEXAS WHICH HAVE ALREADY
IMPLEMENTED STATEWIDE POLICIES
AND I'VE SEEN THEIR STUDENTS
REAP THE BENEFITS. AT THE LOCAL
LEVEL WE DO HAVE VAL VERDE
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT IN
PERRIS UNION HIGH SCHOOL
DISTRICT AND RIVERSIDE WHO ARE
REQUIRING THIS FOR GRADUATION.
AND THERE. THE FINANCIAL AID
FUNDING THAT THEIR STUDENTS
SERVICE RECEIVED IS FAR GREATER
THAN MOST OTHER DISTRICTS HERE
TO TESTIFY TODAY IN SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL OR CUT THE LEAN OUT
C. FRONT THIS. CHAIR OF THE
CALIFORNIA STUDENT AID
COMMISSION AND EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF COLLEGE AND CAREER
READINESS AT THE RIVERSIDE
COUNTY OFFICE OF EDUCATION AS
WELL AS MIKE MCCORMICK
SUPERINTENDENT VALVE ALREADY
UNION SCHOOL DISTRICT. THANK
YOU ASSEMBLY WOMAN ALL RIGHT WE
WILL GO TO YOUR FIRST LEAD
WITNESS MISS THE POINT IS IF
YOU'RE READY HAVE TWO MINUTES.
GOOD MORNING CHARLIE VENTANA
MEMBERS MY NAME'S TONY FINDS
THAT THE NINETY DAYS AFTER THE
DIRECTOR OF COLLEGE AND CAREER
READINESS IN RIVERSIDE COUNTY
AND SERVE OVER FOUR HUNDRED AND
TWENTY THOUSAND K. TWELVE
STUDENTS. I'M ALL FOR THE
CULTURE OF THE CALIFORNIANS IN
THE COMMISSION I'M HERE SEARCH
YOUR SUPPORT TO ENSURE
EQUITABLE OPPORTUNITIES FOR ALL
CALIFORNIA STUDENTS BECAUSE
THEY'RE THEY'RE COMPLEMENTARY
DREAMS. REGARDLESS OF THE HIGH
SCHOOL BUT COLLEGE THE FACT
HAVE CONDUCTED MULTIPLE STUDENT
SERVICE INCLUDING THE THIRD
SERVE ALCOHOLIC YOU KNOW WHAT
I'VE BEEN REPAIRS TO COLLEGE
ENROLLMENT AND COMPLETION. TO
WALKING WITH THEM THEY WERE NOT
ACADEMICALLY PREPARED BUT WHAT
WE HAVE LEARNED IS THE GREATEST
BEREDAR STUDENTS. COLLEGE
AFFORDABILITY SO OFTEN IN MY
WILL THE STUDENTS ARE WORKING
TWO JOBS TO PAY FOR COLLEGE AND
PROVIDE ONE ALBUM ABOUT THE
FINANCIAL AID AWARD LETTER HERE
I WAS JUST CONFUSED SO I DIDN'T
SUBMIT MY FAST BUT I FIGURED I
COULD PAY ON MY ON EACH EACH
YEAR CALIFORNIA STUDENTS WITH
MORE IN THE FINANCIALLY DOLLARS
ON THE CABLE. PROGRAMS FEDERAL
DOLLARS THAT COULD BE BROUGHT
BACK TO A STATE THAT FURTHER
SUPPORT THEIR FUTURE NOT
CONTENT. WE NEED A CERTAIN
COLLEGE AFFORDABILITY
CONVERSATIONS EARLY AND IN K.
TWELVE. WORKING CALIFORNIA K.
TWELVE STUDENTS THAT WE POINT
SIX MILLION STUDENTS LAST YEAR
ARE CLOSING. DISADVANTAGE AND
ARE MOST LIKELY FIRST
GENERATION. COLLEGE STUDENT.
COOL THE PENDANT FOR INJURIES.
AND COUNTY WE HAVE DATA SHOW WE
INCREASED EIGHT MAGIC. COLLEGE
AND HAVE THE HARDWARE. RATE
PROVIDE COUNTY IN THE STATE OF
THE POWER YEAR. THESE THE
FUNDING INFORMED MY PHONE ON
CALL FOR. ONE OF TELL AND
FAMILIES YOU FOR CALLING. HELP
THEM FOR THE- DURING THOSE. DAY
THE HIGH SCHOOL THAT. BECOME
BALL YES. I COULD A FOCUS ON
GOING DIVISION BETWEEN BACK IN
THE CAL. COMMON OF THE- ALL BE
BY THIS. THE FESTIVAL SCHOOL.
BELIEVE CURRENTLY LEVELS ON YOU
CAN HAVE COME THE- PROCESS. AND
MOMENT YOU'VE BEEN. OUR SCHOOLS
AND WE NEED LIVE DATA FROM.
THEM. MCCORMICK PLEASE PROCEED
WHEN YOU'RE READY OF TWO
MINUTES. MY NAME IS MICHAEL
MCCORMACK I'M THE PROUD
SUPERINTENDENT OF ALREADY
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT WE
SERVE A VERY DIVERSE COMMUNITY
OF JUST OVER TWENTY THOUSAND
SCHOLARS LOCATED IN RIVERSIDE
COUNTY. SOME OF OUR MAJOR
DEMOGRAPHICS INCLUDE 75% LATIN
ACTS 13% AFRICAN AMERICAN A
FIFTH OF OUR STUDENTS ARE
LEARNING ENGLISH AS A SECOND
LANGUAGE IN APPROXIMATELY 84%
OF OUR STUDENTS PARTICIPATE IN
THE NATIONAL SCHOOL LUNCH
PROGRAM. ACCORDING TO THE
LUMINA FOUNDATION REPORT A
STRONGER NATION APPROXIMATELY
29% OF RESIDENTS IN OUR
METROPOLITAN REGION HAVE
OBTAINED A POST SECONDARY
DEGREE AS COMPARED TO THE
NATIONAL AVERAGE OF FIFTY ONE
POINT 9% THIS COUPLED WITH THE
FACT THAT NEARLY A HALF A
BILLION DOLLARS IN CALIFORNIA
ALONE IS LEFT ON THE TABLE AND
UNCLAIMED FINANCIAL AID FOR
GRADUATING SENIORS. SERVED AS
OUR WIDE TO MAKE FAST WEARING
CAT A COMPLETION REQUIREMENT
FOR SCHOOL DISTRICTS WE KNOW
THAT MANY OF OUR SCHOLARS WILL
BE FIRST GENERATION COLLEGE
GRADUATES AND WE ALSO KNEW THAT
WE NEEDED TO SYSTEMATICALLY
REMOVE THE NUMBER ONE BARRIER
TO COLLEGE ACCESS
AFFORDABILITY. WE BOYS ANY
TRAILING VALERIE NOT FOR FAME
OR ATTENTION BUT BECAUSE WE
KNEW THE MAJORITY OF OUR
STUDENTS WILL BE ABLE TO ACCESS
CAL GRANTS FREE MONEY FOR
COLLEGE. TWENTY SEVENTEEN THE
BOARD OF EDUCATION VOTED
UNANIMOUSLY TO SUPPORT FASTER
AND CATA COMPLETION. CREATING A
COLLEGE GOING CULTURE SUPPORTED
BY ALL LEVELS OF THE
ORGANIZATION HAS BEEN THE KEY
TO OUR SUCCESS. THIS WHOLE
SYSTEM FOCUS HAS PRODUCED SOME
AMAZING RESULTS OVERALL HIGH
SCHOOL GRADUATION RATES OF
NINETY SIX PERCENT. LARGEST
INCREASE IN A THREE G. RATES
RIVERSIDE COUNTY TO SIXTY TWO
POINT SEVEN PERCENT. AND A
COLLEGE GOING RATE OF 67% WITH
A NUMBER OF CAL GRANT
SKYROCKETING. SUPPORTING ARE
UNDOCUMENTED AND MIXED STATUS
FAMILIES HAS BEEN A PASSION OF
OURS WE PARTNER WITH KODAK OF
FIBER ONE C. THREE NON PROFIT
IMMIGRATION RIGHTS
ORGANIZATION. TO ENSURE
FAMILIES HAVE TRUSTED
INFORMATION REGARDING FAST AND
GOT A COMPLETION FINALLY IT'S
IMPORTANT NOTE THAT ENTIRE
EFFORT HAS BEEN COMPLEX
OPERATION WITHIN OUR EXISTING
BUDGETS COSTING ZERO ADDITIONAL
DOLLARS. I DIDN'T FOR A TO JOIN
THIS MOVEMENT WE'VE INVESTED
THIRTEEN YEARS OF EDUCATION
INTO OUR STUDENTS. AND
CALIFORNIA HAS SET ASIDE THE
MONEY TO REMOVE THE NUMBER ONE
BARRIER TO HIGHER EDUCATION.
WHY DON'T WE GIVE OUR STUDENTS
ANOTHER FORTY FIVE MINUTES TO
COMPLETE THEIR FINANCIAL AID
APPLICATIONS THANK YOU. THANK
YOU ALL RIGHT WE'LL MOVE TO
SUPPORT HERE IN ROOM FORTY TWO-
THREE PLEASE STATE YOUR NAME
AND YOUR SUPPORT FOR THE BILL.
GOOD MORNING AGAIN TO CHANNEL
AND THEN ON BEHALF OF THE
CAMPAIGN FOR COLLEGE
OPPORTUNITY IN STRONG SUPPORT.
OF AB FOUR SIX NINE THANK YOU.
JAKE BRUNNER ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA STUDENT AID
COMMISSION IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL. THANK YOU. FOR IT WILL
MOVE TO OUR OVERFLOW ROOM
SAYING NO ONE WILL GO TO THE
PHONE LINES. MATAMATA RICKY
PLEASE QUEUE UP ANYONE WHO
WISHES TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF
AB FOUR SIXTY NINE. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OF AB FOUR SIXTY
NINE. PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO. AN OPERATOR WILL PROVIDE
YOU WITH YOUR LINE NUMBER AND
PLACE YOU BACK INTO Q. ONCE
AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF AB FOUR FIFTY NINE.
CONTRAST ONE ZERO NOW. MY
NUMBER ONE EIGHTEEN THE LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING REBECCA GONZALEZ
NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL
WORKERS CALIFORNIA CHAPTER
INPUT COSTS. MY NUMBER THIRTY
FOUR YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME IS
KIMBERLY WILL UNFORTUNATELY.
JACK AND I STRONG. NOW THANK
YOU THANK YOU. MY NUMBER ONE
SEVENTY TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
ERIKA ROMERO ON BEHALF OF THE
HISPANIC ASSOCIATION OF
COLLEGES AND UNIVERSITIES
CALLING STRONG SUPPORT THANK
YOU. MY NUMBER ONE SEVENTY
SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING CAROLINE
BALANCE A PREVIOUS POVERTY
UNIFIED GRADUATE CALLING ON
BEHALF OF LOS ANGELES COMMUNITY
COLLEGE DISTRICT THE COURT. MY
NUMBER ONE TWENTY SIX YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING I HAVE EVER DONE WITH
WIDENING GROUP ON BEHALF OF
NEXT IN CALIFORNIA AND SUPPORT
THANK YOU. MY NUMBER ONE SIXTY
FOUR YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. SHRAN RAP SPEAKING ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
FACULTY ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT
OF AB FOUR SIXTY NINE THANK YOU.
MY NUMBER NINETY TWO YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING MY NAME IS ALLISON CHEN
UNDERSTOOD AT UCLA AND A MEMBER
OF JANET AND I AM IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THE BILL THANK YOU.
MY NUMBER FORTY THREE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING AND LEAVE THE CAR IN
BEHALF OF UC STUDENT
ASSOCIATION WE ARE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF AB FOUR SIXTY NINE
THANK YOU. MY NUMBER ONE SIXTY
THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR
MEMBERS OF THE LESLIE VASQUEZ
WITH THE LEAGUE OF WOMEN VOTERS
OF CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU. MY NUMBER EIGHTY FIVE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
TRANSITION CATHOLIC SCHOOL
ADMINISTRATORS NOT QUITE THANK
YOU THANK YOU. MY NUMBER
SEVENTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THE MORNING
SURELY REMEMBERS MANGEL THREE
YEARS ON THE OFFICE FISH. THE
BILL THANK YOU. THANK YOU. AND
AT THIS TIME MADAM CHAIR WE
HAVE NO ONE ELSE CAN QUEUE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MATTER
MODERATOR WE HAVE NO LEAD
OPPOSITION IS THERE ANYONE HERE
IN FORTY TWO OH THREE WHICH IS
BUSH'S TO OPPOSE THING THEN WE
WILL GO TO OUR OVERFLOW ROOM.
SINGING NUN MATTER MODERATOR
CAN YOU PLEASE KEEP ANYONE WHO
WISHES TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
OF AB FOUR SIXTY NINE. THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR. LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION. AB FOUR SIXTY
NINE CONSTRUCTS ONE THEN ZERO.
AND THE OPERATOR WILL PROVIDE
YOU WITH YOUR LINE NUMBER.
PLACE YOU BACK INTO Q. ONCE
AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION OF AB FOUR SIXTY
NINE. PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
THERE ARE NOW. AT THIS TIME AND
I'M SURE WE HAVE NO ONE ELSE IN
Q. THANK YOU VERY MUCH MATAMATA
WRITER WILL BRING IT BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE TO HAVE ANY.
QUESTIONS CONCERNS OR COMMENTS.
THING THANK YOU VERY MUCH
SENATOR CORTESE. MADAM ASSEMBLY
WOMAN WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE.
I JUST WANT TO REMIND US ALL
THAT IT STATISTICS SHOW THAT.
IF A SENIOR FILLS OUT A
COUNSELOR OR A CAT OF FORM
THEIR SIXTY PARTS 63% MORE
LIKELY TO GO TO COLLEGE. AND IN
IN THAT REGARD I DO
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR VOTE
ON THE THINK YOU VERY MUCH THE
BILL HAS BEEN MOVED BY SENATOR
CORTESE MADAM CONSULTANT PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. FILE ITEM NUMBER
FOR A BI FOR SIXTY NINE THE
MOTION IS TO PASS BUT FIRST BE
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS SENATOR LEYVA
AYE LEYVA AYE OCHO ABODE I.
CHOI BOGUE AYE COURTESY. CURTIS
THE AYE DALY. GLAZER MCGUIRE
PAN. WE WILL LEAVE THAT BILL ON
CALL. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
ASSEMBLY WOMAN HAVE A GREAT DAY.
ALL RIGHT I DO BELIEVE WE'RE
HERE AND SENATE EDUCATION
LOOKING FOR AUTHORS. ALL AND I
THINK WE JUST GOT ONE PERFECT
TIMING ASSEMBLY MEMBER GIPSON.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GIPSON IS
PRESENTING ITEM NUMBER FIVE AB
FIVE TWENTY BEGIN WHEN YOU'RE
READY. THANK.
THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS
GOOD MORNING THANK YOU FOR
ALLOWING ME TO PRESENT ASSEMBLY
BILL FIVE TWENTY WHICH WOULD
ECSTATIC CALIFORNIA
DIVERSIFYING THE TEACHER
WORKFORCE GRANT PROGRAM THIS
GRANT WOULD SUPPORT A NEW OR
EXISTING LOCAL EFFORTS AIMED TO
BUILD A MORE DIVERSE TEACHER
WORKFORCE THAT MORE CLOSELY
REPRESENTS OUR STUDENTS ACROSS
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA THIS
EFFORT IS BASED ON A PILOT
PROGRAM BY THE COUNTY UNIFIED
SCHOOL DISTRICT WHICH IS IN MY
DISTRICT TO IMPROVE RETENTION
RATES OF MALE TEACHERS OF
COLOR. WHO HAVE SOME OF THE
LOWER RETENTION RATES TODAY MEN
OF COLOR REPRESENTS LESS THAN
10% OF CALIFORNIA'S TEACHER
WORKFORCE OF THAT 10% BLACKS
AND LATINO MALES MAKES UP 122%
BUT- STUDENTS OF COLOR MAKES UP
75% OF CALIFORNIA STUDENTS
POPULATION. THESE ARE
TREMENDOUS DIFFERENCES IN THE
BIGGER PICTURE THIS IS THIS IS
REALLY ABOUT STUDENTS WHEN
STUDENTS CAN IDENTIFY WITH
THEIR TEACHER AND SEE
THEMSELVES AS ROLE MODELS THEY
ULTIMATELY. ARE MORE SUCCESSFUL
IN SCHOOL THEY SHOW A GREATER
CONFIDENCE AND PROPEL THEM TO
PURSUE AND ACHIEVE THEIR DREAMS
AND ASPIRATIONS THIS IS WHERE
THE POWER REALLY COMES FROM. WE
REGULARLY TALK ABOUT EQUITY
THIS BILL WILL PUT IN PLACE
EQUITY FRONT AND CENTER AS A
PRIORITY TO IMPROVE STUDENT
ACHIEVEMENT WE NEED TO CREATE A
BETTER SPACE. FOR OUR STUDENTS
TO GROW TO LEARN AND SUCCEED
FAR MORE THAN WHAT ANY NUMBER-
HAVE SHOWN IN THE PAST AB FIVE
TWENTY WOULD PROVIDE THE RIGHT
SUPPORT TO DIVERT TO DIVERSIFY
THE TEACHER WORKFORCE TO MORE
ACCURATELY REFLECT THE STUDENTS
THEY SERVE. JOINING ME TO
PROVIDE SUPPORTING TESTIMONY ON
THE PHONE I'M HAPPY TO
INTRODUCE- THE CALIFORNIA
SUPERINTENDENT OF PUBLIC
INSTRUCTION WAS A FORMER MEMBER
OF THE STATE ASSEMBLY MISTER
TONY THURMOND AS WELL AS
PROFESSOR FROM UC BERKELEY
GRADUATE SCHOOL OF EDUCATION DR
TRAVIS BRISTOL WHO WILL ALSO
INTRODUCE. VERY GOOD THANK YOU
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WELCOME MR
SUPERINTENDENT WE'RE VERY HAPPY
TO HAVE YOU WITH US TODAY AND
ALSO DR BRISTOL SUPERINTENDED.
THURMAN PLEASE PROCEED. I THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR I COULD MORNING
TO YOU AND TO THE MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE. AND THANK YOU
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GIPSON OF FOR
YOUR AUTHORSHIP OF AB FIVE
TWENTY A BILL THAT HAS THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION. IS PROUD TO BE A
SPONSOR OF. I'D LIKE TO BEGIN
BY JUST ACKNOWLEDGING OUR
INCREDIBLE EDUCATION WORK FORCE
INTO CHEST CONTINUE TO SHOW MY
APPRECIATION FOR WHAT. OUR
ADMINISTRATORS AND TEACHERS AND
CLASSIFIED STAFF AND OUR
STUDENTS HAVE DONE IN THIS VERY
DIFFICULT TIME WE HAVE A GREAT
TEACHER WORKFORCE AND WE ALSO
HAVE AN INCREDIBLY. DIVERSE
STATE THAT CONTINUES TO BECOME
MORE AND MORE DIVERSE ALL THE
TIME. THAT CREATES AN
INCREDIBLE OPPORTUNITY FOR US
TO ALSO DIVERSIFY OUR TEACHER
WORKFORCE CHANCE THIS BILL IN
IT CREATES- IN ITS SCOPE THE
CHANCE TO EXPERIENCE SOME OF
THE EXISTING PROGRAMS THAT HAVE
BEGUN TO FOCUS ON BUILDING THE
RIGHT PIPELINE AND SUPPORTS.
YOU HAVE MORE MALE EDUCATORS OF
COLOR I WON'T GO INTO THE
DETAILS COULD YOU HEAR
CONDUCTOR BRISTOL BUT RESEARCH
SHOWS THAT WHEN YOU DIVERSIFY
THAT THE TEACHER WORKFORCE
CHECK EVEN HAVING ONE TEACHER
OF COLOR I'M PROVIDES ALL KINDS
OF BENEFITS FOR STUDENTS OF
COLOR AND FOR CHEAP FOR
STUDENTS OF ALL BACKGROUNDS. IN
OTHER WORDS THIS IS A MEASURE
THAT IS SIMPLY JUST A WIN WIN
AND SO AS WE LOOK AT HOW WE
DIVERSIFY OUR TEACHER WORKFORCE
EXPANDING PROGRAMS FOR MALE
EDUCATORS OF COLOR. ONE
IMPORTANT COMPONENT OF THAT
MEASURE YEAH YOU HEARD FROM
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GIPSON THERE
ARE GREAT EXAMPLES OF
CONTINUITY FINANCE- IN THE
STATE BAKERSFIELD SCHOOL
DISTRICTS AND AT SOME OF OUR
CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY
PROGRAMS. THIS MEASURE WOULD
SIMPLY ALLOW US TO DOUBLE DOWN
ON THOSE EFFORTS TO EXPAND WITH
THE RESOURCES NEEDED FOR
PROGRAMS LIKE RESIDENTS HE
SUPPORTS IN OTHER KINDS OF
SUPPORT. TO ENSURE THAT WE CAN
RECRUIT RETAIN. AND SUPPORT
MORE MELANIE AT OF COLOR AS WE
DO. OUR TEACHER WORK. I RESPECT
ASK FOR YOUR BOATS ON A FIVE
TWO. THANK YOU THANK YOU MISTER
SUPER. I WILL NOT GO TO PRESS
PLEASE WHEN READY OF MINUTES.
FIRST I'D LIKE TO- GOOD MORNING
BRITAIN LIKE TO THINK SO
MADONNA BERMAN ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GIPSON FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
TESTIFY- ON BEHALF OF EIGHTY
FIVE TWENTY. IN THE WEALTHIEST
STATE IN THE UNITED STATES THE
WORLD'S THIRD LARGEST ECONOMY
THE QUESTION OF HOW WE GET- I
DO BURKE HIGHLY QUALIFIED
TEACHING WORKFORCE ALL OF OUR
CHILDREN ACROSS THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. HAS NEVER BEEN
ABOUT RESOURCE BUT RATHER ONE
ABOUT WILL THIS BILL EIGHTY
FIVE TWENTY LEVERAGES THE
IMMENSE WEALTH OF THE STATE.
WITH THE WHEEL IN THE POLICY
MOMENT ACT ON THE CORNER COMPEL
RESEARCH. WHAT THE ADDED BACK.
TO THE COLOR ALSO. WHAT THIS
RESEARCH ST BUT LACKS FEATURED
EARLY- SCHOOL START LANGUAGE
THIS SO HARD. OF EMOTIONAL
SUPPORT DURING TEACHER
SIGNATURE. MY NEXT TEACHERS OF
IMPLORE MY NECK YEAR TO TAKE
MORE ADVANCED PLACEMENT AND
INTERNATIONAL. QUICKLY WHAT
TEACHERS DRAW ON THE BLACK YOU
CULTURE WITH BRING INCREASING
AND LEARNING. BLACKS BY TO
BLACK TO TRIPLE BETTER ON.
TESTS I WAS PUBLISHED PEOPLE MY
COLLEGE AND I THAT WHEN ASIANS
ARE TO AGENCY THERE ARE LESS
LIKELY TO SPEND. LET ME BE
CLEAR I NOT AT FOR SCHOOL WHICH
BLACKS ARE TAUGHT ONLY BE BLACK.
MY OWN EXPERIENCE THE BLACK MAN
WHOSE YOU TO TEACH YOU COULD
WHAT'S HAPPENED. I RACHEL COCA
CORRECT BY THE DOLLAR YOU CAN.
BUT BACK DURING MY TEACHING
MOAPA HYPE WHY STUDENTS AFTER
BENTO. HAVE YOU HAVE YOUR TO.
EVERYONE CAL. WELCOME BACK AT
STUDENTS. I AM A FULL BLACK
MALE TEACHERS HAVE HAD AB PARK
ONE MAKE SURE THERE ARE STILL
WILL NOT. HAVE TO WAIT UNTIL
COLLEGE THEY HAVE A OF A
TEACHER LIKE THE- FIND YOU THE
POWER ARE. INTO PIECE OF
LEGISLATION AB PART THAT. THE
COURT NUMBER TWO NOTE GIVE A
CALL. MUCH OF VIRUS HAS MY- HOW
MUCH LAND MAKE THEM BOY WERE
PUT OUT OF. SOME MARK THE BLACK
AND NEXT TO. ALL OF OUR
STUDENTS.
REITER PLEASE QUEUE
OF ANYONE WHO WISHES TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OF AB. FIVE TWENTY.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR LADIES
AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF AB FIVE
TWENTY PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO.
AN OPERATOR WILL PROVIDE YOU
WITH YOUR LINE NUMBER AND PLACE
YOU BACK INTO Q. ONCE AGAIN IF
YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF
AB. FIVE TWENTY PLEASE PRESS
ONE ZERO NOW. THE LINE NUMBER
FIFTY TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. CARLOS MARQUEZ
ON BEHALF OF THE DIVERSITY IN
LEADERSHIP INSTITUTE AND
CHARTING THE COURSE THE EQUITY
COALITION IN SUPPORT. LINE
NUMBER TWENTY FOUR YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING MADAM CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME IS TO
RECOMMEND HE ON BEHALF OF THE
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA
SCHOOL ADMINISTRATORS IN
SUPPORT OF AB FIVE TWENTY THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. POLITE NUMBER
ONE NINETY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING MADAM CHAIR AND
SENATORS THE PANEL AGAINST
REPRESENTING THE LOS ANGELES
COUNTY OFFICE OF EDUCATION AND
WE'RE PROUD TO JOIN IN SUPPORT
OF AB FIVE TWENTY. LINE NUMBER
SIXTY THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. AND WE BROUGHT
ON BEHALF OF SAN DIEGO UNIFIED
AND STRONG SUPPORT. MY NUMBER
SEVENTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. COMMISSION
MEMBERS MANY. EDUCATION TRUST
ONCE ENTRANCE. MY NUMBER ONE
FORTY FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
ALEX GRAVES OF THE ASSOCIATION
OF INDEPENDENT CALIFORNIA
COLLEGES AND UNIVERSITIES ARE
FORTY THREE SCHOOLS AND
PROGRAMS OF EDUCATION SUPPORT.
MY NUMBER ONE NINETY SIX YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THE MORNING CARE NUMBERS WE ANY
PACKET ON BEHALF OF TAX NET IN
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK
YOU. THANK YOU MY NUMBER ONE
SIXTY FOUR YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. ONE SIXTY FOR
YOUR LINE IS OPEN MAYBE YOU'RE
ON MUTE. ONE ROB SPEAKING ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
FACULTY ASSOCIATION IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
BLIND SIXTY FOUR YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. MADAM
CHAIR MEMBERS NICK WRONGLY ON
BEHALF OF THE ALAMEDA COUNTY
OFFICE OF EDUCATION AND ALSO WE
HAVE THE PROJECT LEAD THE WAY
IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. MY NUMBER ONE NINETY
FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING MADAM
CHAIR THIS IS BRIAN STAFF ON
THE OPPOSITE DIRECTION OF THE
CONSTRUCTION TYPE BERMAN
TRANSPONDER AND STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU THANK YOU. AT THE
TIME AND I'M SURE WE HAVE NO
ONE ELSE CAN QUEUE THANK YOU
MADAM MODERATOR WE WILL NOW GO
TO ANYONE WHO'S IN OPPOSITION I
HAVE NO LEAD OPPOSITION ANYONE
HERE IN FORTY TWO OH THREE.
SING THEN WILL GO TO THE
OVERFLOW ROOM SEEING NONE OF
MODERATE CAN YOU PLEASE KEEP
ANYONE WHO WISHES TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION OF AB FIVE TWENTY.
THANK YOU AND LAYS IN GERMAN
FOR YOU IN OPPOSITION AB FIVE
TWENTY PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME. ONE CAN
THAT'S ONE ZERO IN OPPOSITION
OF AB FIVE TWENTY. JUST A
MOMENT PLEASE. THIRTY ONE
NUMBER ONE SEVENTY ONE PLEASE
GO AHEAD THANK YOU. YES I AM I
AM NOT POSITION OF THAT. AM I
BEING HEARD RIGHT NOW WE HEARD
TO YES YOU'RE IN OPPOSITION
PLEASE STATE YOUR NAME. OKAY
YES MY NAME IS JULIN ORGANIZED
I REPRESENT- LOCAL SCHOOLS OF
HUNTINGTON BEACH CALIFORNIA AND
WE ARE IN OPPOSITION- THAT'S WE
HAVE A WIDE VARIETY RIGHT NOW A
DIVERSITY AND WE'RE WE DON'T
NEED ANYMORE- TELLING US WHAT
TO DO AND HOW TO BE DIVERSE.
BANIK MANAGEMENT MODERATOR NEXT
CALLER ADAEZE WE HAVE. THANK
YOU AND ONCE AGAIN LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WERE IN
OPPOSITION AB FIVE TWENTY
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT
THIS TIME. AT THIS TIME WE HAVE
NO ONE ELSE IN Q. PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU MR MODERATOR
ART WILL BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE ANY QUESTIONS
COMMENTS OR CONCERNS. YES
CENTER CORTESE. MENTOR.
ASSEMBLY NOTED THIS THE
INVESTMENT VERSUS NEEDED AND-
CERTAINLY HAVEN'T BEEN A SCHOOL
BOARD MEMBER AND VERY CLOSE TO
PUBLIC EDUCATIONAL FOR A NUMBER
OF YEARS NOW- EIGHT I HAVE A
POSITIVE- RESPONSE TO. THE NEED
EVEN BEYOND SOME OF THE REASONS
THAT ARE. IN THE ANALYSIS HERE-
THE QUESTION I FELT. IS REALLY
IN TERMS OF THE NEED ON- ON THE
LEGISLATIVE AND FISCAL SIDE
GIVEN CAR WERE RAT WITH THIS BE
AB ONE THIRTY BECAUSE- THERE'S
AN AWFUL LOT OF MONEY THERE AND
I DON'T KNOW IF YOU'VE MADE
SOME DISTINCTION BETWEEN THE
THREE HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS IT'S HAPPENING THERE
AND I ONLY ASKED. ME TO
COMMITMENT COMMITMENT TO MYSELF
YESTERDAY. AS A FIRST YEAR
SENATOR AFTER GOING THROUGH THE
PROCESS ESPECIALLY THE INTER
HOUSE PROCESS WHERE I'M OFTEN
ASKED BY THE OTHER HOUSE WHY
ARE YOU TRYING TO FIX SOMETHING
THAT'S ALREADY BEEN TAKEN CARE
OF AND I'M OFTEN A LITTLE BIT
TAKEN ABACK BY THAT WHEN THE
MEMBERS ASKING THOSE QUESTIONS
BUT I'M REALIZING SOMETIMES WE
DO HAVE TASSELS QUESTIONS IN IN
HERE IT LOOKS LIKE WE'VE TAKEN
A LOT OF ACTION AS A
LEGISLATURE ALREADY- A TO
ADDRESS THE PROBLEM IN ANY. OF
JUST US YOU. I RESPOND TO THAT
IF YOU'RE WILLING. THANK YOU
SURE I'D AT. THIS OWN
RESTAURANTS IN COURT YOUR
QUESTION CORRECTLY- AGAIN BASED
ON THE STUDIES TO SHOW- THAT
AGAIN WHEN YOU LOOK AT-
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR WHEN YOU
LOOK AT THESE TO THE POPULATION
THAT I'VE MADE MENTION OF 75%
OF THE STUDENT POPULATION
CALIFORNIA OUR CHILDREN OF
STUDENTS OF COLOR. AND THEN YOU
LOOK AT THE TEACHER POLL WHERE
YOU LOOK WE SEE 10% OF THE OF
AFRICAN AMERICANS LATINOS MAKES
UP ONE OR 2% AND THEN YOU LOOK
AT FURTHER THE STUDIES HAVE
BEEN DONE TO SHOW IF HE PLAYS A
MALE TEACHER WHICH AGAIN WE ARE
NEW IN MUNICH IN THIS
PARTICULAR AREA- TO TRY TO SHOW
YOUNG STUDENTS- ROLE MODELS.
THAT LOOK LIKE THEM THE
REFLECTS THEM- AND THE TEACHER
AND THE STUDENT OUTCOME- AND
THROUGH THE STUDIES THAT HAVE
SHOWN IS THAT- IT REDUCES DROP
OUT IT REDUCES A NUMBER OF
DIFFERENT THINGS AND IT ALSO
CREATES THE OPPORTUNITY FOR
STUDENTS TO GO INTO EDUCATION
AS WELL AND THAT'S WHAT WE
REALLY WANT TO AIM AT TO TRY TO
BOOST- THAT'S REASON WHY THAT.
THE MONEY IS PLACED IN THE POT
THAT THROUGH THE GOVERNMENT
THROUGH THE BUDGET TO INCREASE-
DID AND DIVERSIFY- THE TEACHING
WORKFORCE- WE TRY TO FIT UP.
THAT EXIST IN THE PROBLEM THAT
I SEE EXISTS IS THAT THERE'S A
LACK OF MALE TEACHERS- IN
EDUCATION AND THIS WILL
HOPEFULLY ENCOURAGE- A NEW
GENERATION OF MALE TEACHERS TO
GO INTO EDUCATION AROUND AND
ALSO BE THERE TO SUPPORT. OUR
MALE STUDENT TEACHERS I. IF I
DIDN'T ANSWER QUESTIONS PLEASE
REFER TO THE CHAIR AND IT I
AGREE WITH EVERYTHING YOU JUST
SAID. IN MY OWN EXPERIENCE
INFORMS- THEM THAT A DECISION
THAT WE NEED MORE DIVERSITY NOT
ONLY THE TEACHING RANKS BUT IN
THE MINISTRY RANKS AS WELL. AND
I THINK THE- IS SORELY NEEDED-
I DISAGREE WITH ANY OPPOSITION
IT WAS THE OTHERWISE. WHAT I
WAS REALLY ASKING IS MORE OR
MORE NARAL QUESTION IN THE
ANALYSIS. THE GNOSIS OF YOUR
BILL. IT SAYS THIS YEAR'S
BUDGET TRAILER BILL S. B. AB
ONE THIRTY INCLUDES THREE
HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS
IN ONE TIME GENERAL FUND TO
ESTABLISH A TEACHER RESIDENCY.
GRANT PROGRAM. THE PROGRAM
WOULD REQUIRE THE CTC TO MAKE
ONE TIME GRANTS DALY IS. TO
ESTABLISH A NEW TEACHER
RESIDENCY PROGRAMS WORK SPANS
FRANKEN APPROVED ACCESS TO
EXISTING TEACHER RESIDENCY
PROGRAMS THAT SUPPORT DOESN'T
MEAN TEACHER SHORTAGE. FIELDS I
THINK THAT WOULD BE. EXACTLY
THE DEMOGRAPHIC YOU'RE TALKING
ABOUT HELLO EFFORTS TO RECRUIT
DEVELOP SUPPORT SYSTEMS FOR AND
PROVIDE OUR REGION
COMMUNICATION STRATEGIES TO.
AND RETAIN A DIVERSE TEACHER
WORKFORCE REFLECTS LOW BLOOD
EDUCATIONAL AGENCY COMMUNITIES
DIVERSITY. SO IF WE HAVE ACTED
UPON THAT BOTH HOUSES
LEGISLATURE BUT I'M JUST ASK
THAT'S WHAT I WAS REFERRING TO
IS YOUR THEN WHAT DOES THIS
BILL COMMANDED BUT THIS BILL
AND FIX THAT WE HAVEN'T ALREADY
DONE NOT NOT THAT IT IS NEEDED
I'M JUST. BUT I THOUGHT WE HAD
OUR FINGERPRINTS ALL OVER IT
ADDRESSING THIS ISSUE IN THE S.
B. AB ONE THIRTY AND I'M JUST
TRYING TO UNDERSTAND THAT'S WHY
**** CAN YOU MAKE A DISTINCTION
BETWEEN THE TWENTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS FOR EACH STUDENT
ENROLLED AFTER JANUARY FIRST
TWENTY TWENTY WHICH YOUR BILL
CALLS FOR AND ANY ACTIONS THAT
WE'VE ALREADY TAKEN AS A
LEGISLATURE OF OUR AND OUR
WHICH IS UNIVERSITY MILLION OUT
THERE YEAH I WOULD JUST SIMPLY
SAY THIS BILL. WILL MOVE TO THE
LEGISLATIVE PROCESS BEFORE OUR
BUDGET TRAILER BILL BEFORE
EVEN- ACTUALLY VOTED ON THAT
AND SO FOR ME- LOOKING AT WHAT
HAPPENS WHAT'S TAKING PLACE A
COPY YOU KNOW BY SCHOOL
DISTRICT IN THEIR PILOT PROGRAM
MALE TEACHERS A RETENTION OF
COLOR- AND HOW THAT HAS
TREMENDOUSLY WORK IN THAT GAVE
THE IDEA FOR THIS BILL- THIS
BEFORE YOU TODAY FIVE TWENTY
AND ALSO THE WORK THAT OUR
SUPERINTENDENTS A WE HAD. WE
START THIS WORK BEFORE THE
LEGISLATURE TO THE BUDGET
TRAILER BILL HAD ALREADY BEGUN
TO HAVE THOSE KINDS
CONVERSATIONS AND I'M HOPEFUL
AND I'M GONNA TAKE CREDIT FOR
THIS THAT MY BILL WAS ON
SOMEONE'S BUYS IN THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE TO GET TO THE
SAME EXACT THING THAT ASSEMBLY
BILL- A. B. FIVE TWENTY IS
TRYING TO GET TO- TODAY WE'RE
HAPPY THAT THIS MONEY IS IN THE.
BUDGET TO DO EXACTLY WHAT THIS
BILL DOES. I APPRECIATE THE IN
A- I. THE ISSUE AND PEOPLE ALL
BEEN INVOLVED WITH THE WITH US.
WE ARE JUST ACROSS WORKS I'M-
WE JUST CONCLUDE SALE.
EMINENTLY SUPPORT. GETTING THE
SODA CAN TODAY I KNOW WHAT IN
TERMS OF RECONCILING- THE
TRAILER BILL. YEAH THE
APPROPRIATIONS THERE OF AND YOU
KNOW ANY SORT OF APPROPRIATIONS
WITH YOUR BILL- JUST CALLING
THAT OUT. I'M MORE THAN HAPPY
GIVE YOU CREDIT FOR HAVING THE
IDEA FIRST AND I THINK MORE
THAN HAPPY TO STAND FOR YOU AND
OR ANYONE ANY MAN OR WOMAN WHO-
HERO- DESERVES CREDIT AND NOT
TO BE RIPPED OFF SO I JUST I
JUST WANNA MAKE SURE THAT.
DESPITE ALL THAT TRUTH THAT WE
MAY JUST. HAVE A SITUATION HERE
WHERE WE DON'T NEED TO WE ONLY
NEED ONE OF THESE SOLUTIONS BUT
TODAY- YOU KNOW MY COURTESY IS
TO EXTEND AYE BOTH THANK YOU
VERY MUCH I APPRECIATE THAT
THANK YOU CENTER CORTESE ANY
OTHER COMMENTS OR CONCERNS. IT
TO YOUR QUESTION- CENTER
CORTESE IF A BILL IS.
SUBSTANTIALLY IN THE BUDGET
THAN IT USUALLY GETS HELD IN
APPROPRIATIONS SO THAT WILL BE
UP TO THE FOR SHE
EXPROPRIATIONS CHAIR. DO WE
HAVE A MOTION ON THE BILL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MUCH
APPRECIATED ASSEMBLY MEMBER
PLEASE CLOSE THANK YOU VERY
MUCH I APPRECIATE THE SENATOR'S
QUESTIONS AND- EVERYONE WHO'S
ALREADY CHIMED IN IN SUPPORT OF
AB FIVE TWENTY. I WILL JUST
CONCUR WITH THE CHAIR MADAM
CHAIR- WE GO AGAIN WE DIDN'T
KNOW- WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
THIS BILL MOVED THE LEGISLATIVE
PROCESS AND- THE APPROPRIATE- I
GUESS BACKDROP OR RESPONSE WILL
BE. IN THE SENATE APPROPRIATION
THIS BILL GETS GETS THERE FOR
GETS OUT OF THIS COMMITTEE.
TODAY TO LOOK AT WHAT TE
BUDGET TRAILER BILL HAS DONE
AND LOOK WHAT MY BILL WOULD DO.
AND THEN THEY WILL ULTIMATELY
HOLD THIS BILL AND
APPROPRIATIONS AND THEN THE
BUDGET TRAILER BILL MOVE
FORWARD. THAT WILL STILL
ACCOMPLISH EVERYTHING THAT A
BIT ASSEMBLY BILL FIVE TWENTY
SIX OUT TO DO. I WANT TO ALSO
GIVE- THANKS TO THE CARD
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT WE HAVE
THE LEADERSHIP THE BOARD- FOR
HAVING SUCH A PILOT PROGRAM.
THAT IS PROVIDING TREMENDOUS-
SUCCESS AND ALSO OUR
SUPERINTENDENT FOR CHAMPING
THERE'S I RESPECTFULLY ASK WHEN
I VOTE THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MA'AM CONSULTANCIES CALL THE
ROLL. A LOT OF NUMBER FOR. AB
FIVE TWENTY THE MOTION IS TO
PASS BUT FIRST BE REFERRED TO
THE COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
SENATOR LEYVA. HI LEYVA AYE
OCHO ABODE I. TROUBLED AYE
CORTESE AYE COURTESY AYE DALY.
DALY AYE GLAZER MCGUIRE PAN
BELIEVE THAT BILL ON CALL THANK
YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER YOU ALL
RIGHT WE'RE NOT GOING TO FILE
ITEM NUMBER SIX AB FIVE FORTY
FIVE I SEE ASSEMBLYMEMBER QUIRK
HERE AND READY TO GO. SOON AS
NICE AND SANITIZED PLEASE
PROCEED WHEN YOU ARE READY-
KERRY. BOB GOOD MORNING GOOD
MORNING EDITOR'S BOB SOME OF
THE MAJOR TAX EXPENDITURES IN
CALIFORNIA RE DIRECTED HUNDREDS
OF BILLIONS OF DOLLARS IN
FUNDING FROM EDUCATION AND
OTHER VITAL SERVICES FOR YEARS-
THESE MAY BE VERY GOOD USES OF
THE MONEY. IT MAY BE THAT THESE
TAX BREAKS CREATE MORE BUSINESS
AND WE MAKE MORE. FROM THE
BUSINESS THEY BRING AND WE LOSE
IN THE TAX BENEFITS. BUT WE
DON'T KNOW THAT FOR A NUMBER OF
PROGRAMS HAVE JUST BEEN AROUND
FOR A LONG TIME. THE MORE
RECENT PROGRAMS WE REVIEW THEM
HAVE CERTAIN OBJECTIVES WE
UNDERSTAND THEM AND FOR EXAMPLE
THE- TAX CREDIT FOR ALL. OUR
FILMS AND TELEVISION I JUST
VOTED FOR SOME ADDITIONAL MONEY
FOR THAT SO SOME OF THEM WE
KNOW. THEY'RE A WHOLE BUNCH THE
RICHEST GRANDFATHER DAN AND
WE'VE NEVER REALLY LOOKED AT.
SO THERE IS ALSO A STATE AUDIT
THAT FOUND THERE WAS JUST A
LACK OF OVERSIGHT AND
EVALUATION THAT MADE IT.
DIFFICULT TO DETERMINE IF THESE
OLDER TAX CREDITS OR EXEMPTIONS
WERE FOR FAILING THE PURPOSE.
TO ADDRESS THIS LACK OF
OVERSIGHT AB FIVE FORTY FIVE
REQUESTED THE UC RESEARCH
CENTER. ANALYZED THE SOCIAL AND
ECONOMIC IMPACTS THAT MAJOR TAX
EXPENDITURES HAVE IN THE STATE.
AND VERIFY ANY BENEFIT TO THE
STATE GETS FROM THESE PROGRAMS.
THAT'S SOMETHING THAT CURRENT
REPORTS DON'T GIVE YOU CURRENT
REPORTS CAN TELL YOU. HOW MUCH
YOU'VE SPENT IN THE WAY OF TAX
BENEFITS THEY CAN'T TELL YOU
WHAT THE BENEFITS ARE. TO THE
ECONOMY OF THE STATE UNTIL THAT
TAXPAYERS OF THE STATE AND
THAT'S WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO
REALLY LOOK AT THAT'S WHY WE
NEED YOU SEE- THEY WILL
DETERMINE OPTIONS FOR IMPROVING
THE PROGRAMS ARE REDUCING THEIR
IMPACTS IN THE GENERAL FUND. AB
FIVE FORTY FIVE PER PROVIDES
TOOL FOR INFORMING OUR FUTURE
POLICY DECISIONS. ENSURING THE
BEST USE OF LIMITED PUBLIC
DOLLARS ARE TESTIFYING IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL. THE
CALIFORNIA TEACHERS ASSOCIATION
AND THE CALIFORNIA- TAX REFORM
ASSOCIATION. VERY GOOD AND I
THINK YOU HAVE TO LEAD
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT YES OKAY
I'VE GOT LISTED KATIE HARTMAN
AND SAMANTHA CORBIN. IF YOU
WILL QUEUE UP AND WE WILL START
WITH KATIE HARTMAN YOU HAVE TWO
MINUTES. GOOD MORNING MADAM
CHAIR AND COMMITTEE MEMBER
KATIE HARTMAN AT THE CALIFORNIA
TEACHER ASSOCIATION. PTA AND
THE PROUD CO SPONSOR OF AB FIVE
FORTY FIVE EVERYONE I THINK
ASSEMBLY MEMBER COURT FOR HIS
WORK. I DID MAKE A COUPLE OF
POINTS AND AS YOU MAY KNOW THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE RECORDED
A TOTAL OF. SEVENTY FIVE
BILLION DOLLARS IN TAX
EXPENDITURES PROVIDED BY THE
STATE LAST YEAR AND THAT NUMBER
CONTINUES TO GROW EACH YEAR.
YOU EXPENDITURES OBVIOUSLY HAVE
A HUGE IMPACT ON THE STATE
BUDGET AND EDUCATION FUNDING.
AND THINK THAT YOU KNOW
APPROXIMATELY 40% OF THE BUDGET
AN DEDICATED TO KEEP YOUR
FOURTEEN EDUCATION. MEANS THAT
APPROXIMATELY THIRTY BILLION
DOLLARS RE DIRECTED AWAY FROM
SCHOOLS IN THE FORM OF TAX
EXPENDITURES EACH YEAR. AND
ADDITIONALLY AT THE AUTHORS
THAT MANY OF THESE. AT THE
EXPENDITURES HAD NEVER BEEN
EVALUATED. THANK THAT DISPELLED
SIMPLY PROVIDE THE STATE WITH
MORE INFORMATION ABOUT THOSE
MORE COSTLY TAX EXPENDITURES.
TO DETERMINE IF THEIR
ACCOMPLISHING THEIR INTENDED
GOAL. EPA BELIEVES THAT
OVERSIGHT IS ESSENTIAL GIVEN
THE SIGNIFICANT IMPACT ON THE
GENERAL FUND INCLUDING FUNDING
FOR EDUCATION AND CHILD CARE
HIGHER EDUCATION AND OTHER
VITAL PROGRAM. THIS BILL WILL
PROVIDE MUCH NEEDED
TRANSPARENCY AND AYE URGENT AYE
VOTE THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS PLEASE. THANK YOU MAY
CHAIR MEMBERS IN AFRICA ON THE
OF THE- PARKS WITH I THINK IS.
ARE NONPROFIT LOOK. COMPRISED
OF LABOR LABOR PUBLIC INTEREST
GROUPS. AND ACADEMICS I'LL TRY
NOT TO BE TO DUPLICATE WITH THE
COMMENT- BUT HARMON AS WELL AS-
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WE DO ASK THAT
YOU SUPPORT EIGHTY FIVE POINT
FIVE COURT DAY WHICH WILL
INITIATE A COMPREHENSIVE
ASSESSMENT I'M FROM A
CALIFORNIA'S LARGEST. TAX
EXPENDITURE PROGRAM TO ENSURE
THAT THOSE THE MOST COSTLY ARE
ACHIEVING THEIR INTENDED PUBLIC
POLICY OBJECTIVES. AND THAT
THEY'RE MAKING THE BEST USE OF
LIMITED PUBLIC DOLLARS. OVER
THE YEARS CALIFORNIA
LEGISLATORS HAVE INCREASINGLY
TURNED TO TAX CREDIT TO ADVANCE
POLICY INTEREST. PERHAPS
WITHOUT FULLY UNDERSTANDING
WE'RE DEBATING THE IMPACT OF
THE TAX CREDIT. ON THE STATE'S
GENERAL FUND. EVERY DAHLE OF
TAX THAT ARE FUND A DOES NOT.
ACOSTA YOU REVENUE WERE GIFTED
NOT. REVENUE THE WITH OTHER
PROVIDE CRITICAL PUBLIC
INCLUDING FIRE. PUBLIC SAFETY
AS- BUT- CLASSROOM. WHAT A
FINANCE THE TAX EXPENDITURES
ENDED THAT JOB BETWEEN TWO
THOUSAND EIGHT AND TWENTY TWO
ONE THAT THE REVENUE LOST STATE
JOURNAL FUND OVER FIVE HUNDRED
BILLION DOLLARS I'M VERY ACTIVE
MANAGERS. UNFORTUNATELY THIS
OVERWHELMING LOSS OF REVENUE
WILL CONTINUE TO OUR ROADS
AVAILABLE DOLLARS FOR PUBLIC
EDUCATION AND OTHER PROGRAMS
UNLESS ACTION IS TAKEN TO
REDUCE THE DRAIN ON THE GENERAL
FUND I BUDGET IF THE FINANCIAL
THAT WE ENSURE TRANSPARENCY AND
ACCOUNTABILITY ARE AVAILABLE TO
ENSURE THAT CALIFORNIA'S
RECEIVING A RETURN ON ITS
INVESTMENT. WITHOUT A REGULAR
SYSTEM OF THE VALUATION METRICS
YOU TOOK BACK THE ECONOMIC
BENEFITS GENERATED BY TAX
CREDITS AND EXEMPTIONS THERE IS
TRULY NO WAY TO IDENTIFY
WHETHER THESE BENEFITS HAVE IN
FACT OCCURRED FOR THOSE REASONS
WE ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT EIGHTY
FIVE POINT FIVE TODAY THANK
YOU. THANK YOU I WILL GO TO
ROOM FORTY TWO OR THREE FOR
ANYONE IN SUPPORT SAYING NO ONE
WILL GO TO OUR OVERFLOW ROOMS
SEEING NO ONE THERE WILL GO TO
THE MODERATOR MR MODERATOR CAN
YOU PLEASE KEEP ANYONE WHO
WISHES TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT. OF
AB FIVE FORTY FIVE. THANK YOU.
AND OF YOUR SUPPORT OF A FIVE
FOUR FIVE PLEASE. ONE AND THEN
ZERO YOUR TOUCH TONE PHONE.
ONCE AGAIN IT'S ONE ZERO FOR
SUPPORT OF AB FIVE FOUR FIVE.
WE'RE GONNA LINE NUMBER THIRTY
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING THIS IS OLGA CHARLOTTE
LOS ANGELES UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT WE SUPPORT EIGHTY FIVE
FORTY FIVE THANK YOU THANK YOU.
NEXT SUMMER LINE NUMBER SIXTY
SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI THIS
IS DON OR WITH THE CALIFORNIA
SCHOOL EMPLOYEES ASSOCIATION WE
ARE SUPPORT. THANK YOU NEXT ONE
LINE NUMBER TWO FOURTEEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. SH BUDGET ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY
COLLEGES CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE
SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU.
NUMBER ONE NUMBER TWO SIXTEEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GREETINGS
MADAM CHAIR NUMBERS TRICKING
BROWN CFT UNIT OF EDUCATORS
ACOSTA PROFESSIONALS HERE IN
SUPPORT. AND ONCE AGAIN IF
YOU'RE IN SUPPORT OF AB FIVE
FOUR FIVE PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME. THAT'S ONE
ZERO IN SUPPORT OF AB FIVE FOUR
FIVE. I DON'T CARE PERSONALLY
OF NO ONE ELSE IN QUEUE AT THIS
TIME. THANK YOU VERY MUCH ALL
RIGHT WE WILL GO TO ANYONE IN A
WITH NO LEAD OPPOSITION LISTED
SO ANYONE HERE IN FORTY TWO OH
THREE WISHES TO OPPOSING NONE.
GO TO OUR OVERFLOW ROOM ALSO
SEEN NONE MISTER MODERATOR BACK
TO YOU CAN YOU PLEASE KEEP
ANYONE WHO WISHES TO SPEAK. IN
OPPOSITION AB FIVE FORTY FIVE.
THANK YOU IF YOU WERE IN
OPPOSITION AB FIVE FORTY FIVE
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN JOE AT
THIS TIME. ONCE AGAIN THAT'S
ONE ZERO IN OPPOSITION OF AB.
FIVE FOUR FIVE. IN OPPOSITION
AB FIVE FOUR FIVE PLEASE PRESS
ONE ZERO. MADAM PURSUE HAVE
KNOWN IN QUEUE AT THIS TIME
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WILL BRING
IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE TO
HAVE ANY QUESTIONS COMMENTS
CONCERNS. SEEING NONE WE GET A
MOTION PLEASE CENTER CORTESE
MOVE THE BILL THANK YOU THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. A SUMMER COURT
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE. YES
AGAIN THE MAJOR- THING WE'RE
TRYING TO DO HERE IS LOOK AT
WHAT THE- ADVANTAGES ARE OF
THESE PROGRAMS- THAT'S
SOMETHING WE JUST HAVEN'T BEEN
ABLE TO LOOK INTO- EITHER FROM
THE L. A. O. OR OTHER. OF OUR
OWN ORGANIZATIONS- THE UC GROUP
WILL BE ABLE TO DO THIS- AND-
WILL HAVE A LOT MORE
INFORMATION WE FINISH. THE
ORIGINAL VERSION OF THIS BILL
HAD A COMMITTEE WHICH IS GOING
TO MAKE RECOMMENDATIONS THERE
WILL BE NO RECOMMENDATIONS
MADE. BY THE UC THERE WILL BE
NO ADDITIONAL COMMITTEE. WE
BELIEVE THIS THEN THE GOVERNOR
WILL BE ABLE TO SIGN THE BILL
SO I ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MA'AM
CONSULTANT PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. WE HAVE A MOTION WAS
CENTER CORTESE PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. FILE ITEM NUMBER SIX AB
FIVE FORTY FIVE THE MOTION IS
TO PASS BUT FIRST BE REFERRED
TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS SENATOR LEYVA
AYE LEYVA AYE OCHO A BOAT.
PATROL BOAT NO COURTESY.
COURTESY I. DALLI. DALLI NO
GLAZER MCGUIRE PANTS WILL KEEP
THAT BILL ON CALL FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS THANK YOU ASSEMBLY
MEMBER THANK YOU. NEXT UP IS
FILE ITEM EIGHT AB NINE TWENTY
EIGHT ASSEMBLY MEMBER BERMAN
GOOD MORNING. AS SOON AS THE-
PODIUM IS READY PLEASE PROCEED.
THANK YOU MANCHURIAN SENATORS-
AND I WOULD LIKE TO THINK OF
THE CHAIR IN THE COMMITTEE
STAFFER THOUGHTFUL AND THOROUGH
ANALYSIS. I'M HAPPY TO ACCEPT
THE COMMITTEE SUGGESTED
AMENDMENTS RELATED TO THE
SINGULAR GENERAL EDUCATION
PATHWAY PROVISION. SPECIFIED IN
THE ANALYSIS. AS CHAIR OF THE
SELECT COMMITTEE ON THE MASTER
PLAN FOR HIGHER EDUCATION I'VE
HEARD DIRECTLY FROM STUDENTS
WHO SHARED THEIR TRANSFER
EXPERIENCE. THE MESSAGE WAS
LOUD AND CLEAR THE TRANSFER
PROCESS IS TOO COMPLEX
CONFUSING AND DIFFICULT TO
NAVIGATE. AS CALIFORNIA
RECOVERS FROM THE PANDEMIC NOW
MORE THAN EVER IT IS CRITICAL
TO INCREASED DEGREE ATTAINMENT.
IMPROVE TIME 2 DEGREES IN CLOSE
RACIAL EQUITY GAPS. EIGHTY NINE
TWENTY EIGHT WOULD TRANSFORM
THE TRANSFER PROCESS THREE
THREE SIGNIFICANT STUDENT
CENTERED PROVISIONS. FIRST THE
BILL WILL CREATE AN INTER
SEGMENTAL IMPLEMENTATION
COMMITTEE TO PROVIDE A
PERMANENT VENUE TO FACILITATE
INTER SEGMENTAL COORDINATION
AND GREATER STATE LEVEL
ACCOUNTABILITY FOR
IMPLEMENTATION. OF THE
ASSOCIATE DEGREE FOR TRANSFER
AND TO FOCUS ON IMPROVING
TRANSFER OUTCOMES FOR ALL
STUDENTS. SECOND AS AMENDED THE
BILL WOULD SET A TARGET DATE
FOR THE INTERSEGMENT ALL
COMMITTEE OF ACADEMIC SENATES.
TO ESTABLISH A SINGULAR LOWER
DIVISION GENERAL EDUCATION
PATHWAY THAT MEANS TRANSFERRED
MISSION TO CSU AND UC. GOING
FROM TWO GENERAL EDUCATION
PATHWAYS TO ONE MAKES IT EASIER
FOR STUDENTS TO APPLY TO BOTH
CSU AND UC. AND KEEP THEIR
OPTIONS OPEN. THIRD THE BILL
WOULD REQUIRE COMMUNITY COLLEGE
STUDENTS TO DECLARE A GOAL OF
TRANSFERRED TO BE PLACED ON AN
ASSOCIATE DEGREE FOR TRANSFER
OR AT T. PATHWAY. WHERE ONE
EXISTS FOR THEIR MAJOR SINCE
THE AT T. GUARANTEES ADMISSION
TO THE CSU SYSTEM AT
PARTICIPATING PRIVATE
INSTITUTIONS THIS PROVISION
WILL INCREASE THE LIKELIHOOD
THAT A STUDENT WILL TRANSFER
AND COMPLETE A BACHELOR'S
DEGREE. IN A TIMELY MANNER. IF
IN AT T. DOES NOT EXIST IN THE
STUDENTS CHOSEN MAJOR THEN
THERE IS NO AT T. FOR THE
STUDENT TO BE PLACED ON.
IMPORTANTLY STUDENTS CAN OPT
OUT IN OUR POWER TO CHOOSE WHAT
IS BEST FOR THEM IN THEIR
EDUCATIONAL GOALS. ALSO NOTHING
IN THIS BILL PROHIBITS A
STUDENT FROM BEING ON THE AT T.
PATHWAY AND ALSO APPLYING TO
TRANSFER TO A UC OR PRIVATE
INSTITUTION. THE TROUBLING
REALITIES OF THE STATUS QUO IS
FAILING OUR STUDENTS. ONLY 20%
OF STUDENTS WITH THE TRANSFER
GOAL SUCCESSFULLY TRANSFER
WITHIN SIX YEARS. THIS IS
SHOCKING AND UNACCEPTABLE
STUDENTS DESERVE BETTER AND
CALIFORNIA CAN DO BETTER. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE- AND WITH ME TODAY I HAVE-
IN TESTIFYING IN PERSON.
MICHELLE SECURUS PRESIDENT OF
THE CAMPAIGN FOR COLLEGE
OPPORTUNITY. AND TESTIFYING
OVER THE PHONE SO YOU'RE
CHRISTIAN CHANCELLOR OF THE
CURRENT COMMUNITY COLLEGE
DISTRICT. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
ALL RIGHT WELL THANK YOU FOR
BEING HERE IN PERSON PLEASE
PROCEDURE OF TWO MINUTES. THANK
YOU GOOD MORNING CHAIR LEYVA
GOOD MORNING SENATORS THANKS
FOR HAVING ME ON MICHELLE C. K.
DOES PRESIDENT OF THE CAMPAIGN
FOR COLLEGE OPPORTUNITY. A
STATEWIDE POLICY RESEARCH AND
ADVOCACY ORGANIZATION OUR FOCUS
IS ALWAYS TO ENSURE GREATER
OPPORTUNITY AND ACCESS AND
SUCCESS FOR STUDENTS IN
CALIFORNIA. AND TO CLOSE THE
RACIAL EQUITY GAPS THAT PERSIST
IN HIGHER EDUCATION. I STAND
HERE BEFORE YOU AS THE DAUGHTER
OF A SEAMSTRESS WHO ONLY AD A
SIXTH GRADE EDUCATION. IT WAS
PETS ARE COLLEGE AND UCLA AND
CAL GRANTS THAT ALLOWED MY
DREAMS TO BECOME A REALITY. AND
FOR A LT OF LOW INCOME FIRST
GENERATION STUDENTS THAT IS
ALSO THE CASE COMMUNITY
COLLEGES ARE THE PATHWAY IN OUR
STATE FOR THAT OPPORTUNITY. ONE
MORE THAN 70% OF COMMUNITY
COLLEGE STUDENTS INDICATE THAT
THEY INTEND TO TRANSFER.
UNFORTUNATELY TRANSFER IS
INCREDIBLY BROKEN IN CALIFORNIA
AFTER TWO YEARS ONLY TWO AND A
HALF PERCENT ACTUALLY DO. I
WANT TO REPEAT THAT ONLY TWO
AND A HALF PERCENT TRANSFER
AFTER TWO YEARS. TO BUILD UPON
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BERMAN'S
REMARKS HIGHLIGHTING THE
TROUBLING TRANSFER RATES. THE
DATA IS EVEN WORSE FOR BLACK
AND WHITE NEXT STUDENTS.
DESPITE HAVING SIMILAR RATES OF
DECLARING TRANSFER AS A GOAL.
ONLY 9% OF BLACK STUDENTS ONLY
10% OF LATIN ACCIDENTS. ARE
SUPPORTED TO TRANSFER AFTER
FOUR YEARS. THIS IS COMPARED TO
SEVENTEEN AND 27% OF THEIR
WHITE AND ASIAN AMERICAN PEERS
RESPECTIVELY WHICH IS ALSO
UNACCEPTABLE. AB NINE TWO EIGHT
DRAWS INTENTIONAL STATEWIDE
FOCUS TO STRENGTHENED
CALIFORNIA'S TRANSFER PROCESS.
BUILDING ON TEN YEARS OF THE
ASSOCIATE DEGREE FOR TRANSFER.
A HISTORIC PROVISION OF THIS
BILL IS TO CREATE A SINGULAR G.
PATHWAY INTO THE UC AND THE CSU
FOR STUDENTS THIS IS TRULY A
GAME CHANGER. THE MASTER PLAN
FOR HIGHER EDUCATION ENVISIONED
THAT WE WOULD HAVE A SEAMLESS
TRANSFER PATHWAY WHEN IN FACT
WE STILL DON'T. THE HARSH
REALITY IS THAT PROSPECTIVE
STROKE TRANSFER STUDENTS HAVE
TO NAVIGATE ADDITIONAL HURDLES
THAT THEIR PEERS FROM HIGH
SCHOOL DIDN'T HAVE TO HIGH
SCHOOL STUDENTS COMPLETE THE
EIGHT THREE G. COURSE
REQUIREMENTS AND THEY CAN APPLY
TO BOTH THE UC AND THE CSU.
THEY DON'T NEED TO NAVIGATE
DIFFERENT HURDLES IN ORDER TO
BE ELIGIBLE FOR ADMISSIONS. BY
REQUIRING THAT COMMUNITY
COLLEGE STUDENTS WHO SEEK TO
APPLY FOR TRANSFER TO BOTH THE
CSU AND UC COMPLETE MULTIPLE
DIFFERENT G. E. PATTERNS. IT'S
AT BEST INEFFECTIVE COSTLY FOR
STUDENTS AND FOR THE STATE. AT
WORST IT'S DISCRIMINATORY FOR
COMMUNITY COLLEGE STUDENTS. IN
TWENTY TEN THIS BODY MADE
HISTORY LED BY THEN STATE
SENATOR ALEX PADILLA ON
TRANSFER REFORM. TODAY WHILE
THE OPPOSITION CLAIMS THERE
ISN'T ANYTHING WRONG I THINK
THOSE STATISTICS BEG TO DIFFER.
THEY MAY PREFER THAT YOU DO
NOTHING BUT YOU HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO MAKE HISTORY AND
FINALLY FIXED TRANSFER ONCE AND
FOR ALL. LET'S MAKE EQUITY IN
HIGHER ED MORE THAN JUST A
SLOGAN THANK YOU AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE THANK YOU ALL RIGHT NEXT
WITNESS ARE YOU ONLY HAVE A
MINUTE LEFT BECAUSE AT FIRST
WHEN IT'S SUPPOSED TO YOUR
TIME. SO PLEASE PROCEED TO HAVE
A MINUTE. GOOD MORNING CHAIR
LEYVA AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE SENT YOUR QUESTION
FOURTEEN DAYS IN MY NEW JOB. AS
CHANCELLOR OF THE COUNTRY TO
COLLEGE DISTRICT PAST PRESENT A
BIGGER SO COLLEGE. FORM ABOUT
THE FACULTY AN IMMIGRANT TO
THIS GREAT COUNTRY. SO LET ME
SKIP OVER. TO MY FINAL
CONCLUDING POINT. SENATE GOAL
FOURTEEN FORTY WITH A POWERFUL
LEGISLATIVE TOOL THAT REQUIRED
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGES
TO OFFER AND SHE IS USED TO
ACCEPTED STUDENTS WITH AT T. A-
STATUS. BUT THERE IS STILL MUCH
WORK TO BE DONE THERE ARE
TROUBLING INEQUITIES THAT
REMAIN PARTICULARLY AMONG OUR
BLACK STUDENTS INCLUDING
THROUGH THE AT T. PARKWAY TO
THE BACHELOR'S DEGREE. IN AB.
NINE TWENTY EIGHT. SENATOR BYRD
BENNETT SPOKE ELOQUENTLY ABOUT
THE KEY. LET ME ANSWER THE LAST
PIECE WHICH IS A COMMUNITY TO.
SHOULD BE GIVEN THE T. AS THE
DEATH AT PLAN IF THEY ARE A
TREND ISSUE IGNORE TO INCREASE
THEIR CHANCES OF SUCCESS. BY
RICK STUDENTS TO OPT OUT DRAWS
THAN CURRENT MODEL WHICH-
STUDENTS TO OPT INTO THE EIGHTY
TWO PATHWAY. WE REMOVE THE
POTENTIAL FOR CHOICE BIAS WHICH
RESULTS IN RACIAL BIAS IN THIS
INITIAL PATHWAY SELECTION WE
CANNOT WE MUST NOT LEAVE EQUITY
TO CHARM. I RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOU TO SUPPORT EIGHTY NINE
TWENTY EIGHT THANK YOU VERY
MUCH ALL RIGHT WE'LL MOVE TO. A
SUPPORT HERE IN ROOM FORTY TWO-
THREE SAYING NONE WILL GO TO
THE OVERFLOW ROOM SINGING NONE
WILL GO TO THE OPERATOR. OF
MADAM ARE MISTER MODERATOR
PLEASE KEEP ANYONE WHO WISHES
TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF AB NINE
TWENTY EIGHT. LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOUR SUPPORT OF AB
NINE TWENTY EIGHT PLEASE PRESS
ONE THEN DO IT THIS TIME. ONE
CAN IN SUPPORT OF EIGHTY NINE
TWENTY EIGHT PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO AT THIS TIME. WHERE TO GO
LINE NUMBER THIRTY FOUR PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME IS
KIMBERLY RURAL AND WHAT THE
NUMBER JANET. THANK YOU THANK
YOU. NEXT TO A LINE NUMBER
EIGHTY TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD.
PINE EIGHTY TO YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. SIX WOULD LINE NUMBER
SEVENTY EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD MORNING SHOW. AND THERE'S
NEEDED TO GET SOMETHING OUT
THAT YOU CAN CENTRAL IN SUPPORT
OF THE BILL. NEXAVAR LINE
NUMBER TWO TWENTY TWO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. LINE TO TWENTY TWO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. THANK YOU
CHAIRMAN COMMITTEE MERRY
WASHINGTON WITH THE CAL STATE
STUDENT ASSOCIATION CO SPONSORS
OF EIGHTY NINE TWENTY EIGHT
REPORT. THANKS TO A LINE NUMBER
TWO TWENTY EIGHT PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR
MEMBERS AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS
MY NAME BUT I SUSPECT NOT LEAVE
WITH HOPE HICKS FINANCE
ORGANIZED FOR POLITICAL
EQUALITY IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
AB NINE TWENTY EIGHT. THE.
THANKS TO A LINE NUMBER SIXTY
FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. I'M SURE
MEMBERS NICK RAMLI ON BEHALF OF
THE WESTERN ASSOCIATION FOR
COLLEGE ADMISSION COUNSELING IN
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
SCHOOL COUNSELORS SPOKE IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
WHEN YOU GO TO LINE NUMBER
FIFTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. LINE
FIFTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN. SIX
ONE ONE NUMBER TWO TWENTY ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH OIL WITH THE CSU WE AGREED
AT THE END OF THE BILL BUT
WOULD ALSO LIKE TO URGE DOCTORS
YOUR DOCTOR AND THEN TO ENSURE
MORE ROOM IN GENERAL AT FIRST
AND CAL HALFWAY. AND YOU ALL TO
ALIGN IT WITH THE ETHNIC
STUDIES LEGISLATION PASSED LAST
YEAR. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
NUMBER ONE NUMBER NINETY TWO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
MY NAME AND IT IN THE L. A. AND
ALSO A MEMBER OF CHEN IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL. NOW THE
LINE NUMBER FORTY THREE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HOW MAY I AM I TOOK
ARE ON BEHALF OF UC STUDENT
ASSOCIATION WE'RE ON TRONG
COURT. THANK YOU. NOW THE LINE
NUMBER EIGHTY TWO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI IT. HANSI EVENTS FORM
PUBLIC ADVOCATE. AND WE ARE IN
STRONG SUPPORT AND AB NINE
TWENTY EIGHT THANK YOU. I WANT
TO GET LAYS IN GERMAN YOUR
SUPPORT OF AB NINE TWENTY EIGHT
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS
TIME. BURGER LINE NUMBER
FIFTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD OUR-
PEOPLE. PINE FIFTEEN YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. THE MANAGER PERCENT
THIS TIME WE HAVE NOBODY ELSE
IN Q. THANK YOU MR MODERATOR WE
WILL NOW GO TO OPPOSITION I
HAVE TWO FOLKS LISTED AS A LEAD
OPPOSITION- JEANNIE MAI AND
RYAN MCKINNEY- WE WILL START
WITH YOU- GINNIE MAE YOU HAVE
TWO MINUTES. A GOOD MORNING
MADAM CHAIR- I'M NOT YOU NAY
BUT I AM RIGHT NOT GOING ANY
AND I WAS TOLD TO START OFF-
ABSOLUTELY- I REPRESENT A
COMMUNITY COLLEGE IN CALIFORNIA
AND WE ARE THE TRADE
ASSOCIATION FOR SEVENTY.
CALIFORNIA SEVENTY THREE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE DISTRICT. WE
ALONG WITH OUR FACULTY COLLEGES
ADOPTED AN OPPOSE UNLESS
AMENDED POSITION REGARDING THE
BILL SH FIRST WE GREW THE
AUTHOR IN THE SPONSOR OF THAT.
THAT CALIFORNIA CAN AND SHOULD
DO A BETTER JOB AGREED TO
TRANSFER RATE THE CLOSING
ACHIEVEMENT GAPS TOO MANY
CALIFORNIANS DECLARE THE COLOR.
LOW INCOME WORKERS THEIR FAMILY
TO ATTEND COLLEGE. LOCKED OUT
OF OUR HIGHER EDUCATION SYSTEM.
WE DO SUPPORT THE I OF A CAN
INCRIMINATING HIGHER EDUCATION
PROFESSIONAL TO BE OUR TO TAKE
A HARD ON HOW WE'RE DOING.
TRANSFER IMMIGRANT DILIGENCE ON
HOW WE CAN. MAKE THE PROCESS
BETTER PURSUIT. WE DO ASK THAT
AN APPOINTEE FROM THE
CALIFORNIA INTERSEGMENT
ARTICULATION CAMP WILL BE ADDED
TO THE COMMITTEE. THAT THEY ARE
CRITICAL TO THE PROCESS.
HOWEVER WE DO HAVE SIGNIFICANT
CONCERNS ON THE UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCES REGARDING THE
MANDATE. CONTAINED IN THE BILL.
ONLY DIFFERENCE WE THINK THAT
THEY SHOULD BE AMENDED OUT AND
ADDED A CRITICAL TOPIC FOR THE
COMMITTEE TO CONSIDER. FOR
EXAMPLE WE THINK THAT BEING
AUTOMATICALLY PLACED INTO
NEEDED HE WILL NOT WORK PLACE
FROM. DO NOT HAVE AN EASY
OPPORTUNITY YOU OR A LOCAL
CAMPUS IS IMPACTED.
ADDITIONALLY AUTOMATICALLY
PLACING A STUDENT INTO NEEDY
TEAM REGARDLESS OF THEIR
EDUCATIONAL GO DIRECTLY AGAINST
THE GUIDED APTLY INITIATIVE BUT
OUR SYSTEM HAS BEEN IMPLEMENTED
FOR THE PAST COUPLE YEARS. I'M
MORE CONCERNED ONLY MANDATE
THAT MAKES TURN OVER TO THE
VICE PRESIDENT OF THE ACT AND
THE- PROFESSOR JEANETTE. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH PLEASE PROCEED.
THANK YOU THANK YOU RUN. AND
DIDN'T. CHAROLAIS MEMBERS OF
COMMITTEE AND- I AM JENNY MAY
VICE PRESIDENT OF THE ACADEMIC
SENATE FOR CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY
COLLEGES. REPRESENTING THE
FIFTY EIGHT THOUSAND CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGE FACULTY AND
CURRICULAR AND ACADEMIC
MATTERS. WE UNDERSTAND AND
APPRECIATE THE AUTHOR'S INTENT
OR REQUIRING A SINGULAR GENERAL
EDUCATION PATHWAY. HOWEVER WE
ARE DEEPLY CONCERNED THAT THE
CSU SYSTEM WOULD HAVE TO ADOPT
THE UC GENERAL EDUCATION
TRANSFER STANDARDS. DUE TO THE
CONSTITUTIONAL ECONOMY OF THE
UC SYSTEM. YOU SEE EXCEPT PARK
YOUR COURSE THEM YES YOU COULD
TRANSFER FROM THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGES. AND THIS IS TRUE FOR
G. COURSES AS WELL. A SINGULAR
GENE PATHWAY WILL LIKELY
ELIMINATE CURRENT SUCCESSFUL
AND BENEFICIAL OPTIONS FOR
STUDENTS. CREATING NEW BARRIERS
TO G. E. PATHWAY COMPLETION. IN
GENERAL INTRODUCTORY COURSES DO
NOT MEET THE REQUIREMENTS FOR
YOU THINK BUT THEY DO ME J. E.
REQUIREMENTS FOR CSU. SOME
EXAMPLES INCLUDE INTRODUCTION
TO PHILOSOPHY. AND MATHEMATICS
FOR ELEMENTARY. SCHOOL TEACHERS
AND THERE ARE MANY MORE. THE
REASONS WE- THAT THE- IN A
MENTAL COMMITTEE BE REQUIRED
TO. US G. POP. I'M PROPOSED THE
G. PALCO THAT BE A- AND CAREER
GOALS ALL. WE'RE TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS AT YOUR CONVENIENCE
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME AND
CONSIDERATION. THANK YOU I WILL
GO TO ANYONE IN OPPOSITION HERE
IN ROOM FORTY TWO OH THREE
SEEING NO ONE WILL GO TO OUR
OVERFLOW ROOM SEEING NO ONE.
MISTER MODERATOR WOULD YOU
PLEASE KEEP ANYONE WHO WISHES
TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF AB
NINE TWENTY EIGHT. I THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION OF AB NINE TWENTY
EIGHT PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO. AN OPERATOR WILL PROVIDE
YOU WITH THE LINE NUMBER AND
PUSHING BACK INTO Q. ONCE AGAIN
IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION OF AB NINE TWENTY
EIGHT. PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
THERE ARE NOW. GO TO LINE SIXTY
ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. STEPHANIE GOLDMAN ON
BEHALF THE FACULTY ASSOCIATION
OF THE CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY
COLLEGES. OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED
OKAY. WELL MY MANAGER WE HAVE
OTHERS DO NOT KNOW ONCE AGAIN
IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION OF AB NINE TWENTY
EIGHT PLEASE PRESS ONE THAN
THERE ARE NOW. BLIND FORTY
EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HELLO MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS THIS IS TYLER ARE YOU
ARE IN BEHALF OF THE UNIVERSITY
OF CALIFORNIA WE DO NOT HAVE IT
THIS NOT THIS TIME THOUGH WE
REMAIN CONCERNED AND WILL
CONTINUE TO WORK. WITH THE
AUTHOR AND HIS STAFF THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. ONE ONE SEVENTY ONE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. YES WE DO HAVE MULTIPLE
CONCERN AND I HAVE A DAUGHTER
THAT IS GRADUATING SHOULD USE
THAT AND TRANSFERRING WE DON'T
NOW HAVE ENOUGH INFORMATION IT
WOULD BE IRRESPONSIBLE FOR
ANYBODY OF THE MEMBERS NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. I WILL THANK YOU.
AT THE TIME AND I'M SURE WE
HAVE NO ONE ELSE THANK YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WILL BRING
IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
SENATOR GLAZERS. THANK YOU AT A
CHAIR LEYVA. YOU KNOW WE HAVE A
SAYING- IN THE SENATE I'M SURE
BABY IN THE ASSEMBLY I DIDN'T
REALLY MEAN TO SPEAK ON THIS
BUT- BUT NOT NOW. I CAME HERE
BECAUSE I WANT TO SPEAK ON THIS
IS VERY GOOD AND- I TELL YOU I
IF- IF I DIDN'T NEED MY BLOOD
PRESSURE GALLON. THIS TO BE THE
PLACE TO GO TO GET A GALLON AND
LISTENING TO THIS DISCUSSION
THUS FAR. YEAH I HAD A FRONT
ROW SEAT ON THIS ISSUE FOR MANY
MANY YEARS I SAID AS A MEMBER
OF THE BOARD OF TRUSTEES. AT
THE BEGINNING OF THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE AT T.
PROCESS. AND WE BECAME SO
FRUSTRATED WITH THE YEARS THAT
HAD GONE BY. WITHOUT MEANINGFUL
PROGRESS IN THAT TRANSFER TRACK
THAT WE- REQUIRE THAT EVERY
MEETING OF THE BOARD OF
TRUSTEES WE NEEDED A REPORT AN
UPDATE. BECAUSE WE WERE WE WERE
SAYING THAT THERE WAS NO
PROGRESS BEING MADE IN THIS
SPACE AND WE ALL RECOGNIZE. HOW
CONSEQUENTIAL THIS IS TO SO
MANY STUDENTS. THAT THOUGHT
THEY WERE DOING THE RIGHT
THING. IN IN THEIR COMMUNITY
COLLEGE CLASS. AND THEN
REALIZING THAT ALL THOSE UNITS
AND ALL THAT TIME. AND GRANTED
ANY KIND OF LEARNING IS A
HEALTHY THING IN A WONDERFUL
THING. BUT ALL THAT TIME. CAME
ZERO. WHEN IT CAME TO GETTING.
PROGRESS TO DEGREE. AND THEN
THIS IS IT AN INCREDIBLE
FAILURE THAT I SAW. BACK IN THE
200-015-2000 SIXTEEN PERIOD.
AND IT FRUSTRATED THE HECK OUT
OF US. AND WE ASKED A LOT OF
QUESTIONS ABOUT WHY THE
FACULTY. WERE NOT ENGAGING AND
CERTIFYING THESE COURSES. ARE
THESE DAYS IS- BRAIN SURGERY
WERE TRYING TO CERTIFY THESE
COURSES NO FOLKS. THESE ARE
INTRODUCTORY COURSES THESE ARE
THE MOST BASIC COURSES. IN OUR
UNIVERSITY SYSTEM IN ANY
SUBJECT AREA. WHETHER IT'S
ENGLISH OR MATH OR LANGUAGE.
THIS WAS IN A COMPLICATED
THING. AND I THINK THAT OUR
FACULTY. IN ALL OF THESE.
SEGMENTS WERE NOT ABLE TO GET
TOGETHER AND FIGURE THIS THING
OUT. WHEN WE WERE SEEN TRAIN
WRECKS HAPPENING EVERY YEAR.
WITH THOUSANDS OF STUDENTS.
DOING THE WRONG THING. FROM AN
INSTITUTION THAT'S SUPPOSED TO
HELP THEM DO THE RIGHT THING.
AND GET THEM ON THE RIGHT TRACK.
AND SO WE GET TO WATCH EVERY
YEAR THAT TRAIN CRASH HAPPENING.
WE LOVE OUR INSTITUTIONS OF
HIGHER EDUCATION THEY ARE THE
MOST INCREDIBLE JEWELS THAT WE
HAVE IN OUR STATE THAT EVERY
LEVEL. AND WE HAVE SOME OF THE
SMARTEST PEOPLE LEADING THOSE
INSTITUTIONS. GREAT PRESIDENT
GREAT FACULTY AND GET TO SEE
THIS TYPE OF A BREAKDOWN. IT'S
STUNNING. AND HAVE A BILL
THAT'S PERFECT FOR US TODAY.
THE TRIED TO CONTINUE TO REPAIR
THIS PROBLEM IS STUNNING. IT IS
A COMPLETE FAILURE. OF OUR
WONDERFUL INSTITUTIONS TO DEAL
WITH THIS PROBLEM. AT ITS CRAZY
IS THE BUREAUCRACY FAILING US.
CAN WE TALK A LOT ABOUT HOW
GREATER INSTITUTIONS ARE
ACCESSIBILITY LOW COST QUALITY.
BUT COMPLETION MY FRIENDS.
COMPLETION IS A SERIOUS PROBLEM.
THAT STUDENTS ARE TAKING THE
RIGHT COURSES THAT THEY'RE
GETTING THEIR DEGREE IT THAT'S
WHAT THEY WANT. IF THAT'S WHAT
THEY WANT A LOT OF KIDS GO TO
COMMUNITY COLLEGES FOR OTHER
REASONS GOOD REASONS. IT THERE
TRY TO GET PROGRESS 2 DEGREES
WE ARE FAILING. WE ARE FAILING.
AND I SAY TO MY FRIENDS IN THE
FACULTY. WE HAVE PLEADED WITH
YOU. PLEASE COMMUNICATE
COOPERATE WORK IT OUT CREATE
THE PATHWAYS THESE ARE
INTRODUCTORY COURSES. N. Y.
INTRODUCTORY COURSE IN
POLITICAL SCIENCE OR BIOLOGY IS
NOT THE TRACK TO GET TO UC OR
CSU COME ALIVE SO NOW THEY'VE
HAD TEN YEARS. AND E HAVE A
IT'S A PROBLEM AND WE'VE GOT TO
DO BETTER TEN. ASSEMBLY MENU
OUR COURSE RIGHT. AND I APPLAUD
YOUR DEDICATION AND YOUR
COMMITMENT TO THIS ISSUE. AND
IT'S FRUSTRATES THE HECK OUT OF
ME TO SEE A BILL LIKE THIS AND
TO SEE THE OPPOSITION. STILL
THERE. FORCES THEM TO DO THAT'S
NOT ENOUGH REPRESENTATION HERE.
COME ON FOLKS WE ARE FAILING
OUR KIDS AND WE CANNOT BE
PATIENT IN THE SPACE WE CANNOT.
AND SO TODAY I'M HAPPY TO
SUPPORT THIS BILL. I HOPE THAT
THE FACULTY ARE WONDERFUL
FACULTY CAN REALIZE THAT THEY
CARE ABOUT THE STUDENTS WE KNOW
THEY CARE WILL STEP UP AND GET
THIS THING DONE CREATE THOSE
PATHWAYS ELIMINATE THIS
MISCOMMUNICATION. MAKE SURE
WE'RE HELPING OUR KIDS SIXTY
NOT JUST IN YOUR CLASSROOM. BUT
IN THE EDUCATION BUREAUCRACY
WHICH THIS BILL TRIES TO
OVERCOME ONCE AGAIN. HAPPY TO
SUPPORT YOUR BILL SIR. THANK
YOU SENATOR GLAZERS ANYONE ELSE
COMMENTS QUESTIONS CONCERNS
SEEING NONE SHALL I TAKE THAT
AS A MOTION SENATOR GLAZERS
MEMBER BERMAN PLEASE CLOSE THAT
WAS MY CLOTHES BEAUTIFUL THANK
YOU VERY MUCH CENTER GLAZER AND
HOPEFULLY COMMITTEE MEMBERS FOR
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. THE BILL
HAS BEEN MOVED BY SENATOR
GLAZERS MADAM CONSULTANT PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. FILE ITEM NUMBER
EIGHT A. B. NINE TWENTY EIGHT
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED THE FIRST AMENDED AND
RE REFER TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS SENATOR LEYVA.
HI LIVE AUDIO TROUBLED. OCTOBER
NOT VOTING CORTESE ACT
ACTUALLY. I'M SORRY HERE THE
TROUBLE IS NOT. IN THE ROOM
SENATOR CORTESE. PARTISI I HAD
DALY HI KELLY I SENATOR GLAZERS
GLAZER AYE MCGUIRE PAM. THE
WHOLE BIT BILL OPEN THANK YOU
ASSEMBLY MEMBER THANK YOU VERY
MUCH ALL RIGHT WE ARE MOVING ON
TO FILE ITEM NUMBER NINE AB TEN
FORTY BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
MEDICINE SHE AS SOON AS THE
PODIUM IS READY. PLEASE BEGIN A
FRESH START. THANK YOU. AND. DR
OKAY GOOD. WELL ASSEMBLYMEMBER
PROCEED WHEN YOU'RE READY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH SIR MADAM
CHAIR AND GOOD MORNING
SENATORS- I'M HERE TO PRESENT
AB TEN FORTY AND FIRST OF ALL I
WANT TO THANK- YOU MADAM CHAIR
FOR THE COURTESY AND THE
RESPECT. THAT WE'VE HAD IN IN
DISCUSSING THIS BILL AND FOR
ALLOWING US TO PRESENT THIS
BILL OF CLOUT HERE TODAY. SO AS
A ALL OF YOU I BELIEVE NO. V.
CALIFORNIA COMMITTEE COLLEGE
BOARD OF GOVERNORS- TOOK A
HISTORIC VOTE. ON MONDAY TO
ADOPT- THE ETHNIC STUDIES
REQUIREMENT FOR THE ASSOCIATE
DEGREE THAT WE- ARE SEEKING AN
IN THIS BILL A. B. TEN FORTY.
AND SO- LAST NIGHT I CALLED.
THE LOS SENSES COMMITTEE
COLLEGE DISTRICT CHANCELLOR
FRANCISCO RODRIGUEZ THAT-
YOU'LL BE HEARING- AS ONE OF
THE SUPPORTING WITNESSES
WHETHER HE WANTED TO PROCEED
WITH THIS BILL. AND HE MADE A
POINT THAT I. COMPLETELY AGREED
WITH AND- WAS THE REASON WHY I
WANTED TO I JOIN HIM AND
REQUESTING THAT WE BE ALLOWED
TO PRESENT THIS BILL NOT
WITHSTANDING THE BOARD OF
GOVERNORS VOTE WHICH IS THAT.
THIS MORNING THIS COMMITTEE
HEARD AB ONE ON ONE. TO
ESTABLISH THE EPIC SAYS
REQUIREMENT FOR OUR K. THROUGH
TWELVE SCHOOLS. LAST YEAR WE
HAD AB FOURTEEN SIXTY THAT
ESTABLISHED THE REQUIREMENT.
FOR CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY.
WHY NOT FOR A COMMUNITY
COLLEGES. WHY WHY WHY DOESN'T
TAKE AS A COMMUNITY COLLEGES
HAVE ITS OWN LAW THAT REQUIRES
AN ATTIC STATUS REQUIREMENT FOR
THE LARGEST AND MOST DIVERSE.
YES IT'S A SYSTEM OF PUBLIC
HIGHER EDUCATION NOT ONLY IN
CALIFORNIA BUT IN THE ENTIRE
COUNTRY. WE KNOW THAT IT OUT
LAWS. HAVE A STRONGER. AND GOOD
AND THEN REGULATIONS AND SO
THIS IS OUR OPPORTUNITY THIS IS
THE LEGISLATURE IS OPPORTUNITY
TO PASS AN ETHNIC STUDIES
REQUIREMENT FOR OUR CALIFORNIA
COMMUNICABLE AS HIS FOREIGN
ASSOCIATE DEGREE TO DEMONSTRATE
OUR COMMITMENT NOT ONLY TO THE
PRINCIPAL AND THE REQUIREMENT
OF AN ETHICS IS REQUIREMENT BUT
ALSO TO DEMONSTRATE OUR
COMMITMENT TO ENSURE THAT THERE
WILL BE ADEQUATE FUNDING. TO-
TO MAKE SURE THAT THIS PROGRAM
IS A SUCCESS AND IT'S ALSO-
THIS BILL IS CRITICAL AND IT
GOES BEYOND WHAT THE BOARD OF
GOVERNORS VOTED ON ON MONDAY.
AND THAT. THIS WOULD REQUIRE V.
V. THE FACILITATION OF THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE ETHICS
STUDIES COURSES TO BE ACCEPTED
BY THE CALIFORNIA STATE
UNIVERSITIES. RIGHT NOW- YOU
DON'T CENTER GLAZER WE JUST
GAVE ELOQUENT SPEECH ABOUT HOW
BUREAUCRACIES CAN UNDERMINE A
PROXIES- DRAG THINGS OUT AND
MAKE IT DIFFICULT IN ORDER TO
WORK FROM ONE SILO TO ANOTHER
THIS BILL WILL REQUIRE. THAT
THE COMMITTEE COLLEGE ETHICS
STUDIES COURSES WILL BE
ACCEPTED BY THE CALIFORNIA
STATE UNIVERSITY AND IT WILL
SET FORTH. YOU KNOW WE HAVE THE
ABILITY TO CROSS. THOSE THOSE
SILOS IN THIS CASE THE
COMMUNICABLE SYSTEM AND OUR AND
THE CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY
SYSTEM- TO ENSURE THAT WE WILL
HAVE A SEAMLESS TRANSFER- IN IN
TERMS OF ETHNIC STUDIES COURSES
FROM OUR COMMUNICATORS TO
FULFILL THE CAL STATE
UNIVERSITY AT THE EXTRAS
REQUIREMENT. HERE IN SUPPORT OF
THE BILL- TO SPEAKER AND
PERHAPS EVEN MORE PASSIONATELY
IN SUPPORT OF AB TEN FORTY IS
THE LOSS AS A COMMUNITY COLLEGE
DISTRICT CHANCELLOR FRANCISCO
RODRIGUEZ. WHO'S A SPONSOR OF
THIS BILL AS WELL AS WE HAD TO
CHANGE AND NOW- WITNESSES-
MADAM CHAIR- TUDYK ZINE A
STUDENT AT UC DAVIS FOR A
COMMUNITY COLLEGE STUDENT AND
MEMBER OF THE STUDENT SENATE OF
THE CALIFORNIA COMMUNICATIONS
IS TERRIFIC THANK YOU VERY MUCH
ASSEMBLY MEMBER ALL RIGHTWE'RE
GOING TO START WITH CHANCELLOR
RODRIGUEZ YOU HAVE TWO MINUTES.
AND THEN WE WILL GO TO
RECONVENE AND YOU WALK TWO
MINUTES AS WELL CHANCELLOR
PLEASE PROCEED. THANK YOU-
CHAIR LEYVA AUDIBLE MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE AND STAFF A GOOD
MORNING FRANCISCO THE GUESTS ON
THIS I SERVICE CHANCE FOR THE
LOS ANGELES COMMITTEE COLORS
DISTRICT AND I'M VERY HONORED.
TO JOIN YOU THIS MORNING ALONG
WITH SOME AMEND. MURATSUCHI
REPRESENTING L. A. C. CITY IN
THE AS THE PROUD SPONSOR OF AB
TEN FORTY. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MURATSUCHI MENTIONED IN HIS
OPENING STATEMENT THIS BILL
ADDRESSES THE CRITICAL ISSUE.
OF ETHNIC STUDIES IN COMMUNITY
COLLEGES SELECTED EVERYDAY WHY
WE BELIEVE THAT THIS BILL
SHOULD BECOME LAW FOLLOWED BY
SOME BRIEF POINTS ABOUT THE
BENEFITS OF ETHNIC STUDIES. THE
SENATE EDUCATION COMMITTEE
ANALYSIS QUESTIONS THE NEED FOR
THIS BILL FOLLOWING THE RECENT.
COMMUNITY COLLEGE BOARD OF
GOVERNORS VOTE AND THE APPROVAL
OF TOTAL FIVE REGULATIONS AND
INCLUDING THREE UNIT THAT
THINKS THAT IS GRADUATION
REQUIREMENT. FOR THE CALIFORNIA
COMMITTEE COLLEGE ASSOCIATES
DEGREE I WOULD LIKE TO
HIGHLIGHT WHY THIS BILL IS
STILL NECESSARY FIRST COSTA
REIMBURSEMENT. THE
LEGISLATURE'S PASSAGE AND
GOVERNOR'S SIGNATURE OF AB
FOURTEEN SIXTY LAST YEAR DR
WEBBER'S LANDMARK LEGISLATION
TO REQUIRE SATISFACTORY
COMPLETION OF A LOWER DIVISION.
I THINK STUDIES COURSE IN ORDER
TO RECEIVE A BACHELOR'S DEGREE
AT THE CSU ESSENTIALLY REQUIRES
THE COMMUNITY COLLEGES TO OFFER
I THINK STUDIES FOR OUR
STUDENTS. WHO PLAN TO TRANSFER
TO A CSU THIS BILL BOTH
COMPLIMENTS AND CONFORMS TO THE
REQUIREMENTS. OF AB FOURTEEN
SIXTY ASSEMBLY MEMBER POINTED
OUT AB TEN FORTY WILL ALSO
ENSURE THE COMMITTEE COLLEGES.
WHICH ALREADY THE MOST UNDER
FUNDED. EDUCATION SYSTEM WILL
PROBABLY WILL PROBABLY BE
REIMBURSED FOR THIS NEW
REQUIREMENT. ARTICLE THIRTEEN
B. SECTION SIX OF THE
CALIFORNIA CONSTITUTION
PROVIDES THAT WHENEVER THE
STATE MANDATES A NEW PROGRAMMER
HIGHER LEVELS SERVICE. BY THE
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGES
IT QUOTE STATE SHALL PROVIDE
FUNDING TO REIMBURSE THE LOCAL
GOVERNMENT FOR THE COST OF THE
PROGRAM OR INCREASED LEVELS
SERVICE. I'M THEREFORE COSTS
ASSOCIATED WITH OFFERING
NOTHING STUDIES COURSES AND ANY
OTHER COSTS ASSOCIATED WITH
COMPLYING WITH A. B. TEN FORTY
COULD BE SUBJECT. TO
REIMBURSEMENT. BY THE STATE IN
CONTRAST TOTAL FIVE REGULATIONS
IN. SIMILAR REQUIRE COULD NOT
IN. COMMITTEE COLLEGES TO ANY
OF. APPROPRIATION FROM THE
STATE GENERAL. SECOND ANY
REQUIREMENT IMPOSED BY
REGULATION ALONE COULD BE
SUPERSEDED BY STATUTE THE TOTAL
FIVE REGULATIONS PROMULGATED BY
THE CALIFORNIA CAN BECAUSE
BOARD OF GOVERNORS ARE ENACTED
TO IMPLEMENT. THE EDUCATION
CODE A SUBSEQUENT LEGISLATIVE
ENACTMENT AMENDING THE CODE
COULD POTENTIALLY INVALIDATE
THE BOARD'S REGULATIONS AB TEN
FORTY PROVIDES ADDITIONAL
PROTECTIONS. FOR THE ETHNIC
STUDIES PROGRAMMING COMMITTEE
COLLEGE STUDENTS THAT ARE
BEYOND. THE AUTHORITY OF THE
BOARD OF GOVERNORS TO ADOPT IN
TOTAL FIVE. REGULATIONS AB TEN
FORTY REQUIRES A CSU TO
COORDINATE. WITH THE CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGES TO ACCEPT
TRANSFER UNITS FOR COMPLETION
OF COMMUNITY COLLEGE I THINK
STUDIES COURSES FINALLY. THE
BILL REQUIRES THAT THE L. A.
O.'S OFFICE CONDUCT A STUDY
THAT WILL ENABLE AN ASSESSMENT
OF POLITICS STUDIES. COURSES
ARTICULATED BETWEEN THE TWO
SYSTEMS THIS PROVISION IS NOT
INCLUDED IN THE BOARD OF
GOVERNORS REGULATIONS IN
CLOSING. I WOULD UNDERGRADUATE
YOU'RE GONNA STUDIES MAJOR FROM
UC DAVIS HAVE FIRST HAND
KNOWLEDGE OF THE BENEFITS BUT I
THINK STUDIES HIDING CONTINUES
TO HAVE. IN MY PERSONAL AND
PROFESSIONAL LIFE IT CAN DO THE
SAME AND MORE FOR COMMUNITY
COLLEGE STUDENTS. GIVEN THE
RACIAL STRIFE THAT WE'VE
EXPERIENCED THROUGHOUT THIS
COUNTRY ANY IMPORTANT DEMANDS
FOR RACIAL EQUITY. YOUR RACE
ETHNICITY IN CLASS AND PROVIDES
A FRAMEWORK TO PUSH TODAY
CIRCUMSTANCES INTO CONTEXT
WHICH ULTIMATELY HELPS OUR
STUDENTS BUILD. A MORE INFORMED
RACIALLY JUST AND INCLUSIVE
FUTURE A FUTURE THAT THEY WILL
INHERIT AND BENEFIT FROM.
CALIFORNIA HAS THE LARGEST AND
MOST DIVERSE COMMITTEE COLOR
SYSTEM IN THE COUNTRY PERHAPS
THE WORLD ADOPTION OF AB. TEN
FORTY IS LANDMARK LEGISLATION
THAT WILL PLACE CALIFORNIA AS
THE LEADER IN THAT THE STUDIES
WERE COMMUNITY COLLEGES IN THE
MOST RACIALLY AND ETHNICALLY
DIVERSE STATE IN THE COUNTRY.
AT A TIME IN OUR HISTORY WHAT
ARE USED OUR COMMUNITIES NEED
IT THE MOST THANK YOU FOR YOUR
THOUGHTFUL CONSIDERATION FOR
THESE REASONS. I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE ON AB TEN
FORTY. THANK YOU CHANCELLOR YOU
TOOK UP ALL OF YOUR TIME AND
YOU TOOK UP ALL OF TWO WEEKS
TIME. SO TREAT IF YOU WOULD
LIKE TO JUST STATE YOUR NAME
AND YOUR SUPPORT THAT WOULD BE
TERRIFIC. YEAH MY NAME IS THE
MINIMUM FROM A MEMBER OF THE AT
THE SHIP WHICH IS BOARD
DIRECTORS IN THE CURRENT CHAIR
OF THE TRANSFER THE ENTRY
VETERANS COMMITTEE PRETTY
ACCEPTED STUDENTS UC DAVIS
GETTING MY SUPPORT. PORTANTINO
AND PARTY THANK YOU. AND KNOW
GO GO AHEAD AND TAKE A MINUTE
IT'S NOT FAIR THAT THE
CHANCELLOR TOOK ALL OF YOUR
TIME IN IT AND YOU STAYED ON
AND YOU ARE ONE OF OUR STUDENTS
SO. GO AHEAD AND MAKE YOUR
STATEMENT. THEN THERE'S- THANK
YOU SO MUCH SHARE- I TRIED TO
COMPETE. HE DID WAS RIGHT BUT
MY FIRST AT. HE'S QUITE THE
CATCH. REPORT WHICH IS AN
AMERICAN STUDIES CLASS. THE
FIRST TIME AT. WHY CHIU GOT
CAUGHT. TO WALK IN AND YOU.
SPEECH IN THE BANGALI AND-
AMERICA STUDENT. AT THE BUT HE
HAS THE POWER TO CHANGE. IN THE
SOUTH. HOW NEGATIVE. THE
CLASSICAL BALL. ACROSS YOU SEE
PRESENTLY. WE DON'T LEARN
AMERICAN. COURSE THAT LESSON A
HUNDRED YEARS AGO THIS COURT
RULED THAT PEOPLE OF INDIAN.
WERE IN. ACTUALLY THE- OR THE
GIVE. YOU THAT THOSE WITH
HIGHER LEVELS AT. MANY THE
FINANCIAL IN A- TO BE. ACTUALLY
THE CARD FOR SOME. THE ONLY
OPERA. OF THE- TO A COPPER
PACKAGE. FROM PERSPECTIVE OF
THE- MY- COMMUNITIES. AND MAKE
THIS WORK. IN THE MOST I. STOCK
HIGHER AT. IN CALIFORNIA. IS A
RIGHT OR- THANK YOU AND I
REALLY HOPE IT CAN SUPPORT YOUR-
I THINK YOU AND I STRONGLY URGE.
THE APPROVAL OF THE- THANK YOU
VERY YOU'RE ALL. A INFORM
STUDENTS YOU PAUL TIMING WE MAY
OF. THE WE'RE NOW GOING TO GO
TO THE IN THE SUPPORT HERE IN
ROOM FORTY TWO OR THREE. PLEASE
STATE YOUR NAME. AND YOUR
SUPPORT OF THE BILL. A MAN IN
CHAIR MEMBER OF. BE A FOR HAND.
MIX AMERICAN ONE OF THE US ALL
RIGHT. THE JOSE. COMMUNITY
COLLEGE DISTRICT VERY MUCH IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU SIR NEXT.
MAREZ SAID JOHNSON ON BEHALF OF
THE CAMPAIGN FOR COLLEGE
OPPORTUNITY IN STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU. WE WILL NOW GO TO
OUR OVERFLOW ROOM SEEING NO ONE
THERE WILL GO TO THE PHONE
LINES MISTER MODERATOR IF YOU
COULD PLEASE KEEP ANYONE WHO
WISHES TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT. OF
AB TEN FORTY. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF
YOU WISH TO BE IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF AB TEN
FORTY. PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO AN OPERATOR WILL PROVIDE
YOU WITH YOUR LINE NUMBER AND
PLACE YOU BACK INTO Q. ONCE
AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
pZERO. PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
THERE ARE NOW. THE MANAGER WILL
START WITH ONE ONE EIGHTEEN.
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON REBECCA
GONZALEZ NATIONAL ASSOCIATION
OF SOCIAL WORKERS CALIFORNIA
CHAPTER IN THE PARKS. BY NUMBER
TWO FORTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. YOUR LINE
IS ON YOUTH LINE TO FORTY FIVE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. BY NUMBER
SIXTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU OUT
YOU'RE ON MEMBERS MARK MCDONALD
M. G. R. TO C. ON BEHALF OF THE
CHROME CHAMBER A DINO CALL
CLIENTS IN FRANCISCO COMMUNITY
COLLEGE DISTRICTS. AS WELL AS
THE- LOS ANGELES COLLEGE
FACULTY DEVELOP AND SUPPORT OF
THE BILL THANK YOU. MY NUMBER
TWO FORTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. MICHAEL
YOUNG WITH CALIFORNIA
FEDERATION OF TEACHERS AND
SUPPORT. MY NUMBER TWO FIFTY
ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GO AHEAD.
HI NEARLY WE SURE CAN. OKAY
THANK YOU ZERO BATES THE BLACK
LIVES MATTER LOS ANGELES LONG
BEACH TO BLACK LIVES MATTER
CALIFORNIA CALLING IT THE
STRONG SUPPORT OF THE BILL
REQUEST I THANK YOU. MY NUMBER
ONE SEVENTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
CAROLYN BABAFEMI HAPPENED
PASADENA CITY COLLEGE AND THE
SACRAMENTO YOUNG DEMOCRATS
SUPPORT. THANK YOU LINE NUMBER
TWO FORTY SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. WELL I'M ROB
SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA FACULTY ASSOCIATION
IN SUPPORT OF AB TEN FORTY
THANK YOU. THE LINE NUMBER ONE
EIGHTY NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING I
AM CANCELING MY BRAND OF THE
HALF OF. HE FIFTEEN TWENTY ONE
PACKAGING HE'LL NUMBER AND
STRONG SUPPORT OF AB TEN FORTY
REQUESTING AN IPHONE THANK YOU
THANK YOU. THE NUMBER TWO OH
SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI THIS IS COUNTY YOU
KNOW FROM EL CAMINO COLLEGE AFT
THIRTEEN EIGHTY EIGHT AND WE
SUPPORT THE BILL. YEAH THANK
YOU. MY NUMBER ONE EIGHTY EIGHT
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO THIS IS CARL ON
BEHALF OF AMERICAN FEDERATION
OF TEACHERS AND THE LOS ANGELES
COMMUNITY COLLEGE DISTRICT
CALLING IN SUPPORT. OF THE BILL.
MY NUMBER ONE THIRTY TWO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
BUT I GUESS OTHER CRITICAL. THE
HOBBIT. LIKE THOSE MA'AM MAYBE
RELY THAT YOU ARE ONE THIRTY
TWO JULY IS OPEN GO AHEAD.
HELLO GOOD MORNING- MY NAME IS
NATALIE. I'M WITH LOVE AND
COLLEGE IN TO GET- AND THE
POLITICAL DIRECTOR FOR THE CALL
FACULTY ALONG CALL IN SICK OF
BILL THANK YOU. THANK YOU. LINE
NUMBER TWO THIRTY ONE JULY IS
OPEN PLEASE CALL. THE DAY DR
JOSH WHEN BACK ON THE NUMBER OF
ANGELES MISSION. PART OF THE
LAS ANGELES CA COLLEGE DISTRICT
ON BEHALF OF A IT ONE IN
SUPPORT. OF THIS BILL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. MY NUMBER TWO
EIGHTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO I'M DR
JEFF SIX OF THE LOS ANGELES
COMMUNITY COLLEGE DISTRICT M.
F. G. FIFTEEN TWENTY ONE
FACULTY GO CALLING IN FAVOR OF
AB TEN FORTY THANK YOU VERY
MUCH THANK YOU. MY NUMBER TWO
FORTY FOUR YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MAYBE OUR
LINES I MEAN LINE NUMBER TWO
FORTY FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN. MY
NUMBER ONE EIGHTY SIX YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY
NUMBER ONE EIGHTY SIX MAYBE ON
YOU. HELLO MY NAME IS DAVID AND
FROM THAT MAKE UP THAT IS
IMPATIENT- FIFTEEN TWENTY ONE
AND I AM CALLING ON THE SERBS
APART UP A. B. TEN TWENTY. MY
NUMBER TWO FORTY NINE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO
MORNING MY NAME IS TRINA
CARRILLO I'M CALLING. ON THE
HAPPEN BLACK LIVES MATTER LOS
ANGELES CALLING IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF AB TEN FORTY
REQUESTING AN AYE VOTE THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. THE LINE NUMBER
TWO FORTY THREE THE LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. DR DAVID
OFTEN CANNELLA INCREASE CD AND
AMERICAN FEDERATION OF TEACHERS
LOCAL FIFTEEN TWENTY ONE I HOPE
YOU TAKE THE CHANCELLOR'S OF
BIRDS ARE AND GRANT PRESCRIBED
LEGAL CRITICAL NEXT CALLER
PLEASE WORD THAT. LINE NUMBER
TWO THIRTY FOUR YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. I THANK
YOU MY NAME IS GOLDEN SHEARS-
ALARM THAT- THE LOS ANGELES
COMMUNITY COLLEGE DISTRICT AND
UCLA IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THE
BILL AS- INCORRECT OKAY QUICKLY
I SHARE QUOTE BY MARIANA LOPEZ
CULTURE IS LIKE A TREE IF THE
GREEN BRANCHES IT PEOPLE'S
LANGUAGE RELIGIONS CUSTOMS ARE
CAREFULLY CHOPPED OFF HELL IN
THE ROOT AND FIND. TO THEIR
PLACE NOT A WRITER ENGAGE COLOR
PLEASE. THANK YOU. MY NUMBER
TWO TEN LINE IS A PLEASE AHEAD.
HI MY NAME IS COMPILED FROM
COMMUNITY DISTRICT IN FIFTY
TWENTY ONE. ONLY COLLEGE BACK
ON GUILTY NINE CORNER OF THE
TWO FORTY. BELGRADE YOU THANK
YOU. BY NUMBER TWO YOUR LINE IS
OPEN GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS DR
REBEKAH RAMON ON THE SOCIOLOGY
PROFESSOR PROFESSOR AT SANTA
MONICA COLLEGE AND I'M CALLING
IN SUPPORT OF AB. TEN FORTY. MY
NUMBER TWO FORTY EIGHT YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MY NUMBER TWO FORTY EIGHT MAYBE
OUR LINES AND YOU. MY NUMBER
TWO THIRTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. I'M
THINKING COMING HERE ME. WE CAN.
OKAY SORRY ABOUT THAT HI MY
NAME ABOUT THE MONEY FROM WHAT
I KNOW I'M FROM THE HOOD THE
DEPARTMENT BY MARKET-
REQUESTING- SUPPORT OF AB TEN
FORTY THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK
YOU. THE LINE NUMBER TWO FIFTY
THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS LI
O'REILLY A MEMBER THE A. F. T.
FIFTEEN TWENTY ONE THE LOS
ANGELES COLLEGE OUT PRETTY ILL
AND I'M IN SUPPORT OF THE A. B.
TEN FORTY I THINK THAT HE'S
BILL THANK YOU. THANK YOU. MY
NUMBER TWO FIFTY SEVEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HI MY NAME IS KIM ISAAC I'M
FROM BLACK LIVES MATTER LOS
ANGELES. I'M WRONG THE COURT AB
TEN FORTY THANK YOU. ONCE AGAIN
IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
OF AB TEN FORTY PLEASE PRESS
ONE THEN THERE ARE NOW. AND AT
THE TIME OUT UNTIL WE- WE DO
HAVE A COUPLE TO NOT ONE MOMENT
OKAY. NUMBER TWO FORTY FIVE
DEADLINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. ADMINISTRATION READING
WITH BLACK LIVES MATTER LOS
ANGELES AND I'M CALLING TO
SPEAK MY STRONG SUPPORTER OF AB.
TEN FORTY. ONE MOMENT ADAM SO
WE STILL HAVE PEOPLE QUEUING UP.
THE GOVERNOR LINE NUMBERS NOW
ONE MOMENT HERE. NO PROBLEM.
THE LINE NUMBER TWO FIFTY FIVE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME IS FRANK
WATER I'M FROM LA PPD A MEMBER
OF ATF ONE FIVE TWO ONE AND I'D
LIKE TO PUT MY SUPPORT IN FOR
A. B. TEN FORTY. THANK THANK
YOU. NUMBER TWO FIFTY SIX YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HI CAN YOU HEAR ME WE CAN. OKAY
GREAT ITS DOWN WILLIAMS I'M
WITH BLACK LIVES MATTER A LOT
AND WE'RE CALLING IN IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF AB PORT. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MY NUMBER MY NUMBER
TWO FIFTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY
NAME IS DANNY OUT THEN FROM B.
L. N. IN STRONG SUPPORT OF AB
PEN. FORTY ANOTHER TIME OUT I'M
SURE THERE'S NO ONE ELSE IN Q.
THANK YOU MADAM MODERATOR WE
WILL NOW MEET LEAGUE MOVED TO
OPPOSITION I HAVE ONE PERSON
LISTED AS LEAD OPPOSITION. THAT
IS DAVID O'BRIEN DAVID ARE YOU
MAY PROCEED AND SENSE THE LEAD-
SUPPORT TOOK FOUR MINUTES YOU
MAY HAVE FOUR MINUTES AS WELL.
Q. SO MUCH MADAM CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBER IF I COULD-
MAKE A POINT OF CLARIFICATION A
VERY IMPORTANT POINT- UNDIVIDED
BY CENTER FOR GOVERNMENT
RELATIONS WITH THE CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGES WE ARE NOT A
PROBLEM. ASSEMBLY BILL TEN
FORTY- WE SHOULD HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO WORK WITH YOUR
OUTSTANDING. STAFF MADAM CHAIR
ON PRESENTING A LITTLE BIT. OF
CONTACT AND- IN THE ABOUT THE
RED. BUT BORDER GOT GRAY-
DOCTOR REGARDING THINK STATE SO
I WITH YOUR PERMISSION-
JERMAINE LIKE WORKING ON THE
UNDERSTAND THAT WE ARE. BUT YOU
ON THE BILL OPPOSITION MONEY
IT'S JUST A LITTLE BIT OF
PROJECT IN DETAIL ABOUT THE-
GROUNDBREAKING BUT- BEFORE
GOVERNOR ABOUT THE THIS WEEK
YEAH ALL RIGHT YES ABSOLUTE AND
NOTED. ALL RIGHT THANK YOU SO
MUCH A LITTLE DELAY YOU ONE OF
KNOWLEDGE THANK YOU SOME OF
THEM WORK. ABOUT MARGINS
RODRIGUEZ- IMMIGRATED OF LOS
ANGELES COMMUNITY COLLEGE IF
YOU'RE CALL THE OTHER TO
AGREEMENT WITH CONVERSATION
REGARDING THE VALUE RATHER THAN
THIRTY. THE THE CHANCE OF THE-
CALLED THE ORDER GOT COMPLETELY
SHARE YOUR COMMITMENT TO
DECOLONIZING CURRICULUM AND
PROMOTING DIVERSITY EQUITY. AND
INCLUSION IN OUR COMMUNITY
COLLEGES. FOLLOWING THE PROJECT
OR OR- IN MAY OF TWENTY. THE
GOVERNOR LEGISLATURE TICKETS
ACTION MAKE IT VERY TO GROW.
REQUIREMENTS ALL SHE HAS USED
THROUGH PASSAGE OF THE FAMILY
BILL OR YOU THANK YOU I USUALLY
FALLING THE PAST ABOUT DISPLAY.
OUR OFFICE COMMUTER. IN
PASCAGOULA. ON OUR FUTURE
CREEPER. PATHWAY COMMUNICATED
WITH THE C. YOU SURE OR CALL AN
ACADEMIC SENATE TO DEVELOP A
SHARED THE THING ON HOW I THINK
BUT IT COULD BE. INTO WORKING
EDUCATION BURKE. BOB INCOME.
LEVY FOR SIXTY. ONE AND STATE
OF OUR COLLEGE ADMITTED COURSE.
YEAH YOU OR CARRILLO AND
REMAINING NON A CALL WILL HAVE
OPPORTUNITY FOR A BETTER COURSE
RULED ALL. AND- DESPITE OUR
WORK DID. AS I CAN REMEMBER
WORK YOUR- THE RODRIGUEZ SAYS
THAT HE'D BE HE JUST YOUR
REQUIRE ONLY TARGETING. OF THE
COMMUTER COLLEGE POPULATION
WHICH COULD RESULT IN NEXT WEEK.
WE'RE NOT ON A. WHICH IS
ANOTHER NOTED WORKERS FORMALLY
APPROVED BY OUR BOARD OF
GOVERNORS ON MONDAY RECEIVED
WIDESPREAD SUPPORT. AND THEY'RE
VERY SIMILAR TO FAMILY AND
FORTY IN. THE WAY IT WELL YOU
CAN FORTY MAKE. BUT IT'S A
GRADUATION REQUIREMENT FIRST.
ARMORED BEGINNING IN TWENTY
TWENTY FOUR TWENTY FIVE WE DO
ANTICIPATE ALL HUNDRED FIFTEEN
OF OUR GOVERNMENT CALLED IT
WILL BE MEETING. THE
REQUIREMENTS OF THE REGULATIONS
BY TWENTY TWENTY THREE TWENTY
FOUR. ADDITIONALLY OUR STUDIES
FACULTY COUNCIL IN OUR ECONOMIC
THAT ARE WORKING FIFTY S. U. S.
B. HELLO COURSE OUTLINES FOR
EVERYBODY BECAUSE THAT CAN BE
IMPLEMENTED IN COMMUNITY
COLLEGES. AND I WANT ALSO
HIGHLIGHT THE TRANSFER LEVEL.
COURSES WILL BE OFFERED THROUGH
OUR CALIFORNIA VIRTUAL CAMPUS.
APART FROM ALLOW STUDENTS TO
ENROLL IN ONLINE COMMUNITY
COLLEGE COURSESOFFERED BY
OTHER COMMUNITY COLLEGES
OUTSIDE OF THEIR IMMEDIATE
PICTURE TO CERTAIN AREA. WE
BELIEVE THAT THESE ACTIONS WILL
MAKE AFFORDABILITY
REQUIREMENTS- CALL. FORTY AND
FORTY. YOUR CALL IS ALREADY.
ETHNIC STUDIES COURSE. AND
IMPLEMENTING VERY. WE WILL WORK
AND BEING A- TO COMPETITIVE
MISSION ABOUT THIRTY. THE GOAL.
OF THE TO BE COURSES AT
TRANSFERRED OF BOTH THE USED AN
TO SEE A YEAR. JUST TO READ A-
NOT SURE OR NOT CHAMPASAK HAS
BEEN OVER. YOUR CALL ALL.
EIGHTY FOR. PHOTO LEGISLATOR
BECAUSE CONFUSION HER STUDENTS
AND OBVIOUSLY OF A ANY EFFORT
THAT COULD RESULT IN THE-
FUNDING TO OUR CALL. FACULTY
DESPITE THE- WE VERY OF POINT
SIX MILLION THANK IN REPORT
COULD THE BUDGET COMMITTEE HE
THE CONCLUSION OF THE COMMUTER
COLLEGE BUT THE GOVERNOR BUT IF
YOU'RE- WILL. BE GONE MOST A
GREAT YOU CAN YOUR EYES FOR ONE
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME IN.
HAVE BEEN ANSWERING QUESTIONS
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WE KNOW
WILL GO TO FOR IN OFF. HERE AND
FOR TWO OF. C. NO ONE WILL GO
TO OUR OVERFLOW ROOM SAYING NO
ONE WILL COME BACK TO THE PHONE
LINES MODERATED WITH ANYONE WHO
WISHES TO QUEUE UP IN
OPPOSITION. OF AB TEN FORTY.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR WHAT IS
AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO
SEE ENOUGH OF AB TEN FOR. ONE
THEN ZERO. AN OPERATOR WILL
PROVIDE YOU WITH YOUR LINE
NUMBER AND PLACE YOU BACK INTO
Q. ONCE AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF AB ONE
ZERO FOUR ZERO. PLEASE PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO NOW. WELL MY
MANAGER WE DO HAVE PEOPLE
QUEUING UP. ONE NUMBER ONE
SEVENTY ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. YOUR HONOR YES.
MY HAIR I'M SORRY GETTING TO
KNOW THE CUTE LITTLE BETTER I'M
YES I AM TOTALLY OPPOSED THAT
AB I THANK AND IT IT CHANGES
THE HISTORY THE NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. THANK YOU SO NOTED NEXT
CALLER THANK YOU. THANK YOU MY
NUMBER ONE NINETEEN YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY
NAME'S KAREN COOPER AND I'M
SPEAKING AS A MOTHER OF TWO
YOUNG CHILDREN AT THE PUBLIC
SCHOOL TEACHER AND I AM
REQUESTING AN OPPOSITION THAT
ASPECT OF YOURSELF. THANK YOU.
ONCE AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION OF AB TEN FORTY
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO.
THAT'S ONE ZERO TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION OF AB TEN FORTY. MY
NUMBER ONE SEVENTY ONE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
YES I'D LIKE MY FULL MOMENT
PLEASE. I'M THE CHANGES THAT
HISTORY AND IT'S- THANK YOU
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. BUT THIS
TIME ITEMS HERE WE HAVE NO ONE
ELSE CAN QUEUE GREAT THANK YOU
VERY MUCH ALL RIGHT WE'LL BRING
IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE- I DID
I JUST WANT TO SAY TO THE
AUTHOR I'D APPRECIATE HOW
RESPECTFUL YOU HAVE BEEN AND
WORKING WITH THE WITH YOU ON
THIS I KNOW IT'S A TOUGH ISSUE
I DID WANT TO ADDRESS A COUPLE
OF THINGS THAT THE- CHANCELLOR
SAID. THE BOARD OF GOVERNORS
VOTED UNANIMOUSLY AS SHE SAID
ASSEMBLY MEMBER AND THAT'S
REALLY WHAT WE WANT OUR COLLEGE
AND SCHOOL SYSTEMS TO DO RIGHT
TO COME BY THIS NATURALLY INTO
THE RIGHT THING AND IF I'M
CORRECT I BELIEVE THAT THAT
WILL ACTUALLY GO INTO EFFECT
ONE YEAR EARLIER THAN IF THIS
BILL WERE SIGNED BY THE
GOVERNOR I ALSO DO UNDERSTAND
THAT THE VOTE DIRECTED THE BOG.
TO WORK WITH THE CHANCELLOR'S
TO ENSURE ALIGNMENT WITH THE C.
ISSUES IN REGARD AB FOURTEEN
SIXTY ODD DR WEBER'S BILL. THAT
WE VOTED ON AND SENT TO THE
GOVERNOR'S DESK BECAUSE THE
ACADEMIC SENATE HAD VOTED THREE
YEARS EARLIER TO- INSTITUTE A
PROGRAM AND ETHNIC STUDIES AND
THEY NEVER DID IT SO
UNFORTUNATELY THE LEGISLATURE
HAD TO GET INVOLVED AND MAKE
THEM DO IT IN THIS CASE THE
BOARD OF GOVERNORS DID THE
RIGHT THING AND- AND THAT'S
VERY EXCITING AND WE'RE HAPPY
ABOUT THAT. SO I'M GOING TO BE
LAYING OFF THE BILL TODAY- BUT
I WOULD LIKE TO OPEN IT UP FOR
ANYONE ON OUR COMMITTEE. WHO
WISHES TO SPEAK ON THE BILL.
OKAY SEEING ONE. HOW WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE ASSEMBLY MEMBER.
GEN MADAM CHAIR I. COMPLETELY
RESPECT YOUR THOUGHTFUL
HANDLING OF THIS ISSUE- BUT I
THINK OF YOU'VE HEARD FROM THE
WITNESSES THAT THE CALLERS AS
WELL AS FOR MYSELF YOU KNOW
THAT THAT- EDUCATION HAS THE
POWER TO CHANGE LIVES WE HAVE
AN OPPORTUNITY TO DEMONSTRATE
THE LEGISLATURE'S SUPPORT NOT
JUST THE CALIFORNIA
COMMUNICATIVE BOARD OF
GOVERNORS SUPPORT FOR ETHNIC
STUDIES- AND OUR- LARGEST AND
MOST DIVERSE TO. A SYSTEM OF
HIGHER EDUCATION. WITH THAT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE THANK YOU VERY MUCH DO WE
HAVE A MOTION. ALL RIGHT WE DO
NOT HAVE A MOTION SO THE BILL
DIES FOR LACK OF A MOTION THANK
YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER. MEMBERS
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHAO I AM SO
SORRY YOU'RE HERE WAITING FOR
WE'RE GOING TO RESET WAIT MY
VICE CHAIR IS BACK. ALL I HAVE
TO GO VOTE IN B. M. P. SO I'M
GOING TO HAND IT OVER TO. THE
SENATOR- CHAU BOGUE TO CHAIR
OUR LAST BILL WHICH IS. ITEM
THIRTEEN A. B. FIFTEEN FORTY
SIX. SENATOR WILL GET YOU ALL
THE INFORMATION THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. IF.
GOOD MORNING ASSEMBLY
MEMBER CHALLENGE WELCOME PLEASE
PROCEED WITH PRESENTING AB
FIFTY FORTY SIX PLEASE THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MADAM AND
SENATORS AB FIFTEEN FORTY SIX
WOULD PERMIT THE CITY OF
ALHAMBRA NDL HAMBURG UNIFIED
SCHOOL DISTRICT TO CONDUCT A
SPECIAL ELECTION IN ORDER TO
PROCEED WITH ITS TRANSITION
FROM AT LARGE TO BY TRUSTEE
AREA ELECTIONS FOR MEMBERS OF
THE BOARD OF EDUCATION IN ORDER
TO COMPLY WITH THE CALIFORNIA
VOTING RIGHTS ACT OF TWO
THOUSAND AND ONE. DURING THE
NOVEMBER THIRD TWENTY TWENTY
GENERAL ELECTION MEASURE G.
WHICH APPEAR ON THE BALLOT
SOUGHT TO REMOVE FROM THE CITY
CHARTER ALL REFERENCES TO THE
ALHAMBRA UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT HOWEVER MR G. ONLY
APPEAR ON THE BALLOT SO VOTERS
RESIDING IN THE CITY OF
ALHAMBRA AND NOT ON THE BALLOT
SO VOTERS YOU KNOW HAMMER
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT WHO
RESIDE OUTSIDE OF THE CITY'S
BOUNDARIES UNDER EXISTING LAW
THE CHARTER AMENDMENT FOR CITY
MUST BE SUBMITTED TO VOTERS HAD
AN ESTABLISHED STATEWIDE
GENERAL ELECTION. THEREFORE UP
THE CITY OF ALL HAMBRE AND THE
U. S. A. U. S. A. U. S. T.
WHICH IS THE SCHOOL DISTRICT
ARE PROHIBITED FROM CONDUCTING
A SPECIAL ELECTION TO AMEND THE
CHARTER. PRIOR TO THE NEXT
STATEWIDE ELECTION ON NOVEMBER
EIGHTH TWENTY TWENTY TWO. HOURS
AS SUCH WE NEED TO CREATE A
SPECIAL EXCEPTION AND THE
GOVERNMENT CODE TO PERMIT THE
CITY OF EL HAMBRE AND THE
SCHOOL DISTRICT TO CONDUCT A
SPECIAL ELECTION BEFORE THE
NEXT STATEWIDE GENERAL
ELECTION. TO ACHIEVE THIS I
HEALTH AT IT AND- JUST A COST
TO THIS VERY IMPORTANT DISTRICT
BUILT SO WITHOUT I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE. I
BELIEVE I HAVE TWO WITNESSES TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
YES WE HAVE ON RECORD AT LEAN
LOGAN. AND JOHN OF THAT SALT DO
WE HAVE THE LOGIN ONLINE. YES
GOOD AFTERNOON THANK YOU- MADAM
VICE CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS DEAN LOGAN
AND I'M THE REGISTRAR RECORDER
COUNTY CLERK FOR LOS ANGELES
COUNTY TESTIFYING TODAY ON
BEHALF OF OUR BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS. WE APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO ADDRESS THE
COMMITTEE ABOUT THE IMPORTANCE
OF AB FIFTEEN FORTY SIX AND
WANT TO THANK ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CHAO FOR AUTHORING AS WELL AS
THE ALL HUMBER UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT IN THE CITY OF
ALHAMBRA FOR CO SPONSORING THE
BILL WITH LOS ANGELES COUNTY.
OKAY AB FIFTEEN FORTY SIX
SUPPORT THE EFFORTS AND INTENT
OF THE ALHAMBRA UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT TO ESTABLISH DISTRICT
BASED ELECTIONS BOARD
STRATEGIES ALIGNED TO THE FAIR
AND DISTRIBUTED REPRESENTATION
PROVISIONS OF THE CALIFORNIA
VOTING RIGHTS ACT. ADDITIONALLY
AB FIFTEEN FORTY SIX ADDRESS IS
A UNIQUE SITUATION WHERE
OUTDATED REFERENCES TO THE
SCHOOL DISTRICT IN THE CITY OF
ALHAMBRA CHARTER CONFLICT WITH
THE DISTRICT ACTION TO ADOPT
THE TRUSTEE AREA ELECTION
MODEL. EIGHTY FIFTEEN FORTY SIX
WOULD ENABLE THE CITY OF
ALHAMBRA CONDUCTED SPECIAL
ELECTION ON ANY ESTABLISH
FLEXION DATE ASPECT ABOUT IN
THE ELECTION CODE THEREBY
ALLOWING THE DISTRICT TO
PROCEED WITH THE TRANSITION
FROM AT LARGE TO CUT DEBATE
AREA. ALEXION'S CONSISTENT BOTH
WITH BOTH THE ELECTIONS AND THE
EDUCATION CODE REQUIREMENTS AS
THEY ORIGINALLY INTENDED. BASED
ON THE UNIQUE CIRCUMSTANCES AND
THE LEGISLATIVE INTENT OF THE
CALIFORNIA VOTING RIGHTS ACT
FOR FERRON DISTRIBUTED
REPRESENTATION THE COUNTY LOS
ANGELES RESPECTFULLY. ASK YOUR
AYE VOTE THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH AMIL THE NEXT.
WITNESS IS A JONATHAN SOLD. ARE
YOU ON THE LINE. YES IT DOES
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM VICE CHAIR
HE MEMBERS OF THIS COMMITTEE MY
NAME SHOT HIMSELF IN THE
MILITARY AT THE EDUCATION OFFER
MISTAKEN CRIMINAL CROSS. OUR
FIRM REPRESENTS THE ALHAMBRA
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT IN LOS
ANGELES COUNTY. DISTRICT IN
CLOSE COLLABORATION WITH THE
COUNTY OF LOS ANGELES AND CITY
OF ALHAMBRA IS PLEASED TO CO
SPONSOR AB FIFTEEN FORTY SIX.
YELLOWHAMMER CITY CHARTER
CURRENTLY GOVERNS THE SCHOOL
DISTRICT ELECTIONS AND OTHER
CONDITIONAL SCHOOL BOARD
FUNCTIONS BOB REQUIRING THE USE
OF AT LARGE ELECTION METHOD.
WHICH CARTER ALSO IMPOSES
REQUIREMENTS RELATED TO
TRACKING TERMS IN OFFICE. AND
SHE IS AND HOW WHERE TO FILE.
PAPERWORK THAT IS DIFFERENT
FROM STATE LAW DID NOT APPLY
THE VAST MAJORITY OF OTHER
SCHOOL DISTRICTS ACROSS
CALIFORNIA. A DIFFICULT
TRANSITION TO A DISTRICT OR
TRUSTEE AREA BASED ELECTION
SYSTEM TO ENSURE COMPLIANCE
WITH THE CALIFORNIA VOTING
RIGHTS ACT. AND TO BE TREATED
IN ALL OTHER ASPECTS LIKE MOST
OTHER SCHOOL DISTRICTS IN THE
STATE. IN NOVEMBER TWENTY
TWENTY AT THE DISTRICT'S
REQUEST. THE CITY PLACE THE
MEASURE ON THE BALLOT TO REMOVE
ALL REFERENCES TO THE DISTRICT
IN THE CITY CHARTER. SHE LATER
ACTION THE COUPLE THE DISTRICT
FROM THE CITY CHARTER.
UNFORTUNATELY DUE TO A COUNTY
CLERICAL ERROR. THE BALLOT
MEASURE WAS ONLY AVAILABLE TO
CITY RESIDENTS AND NOT ALL
DISTRICT RESIDENTS AS REQUIRED.
ADAPTION OF AB FIFTEEN FORTY
SIX WOULD COMMIT THE CITY AT
LEAST IDENTICAL MEASURE ON THE
BALLOT THE SENATE THIS
NOVEMBER. AND IF APPROVED ALLOW
THE DISTRICT A COMPLETE
SELECTION TRANSITION THE TIMELY
MATTER. AND HOLD AN ELECTION
THROUGH THE COUNTY. NOCTURNA
CITY AS IS CURRENTLY REQUIRED
EVEN THOUGH APPROXIMATELY HALF
OF DISTRICT RESIDENTS. OUTSIDE
OF THE CITY ABOUT IRAQ. THE
COUNTY CITY AND DISTRICT ARE IN
SYNC AS CO SPONSORS AND URGED
THE COMMITTEES I'D GO ON AB
FIFTEEN FORTY SIX THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. WE WILL
NOW MOVE TO WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT OF AB FIFTEEN FORTY SIX
HERE IN ROOM FORTY TWO OR THREE.
C. NINE. ARE THERE ANY
WITNESSES IN ROOM TWENTY FORTY
TWO WE SHOULD TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF AB FIFTEEN FORTY
SIX. SEEING NONE THANK YOU WILL
NOW MOVE ON TO WITNESSES
WANTING TO TESTIFY AT THE
TELECONFERENCE ORVIS- MODERATE
IF YOU WOULD PLEASE PROMPT
INDIVIDUALS WILLING TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT OF AB FIFTEEN FORTY
SIX WILL BEGIN. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF
YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF
AB FIFTEEN FORTY SIX. PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO. AN OPERATOR
WILL PROVIDE YOU WITH YOUR LINE
NUMBER AND PUT YOU BACK INTO Q.
ONCE AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OF AB FIFTEEN FORTY
SIX. PLEASE PRESS ONE BEEN
THERE- NOW. THANK YOU MODERATOR
LINE NUMBER TWO SIXTY ONE THANK
YOU MANAGER. SORRY JUST ONE
NUMBER TWO SIXTY ONE YOUR LINE
pTHANKS REPRESENTING THE LOS
ANGELES COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS PROUD CO SPONSOR
AND THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME. MY
NUMBER NINETY FIVE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS JOHNNY CANNELLA ON
BEHALF OF THE TV OF OFCOM BROWN
IN SAPPORO A. B. EIGHTEEN FORTY
SIX THANK YOU. WHY NUMBER
EIGHTY THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. NUMBER EIGHTY
THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. MAYBE
YOU'RE A NEW LINE NUMBER EIGHTY
THREE. ONCE AGAIN IF YOU WANT
TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF AB
FIFTEEN FORTY SIX CONTRACT ONE
THEN ZERO. THAT'S ONE ZERO TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF AB. FIFTEEN
FORTY SIX. AND AT THIS TIME AND
I'M SURE WE HAVE NO ONE ELSE
THANK YOU. FOR THANK YOU VERY
MUCH REMOVED OPPOSITION WE HAVE
NO LEAD OPPOSITION SO GO TO
ANYONE IN FORTY TWO OH THREE
SAYING NO ONE WILL GO TO OUR
OVERFLOW ROOM SCENE NO ONE.
SORRY ARAMBULA NOT IS NOT IN AS
GOOD A SHAPE AS I THOUGHT I WAS-
MODERATOR WE HAVE ANYONE
KEEPING UP WHO WOULD LIKE TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION AB FIFTEEN
FORTY SIX. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF
YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
OF AB FIFTEEN FORTY SIX POINT
FIVE ONE ZERO. AN OPERATOR WILL
PROVIDE YOU WITH THE LINE
NUMBER AND PLACE YOU BACK INTO
Q. ONCE AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF AB.
FIFTEEN FORTY SIX PLEASE PRESS
ONE THAN THEIR OWN NOW. AND AT
THE TIME AND I'M SURE WE HAVE
NO ONE IN Q. THANK YOU HAVE A
MODERATOR ART WILL BRING IT
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE DOES
ANYONE HAVE ANY QUESTIONS
COMMENTS OR CONCERNS. ALL HAS
BEEN MOVED ASSEMBLY MEMBER
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE AYE
ASTORIA AYE VOTE THANK YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THE BILL
HAS BEEN MOVED BY SENATOR
GLAZERS. MADAM CONSULTANT
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. FILE ITEM
NUMBER THIRTEEN AB FIFTEEN
FORTY SIX THE MOTION IS TO PASS
SENATOR LEYVA HI LEVEL I WOULD
SHOW ABOVE I. TROUBLED AYE
COURTESY AYE COURTESY AYE DALY.
GLAZER GLAZER AYE MCGUIRE.
ACQUIRE I'D PAN. PAN I. A GOOD
THAT BILL HAS ENOUGH TO GET OUT
BUT WE'LL LEAVE IT OPEN FOR OUR
ABSENT MEMBERS THANK YOU
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CENTERS. ALL
RIGHT MEMBERS WE ARE GOING TO
OPEN THE ROLE ON BILLS- MADAM
CONSULTANT LET'S START WITH THE
CONSENT CALENDAR PLEASE.
CONSENT TO VOTING ON A VICE
CHAIR VOTING I SENATOR GLAZERS.
GLAZER AYE MCGUIRE MCGUIRE I
SEVEN ZERO THE CONSENT
CALENDARS SEVEN TWO ZERO WILL
NOW GO TO FILE ITEM NUMBER ONE
AB ONE OH ONE FILE ITEM NUMBER
ONE AB ONE OH ONE THE MOTION IS
TO PASS AS AMENDED THE FIRST
AMENDED AND RE REFER TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
CHAIR VOTING ON A VICE CHAIR
VOTING NO THE CURRENT VOTE IS
THREE TO TWO. SENATOR GLAZERS.
GLAZER NOT VOTING CENTER
MCGUIRE. MCGUIRE AYE THAT BILLS
OUT FORTY TWO THANK YOU WE WILL
NOW GO TO FILE ITEM NUMBER TWO
A. B. NINE TWENTY SEVEN. FILE
ITEM NUMBER TWO A. B. NINE
TWENTY SEVEN THE MOTION IS TO
PASS AS AMENDED THE FIRST
AMENDED AND RE REFER TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS.
CHAIR VOTING NINE VICE CHAIR
VOTING I CURRENT VOTE FIVE
ZERO. SENATOR GLAZERS. GLAZER
AYE MCGUIRE. REQUIRED BY. THE
BILL'S OUT SEVEN ZERO. FILE
ITEM NUMBER THREE AB FOURTEEN
FIFTY SIX. FILE ITEM NUMBER
THREE AB FOURTEEN FIFTY SIX THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED.
BUT FIRST AMEND AND RE REFER TO
THE COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
CHAIR VOTING ON A VICE YOU'RE
VOTING ON A CURRENT VOTE FIVE
ZERO. SENATOR GLAZERS. GLAZER
AYE MCGUIRE. MCGUIRE AYE THAT
BILLS OUT SEVEN ZERO FILE ITEM
NUMBER FOUR AB FOUR SIXTY NINE.
FILE ITEM NUMBER FOR A BEFORE
SIXTY NINE THE MOTION IS TO
PASS BUT FIRST BE REFERRED TO
THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS. CHAIR VOTING ON
ADVISED HER VOTING ONLINE. VOTE
IS THREE ZERO SENATOR DOLLY.
DALY AYE GLAZER GLAZER AYE
MCGUIRE. MCGUIRE AYE PAN HI
COUNTY THAT BILLS OUT SEVEN
ZERO FILE ITEM NUMBER FIVE AB
FIVE TWENTY. FILE ITEM NUMBER
FIVE AB FIVE TWENTY THE MOTION
IS TO PASS BUT FIRST BE
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS CHAIR VOTING ON%
A VICE CHAIR VOTING I CURRENT
VOTE IS FOUR ZERO. SENATOR
GLAZERS. GLAZER ALRIGHT
MCGUIRE. MCGUIRE AYE PAN HI CAN
I THAT FILLS OUT SEVEN ZERO
FIVE OUT FILE ITEM SIX AB FIVE
FORTY FIVE. FILE ITEM NUMBER
SIX AB FIVE FORTY FIVE THE
MOTION IS TO PASS BUT FIRST BE
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS. CHAIR VOTING
ONLINE BY SURE VOTING NO THE
CURRENT VOTE IS TO. SENATOR
GLAZERS. GLAZER NOT VOTING
SENATOR MCGUIRE MCGUIRE AYE PAN
PAN HI THAT BILLS OUT FORTY TWO
FILE ITEM NUMBER EIGHT AB NINE
TWENTY EIGHT WELL NUMBER EIGHT
A. B. NINE TWENTY EIGHT THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
BUT FIRST AMEND AND RE REFER TO
THE COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
CHAIR VOTING ONLINE VICE CHAIR
HAS NOT VOTED CURRENT VOTE FOUR
ZERO CENTER OCHO ALTHOUGH I OF
CHOI DOG I MCGUIRE. MCGUIRE AYE
PAN AYE PAN AYE THAT BILLS OUT.
SEVEN ZERO. HE COULD GET OVER.
REMOVE THE FILE ITEM THIRTEEN
AB FIFTEEN FORTY SIX PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS FILE
ITEM NUMBER THIRTEEN AB FIFTEEN
FORTY SIX THE MOTION IS DUE
PASS CHAIR VOTING ON A VICE
TRIGGERING ON A CURRENT VOTE
SIX ZERO SENATOR DOLLY. KELLY I
BILLS OUT SEVEN ZERO THANK YOU
EVERYONE I'D LIKE TO THANK ALL
OF OUR MEMBERS THIS IS OUR LAST
HEARING OF THE YEAR THANK YOU.
FOR YOUR DILIGENCE I
APPRECIATED I ALSO WANT TO
THANK US THE REPUBLICAN STAFFER
ALWAYS WORKING SO WELL WITH US-
IT MAKES OUR JOB A LOT EASIER
THANK YOU AND THANK YOU TO ALL
INDIVIDUALS WHO PARTICIPATED
IMPROVE OUR PUBLIC TESTIMONY
TODAY IF YOU WERE NOT ABLE TO
TESTIFY TODAY PLEASE SUBMIT
YOUR COMMENTS OR SUGGESTIONS IN
WRITING TO THE SENATE EDUCATION
COMMITTEE OR VISIT OUR WEBSITE.
YOUR COMMENTS AND SUGGESTIONS
ARE IMPORTANT TO US AND WE WANT
TO INCLUDE YOUR TESTIMONY AND
THE OFFICIAL HEARING RECORDS
THANK YOU AND WE APPRECIATE
YOUR PARTICIPATION THANK YOU
EVERYONE ALSO FOR YOUR PATIENCE
AND COOPERATION WE HAVE
CONCLUDED THE AGENDA THE SENATE
COMMITTEE. ON EDUCATION IS NOW
ADJOURNED.